So Leute, ich bin gleich am Start
Bin gleich da
Ich hab jetzt bloß schon mal Stream angemacht
Dass Twitch das kapiert hat, bis um 17 Uhr
Wenn es dann losgeht
Jetzt kann ich mal raussuchen, wo der Kram eigentlich läuft
Wahrscheinlich Twitch
Twitch Xbox oder so, gehe ich mal von aus
Und 3D
The fuck, die gibt es noch
Was ist da los
Hab mal, ja
Hier, wahrscheinlich hier, gehe ich mal von aus
Wow, ja, hier
Ah, 13 Minuten
Oh nice, man kann direkt jetzt
Gut, das ging glaube ich schon immer
Wir werden aber normalerweise halt kein Kram
Da sehe ich das nicht
Okay, ähm
Ja, also, ich bin gleich am Start
Ich muss halt was zu trinken holen
Und das andere wollt ihr nicht wissen
Muss mich hier mich noch anziehen
Weil ich war gerade duschen
Und ich hab gedacht, ich muss jetzt Stream anmachen
Bis das, dass das auch alles läuft
Bis es losgeht
Mixer, Mixer, Alter
Ihr fahrt
Mixer
Inside Xbox
Das ist ein Anspieler
Nein, Leute, das ist nicht
Warum ist der, warum ist der Champ so groß
Champ Box
Easy Box
Easy Box, hört sich an wie was von Unity Media
Nice
Das, oh, der passt gut
Der passt gut
Happy Box
Okay, Leute, ich bin gleich da
Was zu trinken holen
Kurz paar Socken anziehen
Wieder am Start
Ähm
Wisst ihr, was mir eingefallen ist?
Ich hatte doch vor ein paar
Ah, warte mal
Kirby, Kirby muss mal kurz
Kirby muss mal kurz gemutet werden
Wow
Ich kann mir schon mal die Lautstärke vom Xbox Stream einstellen
Ähm, mir ist eingefallen
Ich hatte doch vor
Vor einem Jahr oder so
Als wir uns E3 angeguckt haben
Hatte ich so nen Bullshit
So nen Bullshit-Counter oben rechts in der Ecke
Und, ähm, wo ist denn der hin?
Ich hab das Programm dazu nicht mehr
Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie ich das gemacht hab mit dem Bullshit-Counter
Leute, wir müssen in neun Minuten nen neuen Bullshit-Counter programmieren
Meint ihr, das kriegen wir hin?
Oder aber wir machen's mit OBS
Ne, wir machen das, wir machen's mit OBS
Äh, wartet mal, wartet mal, wie machen wir das am besten?
Wie machen wir das am besten?
Ähm, wie machen wir das am besten?
Wie krieg ich, wie krieg ich nen Bullshit-Counter jetzt am besten oben hin?
Äh, ich glaube, OBS ist am besten
Ne, ne, wir haben kein, wir haben kein Bullshit
Ja, ne Windows Forms alleine bringt mir ja nix
Ich muss das Ding ja auch irgendwie fernsteuern können
Kann OBS Textdateien einlesen?
Okay, Leute, wir probieren das jetzt mal ganz schnell
Ähm
Alter, okay
Hahaha, mal gucken
Okay, ähm
Bullshit-Counter schnell programmieren, okay
OBS kann Textdateien einlesen
Echt, echt?
Okay, Moment
Äh, ähm
Text
Ne
Wo denn?
Wie geht denn das?
Weiß das jemand?
Text, Text einlesen
Browser
Ich mach nen Browser und einfach auf HTML, was ich selbst aktualisiert, hä?
Moment
OBS read text file
Geht das?
Text from file
Add text
Create
Okay, okay
Okay, ähm
Bullshit-Counter
Ah, read vom File, perfekt
Perfekt
Machen wir ein File hin, hier irgendwie
Mega-Luddel
Da ist jetzt null drinnen
Ah, sehr schön, sehr schön
Sehr schön, ah, das gefällt mir
Da müssen wir doch nicht selbst programmieren
Da bin ich froh, dass wir das hier hinklatschen müssen
Ähm, ah, funktioniert
Okay, da müssen wir noch Bullshit-Counter oder so hinschreiben
Oder nennen wir es, wie nennen wir es denn?
Ähm, ähm, Amazing-Counter
Nee, Super-Excited
Haha
BS-Counter
Ähm
Okay, da liest den Kram auch wieder ein, sehr schön, sehr schön
Schriftgröße
Wir machen mal die Schriftgröße
Vielleicht Font, einfach den fettesten Font, den es gibt
Yeah
Und jetzt brauchen wir noch
Übrigens, danke für die Subs
Ich hab's gesehen, vorhin war schon einer, der...
Spread the Beast, Dankeschön, Twitch Prime, POG, Alter
Und jetzt haben wir hier nochmal den, ähm...
Den Twitch Mason, auch hier, POG
Nein, ich drück das Falsche
Nice
So, dass man den Counter einrichtet, okay, der Counter ist jetzt da oben in der Ecke
So machen wir das jetzt am besten
BS-Counter ist zu lang
Wenn er jetzt einfach... Bingo
So, dann machen wir nochmal schnell eine andere Schrift
Eine andere Schrift
Irgendwas, ein bisschen Outline oder sowas
Kann das Ding denn Outline?
Outline, perfekt
Outline Color
Machen wir mal schwarz, dass es schön hervorsticht
Machen wir mal schwarz, dass es schön hervorsticht, genau
Outline Size noch ein bisschen größer
Sehr schön
Das erkennt man jetzt ganz gut, denke ich, oder?
Wow
Hab ich jetzt gemacht, Alter
Cool
Das ist POG, Alter
Ja, dann Clips mal
Clips mal
Clips mal und nenn es irgendwie Subscriber Sound
Da kann ich es mir nachher nochmal anhören
Der Milchmann, Dankeschön, zwei Monate
Okay, wir haben noch fünf Minuten Zeit
Okay, äh, Dankeschön, Milchmann
Subscriber
Okay, Bingo
Jetzt muss ich mir nur noch überlegen
Wenn ich jetzt OBS weg hab
Und ich pass die Textdatei an
Das kann ich ja hier irgendwie hinmachen
So, aktualisiert das jetzt?
Einfach so, von alleine?
Ah, sehr schön, POG
Also richtig, richtig nice wäre es jetzt natürlich
Wenn ich das auf dem Netzlaufwerk hätte
Dass ich den Kram aus dem Netz
Vom anderen Rechner aus aktualisieren könnte
Da müsste ich nämlich gar nicht
Da müsste ich nämlich gar nicht rum
Rumwursten
Das machen wir jetzt
Ordner
Keine Ahnung
Share
Da kommt es rein
Dann fangen wir das hier schnell an
Wir haben ja immerhin noch vier Minuten Zeit
Share
Okay, ah, Alter
Das ist ja eine Kackfunktion
Wenn man Steuerung S drückt
Okay, ähm
Sharing
Share
Ist mir doch vollkommen egal
Wie shared man das unter Windows?
Ich hab da keine Ahnung
Ich mach das zu selten
Choose
Shared
Oh ne, jetzt ist OBS wieder weg
Jetzt ist OBS wieder da
Ist der Kram jetzt geshared?
Okay
Windows, Windows gucken
Was hab ich für eine IP?
Ich sag dir Leute, es wird Punktland irgendwie das
Wenn das jetzt geht
Ah
Mein Backslash geht nicht
Warum geht mein Backslash nicht auf dem anderen Rechner?
Achso, weil es mir die indische Tastatur eingestellt hat
Äh
Das, das stellt manchmal indische, indische Tastatur ein
Ah
User, Stream
Desktop, Desktop, Desktop
So, und jetzt
Share, und jetzt gucken wir mal
Ob es die Datei aktualisiert, wenn ich die update
Nochmal 1 reinschreiben
Mal kurz warten
Ha, funktioniert
Nice, haben wir jetzt auf die, auf die Schnelle hingekriegt
Easy
Easy AF
Okay, Leute
Ich muss schon mal sagen, wir müssen uns auf ganz viel
Super excited, amazing stuff einstellen
Und achtet mal drauf
Ich hab ja so einen Trend erkannt dieses Jahr
Was die Pressekonferenzen angeht
Oh fuck, ich hab vergessen meinen Chat
Mein Chat-Log zu starten
Professional Stream, Deluxe heute
Ähm
Achtet mal drauf, ich hab eine Sache bei den Präsentationen
Dieses Jahr ausgemacht, ich mach gleich Fullscreen
Ähm
Und zwar, dass dieses, dass dieses Jahr
Weniger super excited und
Also es wird immer noch gelabert
Also es wird immer noch Bullshit gelabert
Aber, was dieses Jahr angesagt ist
Und damit hat, hat Apple so ein bisschen
Den Trend gesetzt, was bei Pressekonferenzen
Was abgeht, dass die Leute
Dass die Leute auf der Bühne mittlerweile
Die ganze Zeit sagen, yeah
Oder, oder, oder, wuuh
Oder irgendwie sowas, achtet mal drauf
Ich wette mit euch, das machen die hier auch so
Okay, ich hab noch 9 Sekunden Zeit
Schnell Chat-Log starten
Come on, Ryder, starte
Okay, dann starte ich
Alles klar, Fullscreen, geht los
Ihr müsst mir mal sagen, wie der Sound passt
Ich mach ein bisschen lauter
Was? Ah, Borderlands
Was? Neunte?
Dreizehnter? Neunter?
Ich hab's nicht gesehen
Die Lautstärke, okay
Ja
Vor allem Leute, die gerne 3 Stunden in der Schlange stehen
Die convergen da auch ziemlich
Kleinen Tick leiser, okay
Ich guck einfach mal, wie der Sound gerade ist
Ja
Das passt so
Siehste, das geht schon los
Ich sag's euch, das ist der Trend
Dieses Jahr, dass man sich selbst anfeuert
Yes
Right here in beautiful Cologne, Germany
Woooo
Muss man die Leute eigentlich kennen?
Wer ist das?
Die Musik ist vom Stream
Der Bingo-Counter, ich weiß nicht, wie ich's nennen soll
Ähm
Grinch-Counter
Nice
Wie sie sich feiern
Wie sie sich feiern die ganze Zeit, ey
I'm so excited to share it with all of you in the room
And I'm so excited to share it with all of you at home as well
Soon we'll be sitting down with Randy Varnell from Gearbox
To talk Borderlands 3
But in just a minute
But first of all
Let's kick this show off right
The way we kick shows off
Is with a world premiere trailer
Premiere
Let's do this
We've been practicing the premiere
It's the 90s found footage phenomenon
That revolutionized the horror genre
And single-handedly made Standing in the Corner
Super creepy
I mean, I feel like it was kind of creepy already, right?
Exclusive!
Right here on Inside Xbox
This is the latest trailer
For Blair Witch
War das nicht mal irgend so ein schlechter
Mit Handkameras gefilmter
There are mistakes we fear
And wrongs that haunt us
But the worst
Are the sins we choose to bear
To forget
Ellis to base
Bullet picked up a cent
Just like you
Sir, I'm not gonna screw this up
Not this time
You guys know
Ellis, I can't do this anymore
They mess with people
Listen to me
You're in no shape to play the hero
Hey, don't talk to me like I'm crazy
Did you see her?
Her eyes, did you see?
These words made me remember
Now there's no way back
But I genuinely don't think I can do it alone
If anyone out there can find me with some more support
Take me through that, hit me up on Twitter
Anyway, as a worldwide event like Gamescom
Brings fans face to face
With some of their favorite games
And do you know, Leah, what else does that?
I wanna say, Unicorn,
Maybe close
But like a mythical beast of burden
Xbox Game Pass delights fans of all ages
And today we are saddling up
A unicorn
Is this The Witcher 3?
For another big announcement
Since E3, more than 22 games
Have been added to the PC catalog
Including Shadow of War, Undertale
Blazing Chrome, Nightcall
And the Banner Saga 3
And that is right, you also told us
You want even more games
Because why wouldn't you?
A brand new group of games
Joining the Xbox Game Pass corral
Coming to Game Pass PC, Game Pass Console
And Game Pass Ultimate on August the 20th
Twitch chat muss noch lernen
Woman to respect Mia
Was hier los, Leute?
Ach
What would you do if a tyrannical medieval king
Murdered your entire family?
Was ist das Dings hier?
Alone?
Kingdom Come Dings?
Is das?
Ape out
The return of an iconic dungeon crawler
From the mind of Brian Fargo
And in exile entertainment
Bard's Tale 4
Rolls out to Game Pass on August 27th
And just three days later
Woah, was das?
Alter
Was war das gerade?
Das sah aus wie ein
Barb aus Diablo
Plus sick
And you won't have to, there's more
That's right, we've got
Three games launching into Xbox Game Pass
Today, that's today
So Age of Empires Definitive Edition
The best selling real time strategy game
Now in 4K
Is joining Game Pass PC
Was macht eigentlich Age of Empires 4?
Stellaris
The epic space 4X grand strategy game
And finally
If quick witted 60 frames per second
Combo tacit demon slaying
Is your jam
And why wouldn't it be?
Because, you know, are you dead inside?
Get ready to dust off that download button
Devil May Cry 5 joins
In the Game Pass 5
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
The last four aliens
For only two dollars
Two euros, two pounds, oh my
And while you're at it
Why don't you check out the newly updated
Xbox beta app for Windows
Find your Game Pass DC titles and DLC
All in one, Game Pass Ultimate
Gets you Game Pass for PC, Game Pass for
Xbox Live Gold
Including access to the Ultimate Edition
Of Gears 5, which includes
Four-Day Early Access
I mean, there's a lot of things that we're calling Ultimate
And the way I look at it, it's just even the name itself
It's like saying, do you want a taco
Or would you want the Ultimate Taco
Ultimate Taco
The Ultimate Taco, come on
It's clearly a lot better
Also since
Xbox E3
We've been listening closely to fans
On how to make the PC gaming experience
Even better
So check out the Xbox Wire
Right after the show for details on new updates
Which are gonna be coming very, very soon to you
But believe it or not
We are not done yet
Starting today, Dell Alienware Arena
Members can claim a free
30-day Xbox Game Pass PC
Beta code
And including Dell Alienware Arena members
Head over to the link below for more information
That's right, and lastly
We're nearly there, guys
We are happy to announce
That Human Fall Flat
The quirky physics-based puzzle platform
And Game Pass Classic title has new
A free DLC
For both PC and Console
Coming very, very soon
The Steam Update
On the free DLC
Why don't we check this out
Wir legen jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr Wert darauf
Dass es DLC gibt
Sondern müssen immer dazu sagen
Free
Früher waren das ganz normale Updates oder so
Aber heute ist Free
Free DLC
Ich wusste jetzt nicht, dass das so
Ein großer Hit war, dieses Game
Aber das ist ein bisschen besser abmischen
Gut, wir wollen
Wir sollen ja nicht immer so kritisch sein, Leute
Also, kann schon mal passieren
Ist Live-Veranstaltung
Das Spiel hab ich mal in Early Access irgendwo gesehen
Vor einem Jahr oder so
Hat null passiert
Wonka Smoke, ah
Die ist auch überall Steam
Aber mir ist
Das Original Steam ist bei mir
Oh Gott, wie sie lustig sein wollen
Das war auch ein richtig geiles Game
Ich, ich
laud wir sind mittlerweile schon
Bei 19 oder so
Das war auch ein super Game
Aber das war ein Game
Keine Ahnung, 98, 2000 rum, oder so
Rück
Il
Aktiv
Play Functionality, Cross-Steam and the Windows 10 Store.
Plus, did I mention, there's also a bonus campaign.
It's called The Last Kahn's and it includes four new civilizations.
So, all together, the games you're asking for came, all the expansions and their Steam-Cross-Play.
Did anyone else here order the Cheesesteak Jimmys?
Did you order it?
Oh Gott!
Es tut weh, es tut weh!
I'll be doing it in November, no.
Now, it's time to toss over to Benny, who might just have the cutest Gears of War assignment ever.
Benny, what's happening?
Charlie, I'm not gonna lie, it is the cutest thing in the world, but it's hard to tell, right?
If you're talking about me, right?
Oder...
Sag mal, ernst gemeinte Frage, ich will die nicht haten.
Wer, was sind das für Leute? Kennt man die?
Excited to announce that Gears of War will be available starting August 22nd.
Which is amazing. August 22nd, we're gonna get Gears of War.
Was?
This adorable free-to-play title will be available...
Wollen die mich verarschen?
Android. Drumroll, please.
Windows 10.
Plus, with game progress synced across all your devices with your Microsoft account,
some of us can finally realize our dream...
Habt ihr denn keine Handys, Leute?
...which they finally won't be able to tell me off for, which would be brilliant.
And fans of free stuff, right? Free stuff.
Alright, listen up. Make sure you're logged into your Microsoft account
and watch this fancy program on Mixer.com forward slash Xbox
to receive a free in-game Gears Pop Gamescom promotional pack
with an assortment of Gears of War.
Was?
Moment, ein in-game Gears Pop in-game?
Krieg ich da ne, ne, ne Pop, ne Gears Pop-Figur in-game?
Oder wie?
Okay, was auch immer.
Ich...
Mein Hirn schafft es gerade nicht. Ich, ich komm da nicht mit.
Ist das ein Sackboy?
Nee.
Das ist ein Locust.
Wie hieß der? Carmine oder so hieß der Typ, ne?
Der immer gestorben ist in Gears.
Die starten...
Die starten allen Ernstes als erstes Game mit nem...
Mit nem Gears Mobile?
Okay.
Ich darf nicht immer so viel flayen.
In Deutschland kennt den Typ kein Mensch.
Hier guckt kaum einer.
Wer guckt hier Basketball?
Da kannst du doch an einer Hand abzählen.
Es gibt ein paar, ja, aber...
Ja, ein Game, was dich sponsert.
Wie findest du es?
I have no idea.
Okay.
No idea.
Are you ready to hear what his overall rating is?
Please!
Boo!
76.
Nah.
Ist das besser als letztes Jahr?
Everyone boo.
No!
Everyone cheers.
Besser als...
Hä?
Yeah.
It's weird.
I don't know.
For me it gets...
I don't really care too much about it.
But 2K, I would like for it to be a little bit higher.
If you could just pass that on.
Yeah, I'll just pass it on to Ballas.
I played Hurt last year.
So I'm gonna do...
That's gonna be my excuse for myself.
And you still did better.
Yeah, you know, I got better.
So it's all about...
It's all about improvements every year, you know?
Exactly.
Man merkt richtig, wie Bock er hat, auf der Bühne zu sitzen.
No, that's the other.
That's a little different.
A little different.
So as a gamer yourself, like, what kind of games do you actually like playing?
What did you play growing up?
Growing up, I was a big Madden guy.
Madden and FIFA.
Those are the two games that really got me into it.
Then now, Fortnite.
I love playing Fortnite.
Do you play with any of your teammates?
A little bit.
I play with, like, Larry Nance Jr.,
who used to be with the Lakers.
And with the Cleveland Cavaliers now.
Fortnite, was sonst?
But now you need to sort of, like, you know, make your new friends.
Yeah, you know.
Aber gut, es ist halt angesagt, hat's halt, ne?
Yeah, I gotta get my new Pelican teammates into Fortnite.
Lonzo plays, apparently plays PUBG now,
so I'm gonna have to get him to switch over.
Ja, okay, wow.
I'm a big Fortnite guy, so I'm gonna have to see if he can do that.
Or maybe they'll switch you to PUBG, you don't know.
They might, they might.
Hair pressure is a big thing.
I played, I liked it, I liked it, don't get me wrong.
I did like it.
Ähm, but, I, I think the, the pro, the thing that happened with me,
I played Fortnite first.
Wollten die nicht über NBA oder so reden, über das Game?
And then, I'm not.
Jetzt reden sie über PUBG und Fortnite.
I think I was just, I was getting my butt kicked in, in PUBG,
when I first started.
Oh, I see, so that's why you just.
So I was like, ah, you know what, I gotta go back.
Okay, duly noted.
I do believe you actually got something for us.
You brought us a little, a little treat, a little trailer, I believe.
Yeah, no, so I'm very excited to introduce the first trailer
of the NBA 2K.
So sieht jemand aus, der very excited ist.
Merkt's euch, Leute.
Produced by LeBron James and SpringHill Entertainment.
Has a bunch of Hollywood star power, so I'm very excited about that.
Hope you guys are excited, ähm, about that trailer as I am
and that game as I am, so.
Oh, yes, well, thank you so much for joining us.
And in the immortal words of sportscaster WarnerWolf,
let's go to videotape, but don't press play,
because that's, no, it's the past.
Oh, there's a story mode.
It ain't easy watching your brother fall like that,
but hey, this is what we want.
You work for, all right?
Look, Jay, Coach took my scholarship, man.
I've been your advisor for four years.
Sportspiele-Story-Mode.
You gotta be willing to sacrifice.
There's a choice.
You chose to sit out.
I chose to stand up.
Whatever point you think you're making, son,
now is not the time.
You are the captain of this team.
Better act like it.
I believe I am, Coach.
Ist das jetzt der FIFA-Story-Mode,
oder ist das der NBA-Story-Mode, oder?
Weil der Typ sieht doch aus wie, wie, wie, wie,
wie?
Die hatten doch im, im, im,
im FIFA hatten die doch,
nee, das ist NBA, okay,
aber die hatten doch, die hatten doch im FIFA auch einen Story-Mode.
Der Typ sah doch genauso aus.
Der aus dem FIFA-Story-Mode.
Genau, der Hunter,
das sah nach diesem Thema so aus,
irgendwie.
Whoa, what's up, Kimber?
Are you ready to touch Earth?
Man, I ain't touching no Earth, man.
What's up?
Gentlemen, I'm your trainer for the next couple months.
These next few days,
he has a chance to really impress these guys.
The Mav handles all of,
all of LeBron's off-court opportunities.
If this ain't legendary, what you call it?
I'm not Dan Z,
it's time to put people on notice.
I want you to get out there and get us to start.
Vielleicht spielt er jetzt ja Bassgewalt.
Decisions, do it?
That's the anxiety, alright?
Use it.
Our success hinges on authenticity.
Boy, there we go,
looking just like you feel.
I'm really giving athletes a force to do cover.
Ich find's eigentlich gut,
dass es Story-Modes für Sportspiele gibt.
Weißt du, versteh den Hater drum nicht.
Er schließt einfach nochmal eine ganz andere Gruppe an Spielern.
Bad enough.
If you're willing to sacrifice,
it will find you.
I have a private fridge
stocked with kombucha in my trailer,
if you'd be interested.
Nah, I think we're good.
Yeah, we'll just catch you later.
We cool?
Okay.
Ja, gut.
Ja.
Sportspiele.
Ist halt nicht meins.
Ich hab's übrigens auch verwechselt.
NBA ist ja gar nicht EA.
Let's keep this gaming train a-moving
with another world premiere.
This time from the top.
Just a small title called
Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
Live the life of a true ghost
stranded behind enemy lines
in this latest installment
in the Ghost Recon franchise.
But of course,
we wouldn't just leave it there.
This is Inside Xbox after all.
So today, we're excited
to show you the first glimpse
into Ghost War,
the competitive multiplayer experience.
Check this out.
Ah, Experience zählt auch als Exciter.
Das ist nah dran.
When facing you, roll cut.
Your skills alone are not enough.
Oh, erst mal Ghillie Suit angezogen.
When the smoke clears,
they will be the last ones standing.
Target down.
Mit Drills im Multiplayer.
But in the heat of the battle.
Oh, Deckung, Deckung stellt.
It's only by working as a team
that you can rise.
By each and most, yeah.
It wasn't easy.
It was hard.
Es war schön.
Great Hiding Spots.
Einen abgekämmt.
Body Shot, One Hit.
Schon mal sehr balanced.
Ih, Battle Royale.
Geh mal fort.
Das war doch ein neulich Battle Royale, oder?
Dieses komische Ding,
was sich da zusammengezogen hat.
Breakpoint.
PvP Mode with intense tactical matches
and extensive shared progression system
and dedicated servers.
Moment.
Double plus bonus,
a Battle Royale-style circle
encruching on the battlefield.
Find out when Ghost War relaunches
on October the 4th
with the full game.
Plus, if you pre-order
Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon Breakpoint,
you get access to the beta
starting September the 5th.
Ich dachte erst,
das ist was für ein Spiel,
was es schon gibt.
Aber das kommt erst noch.
27.
Ich sag's euch, Leute.
Dieses Jahr ist sich selbst anfeuern
voll im Trend.
Ah, jetzt gibt's was Neues
zu Borderlands.
Wir werden uns für ein sehr, sehr seriöses Spiel
für ein sehr, sehr seriöses Spiel
machen.
Sehr seriös.
Ja? Bist du bereit?
Ja.
Okay, also das erste, was ich sagen muss,
ist für die Leute, die nicht so aufhören,
für die neue Borderlands-Serie zu warten,
was können wir von den Geschichten erwarten
und wo können neue Fans ihn aufhören?
Es ist seit sieben Jahren,
seit Borderlands 2.
Und Borderlands 3
ist eine Weiterentwicklung
von der Geschichte, die angefangen hat.
Eigentlich ist das der 10-jährige
Erlebnis des Releases von Borderlands 1.
Oh, glückliches Geburtstag.
Es kam 2009.
Ja, also das ist ein großes Ding.
Danke.
Also, Borderlands 3
hält auf diese Tradition.
Es ist eine Weiterentwicklung
der Geschichte.
Am Ende von Borderlands 2
hat er mit einem Map
der Sterne,
dem Vault-Map,
gesprochen,
über neue Plätze,
in denen die Vaults
über das Universum verbreitet werden.
Also, Borderlands 3
ist unser Spiel,
um in die Rolle
neuer Vault-Puncher
zu springen
und diese Vaults
über mehrere Planeten
im Universum
zu fressen.
Also, für das erste Mal
im Universum von Borderlands,
werden wir von Pandora
und anderen Plätzen
rauskommen
und die Tatsachen
dieser Secret-Alien-Serie
entdecken.
Ich glaube,
es sieht aus
wie Borderlands.
Ja, der war so excited.
Es zählt für zwei.
Das wissen wir schon.
Viele Leute lieben das.
Flak,
über den wir gerne
sprechen wollen,
ist eine pure
Pet-Klasse.
Flak hat eine Wahl
zwischen drei verschiedenen
Tiere,
die Flak nennen kann.
Er hat einen Jabber,
der ein Mönch ist
mit einer Waffe.
Es gibt auch
einen Spiderschwein
und einen Skag,
der...
Spiderschwein?
Wir können den Skag
fressen, nicht wahr?
Du kannst den Skag fressen.
Spiderschwein.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Du hast die Wahl,
welches Tier
du willst.
Und dann,
wie wir in
Borderlands 3
haben,
gibt es viele verschiedene
Möglichkeiten,
den Charakter
zu kustomisieren
und zu machen.
Du kannst nicht nur
welches Tier
du wählst,
aber auch
welches Aktions-Skill
du nutzt.
Flak hat einen,
bei dem du
den Tier
superchargen kannst.
Wenn die Tiere
was machen,
nennst du es
Gamma Burst.
Du kannst den Tier
aufwärmen.
Ja.
Borderlands 3,
also,
wenn man sich eins
und zwei anguckt,
dann ist es
so,
dass du
den Tier
aufwärmen kannst.
Ja.
sind super coole Live-Streamer, die, wie du weißt,
viele Fans haben,
sich entschieden, ihre Fanbase zu militärisieren.
Und sie haben...
Das ist richtig, sie haben das.
Also, die Calypso Twins wollen das gleiche, was du willst.
Sie wollen den Vault.
Also, von Anfang an in Borderlands 3
werden die Calypso Twins in deinem Gesicht sein.
Sie werden versuchen, dich auf dem Weg zum Vault zu stoppen,
um auf dem Planeten zu kommen, zum anderen Vault.
Und, wie du weißt, in großartigem Streamer-Fashion
werden sie die Streams wieder reinnehmen.
Glaubst du, Borderlands könnte mit einem konventionellen
Grafikstil funktionieren?
Das Game an sich ist geil.
... die Königin Tyrene und ihr Bruder Troy...
Muss halt passen.
... als sie für den Vault vor dir hüpfen.
Also, wirklich coole Feinde.
Ich denke, die Leute werden sie wirklich genießen.
Aber, Mann, sie sind aggressiv.
Und jetzt müssen wir kurz abschneiden,
aber ich wollte zurück zu den Planeten kommen.
In einem Wort, wie groß ist dieses Spiel?
Dieses Spiel ist großartig.
Großartig.
Massiv.
Es ist definitiv größer als Borderlands 2.
Wir haben noch keine exakten Zahlen benutzt,
weil wir ein paar Überraschungen halten wollen.
Naja, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es bei Borderlands
so extrem wichtig wäre, dass die Landmasse groß ist.
Wir haben schon über Pandora gesprochen,
von der wir schon vorhin waren.
Und da gibt es ein gutes Spiel.
Wir haben über Promethea gesprochen,
das ist ein großes Stadtplanet,
ein großes ursprüngliches Gebiet mit riesigen Gebäuden.
Und es gibt einen großen öffentlichen Krieg
zwischen zwei unserer großen Kooperationen,
Maliwan und Atlas.
Und wir haben auch über Eden 6 gesprochen,
einen großen schwampigen Flussplanet.
Ich nenne es Space Florida.
Die hier hinten sehen mega exakt aus.
Es ist voller Flüsse und Dinosaurier und so weiter.
Und es werden vielleicht noch mehr Überraschungen
um die Kante kommen.
Aber ich will nicht alles abspielen.
Weißt du was?
Ja, das wäre gut.
Diese Jungs werden später mehr Informationen bekommen.
Lass uns die Überraschungen aufhören.
Ansonsten danke dir so sehr, Randy,
dass du hier warst.
Und dann, falls jemand in der Wohnung
etwas verpasst hat.
Ja, okay, ja.
Gut.
Also ich würde Borderlands 3
auf jeden Fall gerne
ins Flashboard holen.
Die ersten Pfeile waren richtig cool.
Und das zweite hat für die Art von Games
auch eine wirklich nice Story gehabt.
Es ist Zeit, über PUBG zu sprechen.
Aber bevor wir darüber nachdenken,
lasst uns mal schauen,
wie es bei Borderlands 2 aussieht.
Ich habe mir immer noch gehofft,
dass Handsome Jack irgendwie überlebt hat,
aber der war ziemlich ripp.
Ja.
Ich meine, immerhin sieht das Game
jetzt nicht mehr aus wie hingeschmiert,
sondern irgendwie zusammenhängend.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn nicht PUBG
spielen würde, dann würde ich auf dem PC spielen. Aber sowas von. Und nicht auf der Xbox.
Wo ist eigentlich Player Unknown? Ist der überhaupt noch dabei? Was ist das hier, Mann?
Wir haben Erangel mit höherer Fidelity verbessert, insbesondere mit einigen großen Landmarkten, wie Militärpower und Militärbasis.
Und auch alle werden sehen können, was mit Erangel passiert ist, mit den Tränchen und der Kommunikation und dem Platzmarkt auf dem Boden.
Und auch gibt es einige geheime Plätze, wo man ein paar Wege finden kann, was da passiert ist.
Auch mit all diesen Änderungen ist es immer noch Erangel. Wir wissen, dass alle Erangel lieben, also versuchen wir, sie zu verändern.
Ja, ich persönlich kann nicht warten, die neuen Plätze wieder zu entdecken und diese Geheimnisse zu finden. Das wird so cool zu finden.
Ray, kannst du uns über Survival Pass 4 erzählen?
Ja, Season 4 hat auch Survival Pass 4 Aftermath introduziert, was die Spieler mit über 100 Rewarden erlaubt hat.
Diese Rewarden zeigen das Vergangen und das Zukunft von Erangel.
Wir haben auch die Kooperative Missionen eingeführt, die die Gemeinschaft mit den Tieren und Militärböden ermöglichen, um zusammen zu arbeiten.
Als ihr diese Militärböden erzielt,
Dankeschön, Patrick, Pock.
könnt ihr neue Rewarden erzielen.
Und auch könnt ihr die Missionen einfacher auswählen, als die vorherigen Passen.
Und ihr könnt die Militärböden erzielen, um sie weiterzuentwickeln, wenn ihr nicht auf bestimmte Tasken seid.
Ich kann nicht warten, bis ich die Unlocken erzielen kann. Chris, Season 4 Trailer, wie cool war das?
Das ist eigentlich das erste Mal, dass ich den Trailer gesehen habe. Ich höre immer darüber nach, und jetzt habe ich endlich den guten Trailer.
Das war fantastisch.
Und ich bin wirklich stolz darauf, mehr darüber zu erfahren, was da passiert ist.
Ich finde ein paar Geheimnisse und lerne ein bisschen Lüge.
Tier 3 Sub, sehe ich jetzt. Das ist ja noch viel nicer.
Danke schön.
Ich spreche zu früh, und du bist die Person, die sich mit einem Schockgut in der Kante versteckt.
Ja, ich verstecke mich in der Schachtel.
Chris ist die Person, die dich tötet, wenn du so nah am Kaffee-Dinner bist.
Es ist ein Traum.
Aber ich weiß, Chris, das ist nicht alles, was du heute über PUBG gehört hast. Was anderes hast du?
Ja, das ist eines der Dinge, die alle haben wollen.
Es ist Crossplay und Play für die Konsole.
Crossplay!
Für die Konsole!
Vielleicht, man könnte es auch reininterpretieren, vielleicht gehen ihnen so ein bisschen die Spiele auf der Konsole aus.
... mit den PlayStation-Spielern.
Das wird das Spiel weltweit größer machen und auch mehr Wettbewerb bieten.
Chris, wie ist es, dieses Spiel zu haben?
Das ist fantastisch.
Ich meine, als wir vor ein paar Jahren das Cross-Konsole-Spiel ermöglicht haben,
war das genau das, was wir erwartet haben.
Die gesamte globale Bevölkerung wird auf der Konsole spielen.
Ja, Crossplay ist gut. Matt, sehe ich auch so.
Fantastisch. Super cool.
Es ist einfach so spannend, dass die Gemeinschaft immer mehr wächst und mehr Spieler auf PUBG hat.
Es wird wirklich spannend.
Und Ray...
Eigentlich gibt es noch eine Sache zu diesem Schedule.
Wir wollen Crossplay und Play auf dem Publikums-Test-Server am Ende September aufbauen.
Und nach einer Woche Wetter planen wir, den Live-Server am Ende Oktober aufzubauen.
Am Ende Oktober, das ist ein Crossplay, nicht so weit weg.
Das ist wirklich spannend.
Ich kann nicht warten, um etwas zu machen.
Ray, PUBG ist jetzt hier auf der Konsole.
Du bist seit zwei Jahren auf der Konsole.
Was willst du den Spielern noch sagen?
Wir freuen uns wirklich auf das Liebe und Feedback, das uns die PUBG-Community seit dem Launch gegeben hat.
Und wir danken allen Leuten bei PUBG, die uns spielen und uns unterstützen und uns lieben.
Bis zum nächsten Mal auf der Welt.
Ich würde nur sagen...
Ein einfaches Applaus.
Auf behalf von allen.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns so ein tolles Spiel gespielt habt.
Aber vielen Dank, dass ihr heute mitgekommen seid.
Ich persönlich kann nicht warten, in die Saison 4 zu fallen.
Aber jetzt geht es wieder zu Lea mit einem Spiel, das sich in einem postapokalyptischen Winterwunderland befindet.
Ja, danke Benni.
Danke für die Wünsche.
Vielleicht nicht ganz das Wort, das ich dafür benutzen würde.
Jetzt geht es weiter mit der neuesten Veranstaltung eines Fan-Favoriten.
Ich habe noch einmal Excited vergessen.
In Exile's Wasteland 3 bringt dich zum Vordergrund der postnuklearen Welt.
Durch Squad-Based Epic...
Wir nennen sie einfach Squabbles, oder?
Deep-branching Storylines and an open world, Wasteland 3 is truly the next frontier.
We've got your first look at the new story, combat and one heck of a ride.
For more on the new title, take a gander at this here world premiere trailer.
Wasteland 3.
Das heißt, es gab auch schon Wasteland 1 und 2.
You will bring my fractious children to anization.
Just be warned.
Your trip to Colorado will not be easy.
The night is a snow.
Are you off?
Ich stehe mal dran.
Ich glaube, ich habe das nie gespielt.
Gangs and cults watch the passes and prey on the unwary.
Ach das!
Jetzt, wenn ich das sehe, jetzt weiß ich auch, was das ist.
Wasteland 3.
Ich dachte, das ist irgendeine Third-Person, nichts was.
You will have to fight to reach us.
Das ist, das ist so RPG, runden-basierter Taktik.
Jetzt weiß ich, was das für ein Game ist, klar.
Wasteland 3.
Jetzt sagt mir Wasteland 2, ich habe es trotzdem nicht gespielt.
Das war das, wo sich die in den Reviews aufgeregt haben, dass das Spiel zu viel Text hätte, oder?
Wo ich mir gedacht habe, alter, da kann sich aber alles aufregen.
Moin, Flamehaze.
Ja, klar, doch, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was das ist.
Aber trotzdem habe ich nicht gespielt.
Ich wollte es mir auch mal kaufen, weil eigentlich mag ich so eine Sorte von Games.
Es könnte tatsächlich was sein.
Von der Gelegenheit muss ich mir mal aufschreiben.
Das ist ein zweimaler Steam-Haul.
Night Ops Camo, das habe ich schon immer gebraucht, Leute.
Stealthy, das ist dann, dann finde ich meinen Controller noch schlechter.
Es hat so einen Metal-Flake-Effekt, also schifft es sich in der Lichtung,
und es scheint die Farbe direkt vor dir zu verändern.
Es ist super, super cool.
Ihr habt auch einen wunderschönen Gold-Metallic-D-Pad,
und ich liebe persönlich die texturierten Trigger,
die euch locken lassen, wenn ihr diese Dubs bekommt.
Und der Eagle-Eyed von euch, der hier mein T-Shirt gesehen hat...
Wie gefällt es euch?
So, das ist die aktuelle Textbox hier, Night Ops Camo T-Shirt,
ihr könnt es sehen, es passt mit dem Camo hier,
weil, was ist die Alternative zu das T-Shirt nicht sehen?
Also mir persönlich gefällt der Blaue besser als der Night Ops.
I love these grips, they really help you feel connected to the controller,
it just feels amazing.
And of course, both controllers feature Bluetooth-Capability
for gaming on Windows 10 PCs and Tablets,
and 3.5mm stereo ports, so you can plug your headsets directly in.
Das ist heutzutage schon ein Feature, dass man einen Klingelstecker hat.
We have an unboxing video featuring Brenna from the Mixer Team and myself,
and that's going live on the Xbox YouTube Channel right after this show.
Klingelports!
What do you think, everybody?
Isn't that nice?
Isn't that great?
We've got some controller fans in the audience tonight.
And I love that, right?
If you, like me, are obsessed with Xbox controllers,
I love them and I'm not ashamed to say it,
we've created an amazing original video
with the design leads from the Xbox Hardware Team,
taking us through the inspiration for every Xbox One controller ever made.
Literally every single one.
There's so many cool and interesting stories
and behind the scenes things in here,
I think you're gonna love this video.
Every Xbox One controller ever made,
is premiering exclusively on Xbox YouTube
and Instagram TV on August 26th.
Do not miss that.
Now, from a couple of new controllers
to a couple known throughout the gaming world
for their visionary titles.
Julia is about to catch up with Brenda Romero
and John Romero in the speakeasy.
So let's raise a glass
and take a trip back to Prohibition-Era,
Chicago in Empire of Sin.
Mein John Romero gibt's noch.
He's been a thorn in my side.
Now he says he wants to cut a deal.
He doesn't know what's coming.
Bremen Beta gleich Alpha, man weiß es nicht.
But first, let's go back to the beginning.
A week ago I got into Chicago.
As soon as I did,
they started handing out my calling card.
It wasn't long before I was building an empire
and making contacts.
I had a few ups and downs along the way.
Eddie and Marie fell in love and ran off.
But sure,
Tammy's the best shot in town.
If she doesn't show up drunk, that is.
And Jack?
No one would mess with Jack.
So Kommandos, huh?
Das ist ein bisschen was wie Kommandos.
Old Ryan didn't take too well
to my way of doing business.
Now he thinks he's got me pegged.
He ain't got nothing.
What he doesn't know
is I've been making deals all around town.
And I got just enough cops
to look the other way.
Those who work with me
are afraid of nothing.
You must feel bad for the guy.
He's just a step unmoved in the dark.
But if it wasn't me taking him down,
it'd be somebody else.
Think you got what it takes?
Come and get it.
Tatsächlich, da sitzt er ja.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es den noch gibt.
Making some of your favorite games.
From Romero Games Limited,
Game Director Brandon Romero
and President John Romero.
Der hat auch lange nichts mehr fabriziert,
was sich gelohnt hat zu spielen.
First of all, the game looks...
Weiß gar nicht, was das letzte Game von ihm war,
was halbwegs was getaugt hat.
Auf jeden Fall ist es schon 10 Jahre locker her.
It was inspired by a local watering hole,
is that right?
It was.
Bars can be good for other things,
like games, for instance.
Where were you drinking?
I grew up in a town in northern New York,
in Ogdensburg.
There wasn't a lot happening,
but this one place in town
was called The Place, unbelievably.
That's its name.
Still is called The Place.
Anyway, The Place was the oldest
continuously operating bar in the US.
Whether that's true or not, I didn't know,
but when I started asking my mom questions,
like, why didn't the cops just shut it down?
The answers I got, she didn't want to give me answers
that would be like, well, future game designer,
here's how criminal empires are built.
So instead she didn't want to talk about the gray area,
and she just sort of pushed me away.
But it developed this fascination with criminal empires,
and so Paradox was happy to turn that into a game.
And I've always been fascinated with this kind of game.
There's a lot going on.
Yeah, and you guys did like a whole,
a whole bunch of research,
and I think it's like half of the bosses are kind of,
so about half is about half fictional,
and half are actually sort of real.
In fact, John's grandmother,
great grandmother is in the game.
Was I supposed to say that?
Exclusive.
I've said it now, yeah, so half the bosses,
about half the bosses are real,
and half are fictional characters
that are some up the era.
Yeah.
But yeah, we've done a ridiculous amount of research into it.
That's brilliant.
I mean, John, so obviously we've seen a little bit about
kind of what the game is like.
What's the main sort of player experience like?
Going into this game, what am I going to be doing?
What are we going to be doing?
Well, the strategy game, so there's a lot going on in it.
And you have to manage your four main resources,
which is your money, your alcohol, your RPCs,
and the time that you have.
And time taken, and everybody wants to have
the money there, of course.
You start at the bottom at the beginning.
But you do a lot of things.
Such as, you know,
you sell alcohol to, say, allies of yours.
Well, you can sell some poison alcohol
and kill a lot of other guys.
You won't be allies after that.
I mean, no.
You can do a lot of really underhanded stuff in this game.
That sounds really fun.
And one of these sort of interesting things I was reading about
was about the kind of recruitable playable characters.
So you've always got, they were saying that they've got
randomized traits, and then as the game progresses,
they could be a bit more reliable, maybe?
And that's drunk when they turn up, or something?
Well, so,
you start out with the characters,
let's say you and I are both playing the game,
and we both...
Okay.
Weißt du, ein bisschen, wo man einfach spezialisiert,
weil was auch immer die da erzählen,
die erzählen ja nix über das Game, komischerweise,
außer dass es für Bosse gibt.
Das sieht für mich aus wie ein Kommandos,
wo du unterschiedliche Leute,
quasi unterschiedliche NPCs bei irgendeiner Taverne
anheuern kannst, oder sonst was.
Also, aufleveln und halt
rundenbasierte
Taktikstellen machen kannst, also...
Das könnte
in dem Game sein, was was taugt,
wenn sie uns mal
eigentlich das Game was erzählen würden.
Warum müssen die im Hintergrund stehen?
Wahrscheinlich, weil sie Microsoft extra
dafür eingeladen hat, um im Hintergrund zu stehen.
Glaubt mir, ich hab da Erfahrung
aus erster Hand mit.
War auch schon mal Microsoft-Klatscher.
Ich hab Excited vergessen.
Spring 2020.
Spring 2020, so not too long to wait.
Oh, fantastic.
Thank you so much,
for joining us and for being here.
Now, we've got so much more to come,
including, I don't know, a smallish, I don't know,
what's that game called? Gears 5?
I don't know, there's a bit of a showcase of...
Okay, das ist das Gears, wo sie Off-War
weggelassen haben.
Later in the show, obviously.
But before we get there, a graduation celebration
is in order, because from the makers
of DayZ comes the next great
shoot-and-loot-survival game.
Weil DayZ ja auch so fertig ist.
Viggo 1.0 officially releases
as a free-to-play title
today.
Wir haben darauf gewartet, ein neues DayZ, ey.
Was, Viggo 1.0, was?
Ich weiß, wenn ihr erst mal DayZ fertig machen würdet,
Leute, ey.
Norway has become the last
stand.
Crossed by footprints
of surviving outlanders.
Okay, es ist eine neue DayZ-Map.
Dazu muss ich gleich
was einblenden.
Ich fänd, es würde halt ein bisschen mehr Vertrauen in den
Entwickler auch
geben, wenn sie ihr letztes
Game, was ja im Prinzip genau
das gleiche ist, also,
zumindest große Überschneidung, ja,
wenn sie ihr letztes Game erst mal in den Zustand
bringen würden, der spielbar ist oder
beziehungsweise der was braucht.
Aber nee, wir machen ein neues Game.
Das gleiche machen.
Worum geht's
gerade? Um Viggo.
Play free now.
Dann der ganze Microtransaction.
Okay, ah, Leute.
Also, ich zeige euch mal was.
Wo wir gerade sind, bei dem tollen Entwickler,
wo alle super Hyped drauf sind, dass ein neues Game
von ihnen kommt.
So.
Huge, super,
super gute, ähm,
Bewertung.
So much games.
It's enough to send us his on-camera interview
requirements, so, you know, we thought we
returned the favor by basically
reading that rider out on stage. And I'm not even
kidding, this is a direct email that we stole
off the Xbox servers. No joke, right.
Dear inside Xbox, I have a
multi-dimensional preparation program,
which I find is key to setting
me up for success. And with enough time,
this shouldn't be a problem for the team.
This request covers key things like organic
snacks, specific climate-controlled room,
positive color palette, ergonomic seating,
performance socks. What's a performance
sock? I sort of want it.
And fair trade organic sustainable cold brew
from the island of Mauritius.
Thoroughly unreasonable. I mean, I thought
my rider was ridiculous, but it's more just to make me
not look like I've been dragged through a hedge
backwards. Eh, well, try not.
So, to catch up with this Xbox mainstay,
and to find out a bit more, I want to try
some of this coffee. We're gonna chuck it over to Charlie.
Did he bring any? Have you got some? Ah, I can't.
I don't see any coffee, Julia.
Hast du das gesehen?
Der hat den eben angerempelt,
dass er excited sein soll. Habt ihr's
gesehen? Der hat den so angetippt,
so nach dem Motto, ey, Leute, jetzt!
Jetzt!
Ich kann's nicht zurückspulen.
Open Doors Experience.
Oh, oh, ich hab ein paar Exciteds vergessen.
Ja, das erzählen sie
bei jedem Release.
Und in der letzten Folge
war es das Ruhige Premiere von Campaign.
Wir haben ein tolles Story-Asset mit Campaign-Gameplay
sowie Kate Storys Robby
und Jeff Keighley.
So, das ist ein riesengroßer Tag für
Gears- und Gears-Fans hier mit uns hier
und natürlich auch über die Welt.
Aber es gibt auch viele mehr Spiele!
Ja, komm schon! Ich mach's!
Also, Schau, Gamescom ist spannend.
Fast 400.000 Fans kommen nicht nur aus Deutschland,
sondern aus ganz Europa.
Also wir haben eine große Strecke, wir haben Hunderts an
Display. Es ist toll, zu sehen, dass die Fans
Aber Pog, weiß.
First-Time-Hands-On, das hört sich jetzt aber auch irgendwie bis hin.
Sea of Thieves! Mit den fünf Spielern, die es noch hatte.
Und es ist die Halo-Schiff-Livery für gratis, als Bonus auch.
Für mich, meine Lieblings-Parte an Gamescom sind all diese Leute hier, die Fans.
Also, während wir eine riesige Strecke haben,
und wir die Hunderttausende von Leuten begrüßen,
diese Erfahrung hier, dieses große Theater, in dem wir die Show machen,
der Rest der Woche ist eine Erfahrung für die Fans.
Also, um Hands-On zu bekommen, werden wir Turniere haben,
wir werden Panels haben,
und ein wirklich interessantes Spiel,
in einem intimen Zustand.
Ich bin am Dienstag wieder auf dem Mortal Kombat-Show.
Also, einfach mit dabei sein.
Genau, wir haben ein Mortal Kombat-Turnier,
wir haben den Berg vor uns.
Oh ja, das machen wir.
Ich versuche, diesen Jungen runterzuholen.
Also, ja, lass uns das machen.
Also, ich werde am Dienstag hier sein.
Wir werden das auf Mixer streamen,
für die Leute, die es zu Hause sehen wollen.
Und es ist einfach toll, mit unseren Fans zu feiern.
Absolut.
Und es wird nicht nur dieses Jahr so sein, oder?
Es kommt etwas, was in meinem Nacken der Wälder kommt,
glaube ich.
Etwas namens EXO-19.
Könnt ihr uns so viel Informationen wie möglich über das geben?
Ja.
Wenn Sie dachten,
dass wir das hier an Gamescom anbieten,
das ist großartig,
dann wartet nur, bis Sie EXO-19 sehen.
Was ich am liebsten darüber habe,
ist, dass es ein Feierabend von allen Dingen von Xbox ist.
Es wird das größte Inside-Xbox-Show des Jahres sein.
Wir haben viele Sachen, die wir aus unseren internen Studios zeigen,
von Drittpartnern,
viele große Überraschungen sind geplant,
also wollen Sie das definitiv nicht missen.
Inside-Xbox am 14. November.
Wir machen eine Dreijahrsfeier in London.
Die sehen alle so super excited aus dahinter.
Das war am 14. November,
also holt das auf den Kalender.
Der Vodäer sieht mega-huge-excited aus.
Nicht nur haben wir dieses massive Inside-Xbox,
aber ich möchte persönlich alle unsere Fans aus dem ganzen Weltraum anbieten,
um nach London zu kommen und uns zu besuchen.
Wir haben Tausende von Tickets vorhanden.
Es sind nur 19 Pfund.
Wir geben alle Geld und Prozesse an die Charity.
Am 24. September werden die Tickets auf der Verkaufsseite.
Sie können das auf Xbox.com schauen.
Das kann man auf jemanden kennen im Hintergrund.
Aber am 14. November.
Markt euren Kalender.
Es wird großartig.
Es wird tatsächlich ziemlich großartig.
Ja, ich habe noch einen Keks bei X-Files 19.
Ich möchte euch darüber sprechen.
Ist das genug?
Es könnte ein bisschen ein sozialer Gast da sein.
Hallo, wer ist da?
Ja, äh...
Major Nelson wird da sein.
Da sind wir.
Ja.
Die gibt es noch.
Leute, von denen ich es nie vermutlich gehabt habe, dass es sie noch gibt.
Der Chef des Xbox-Game-Studios, Matt Booty wird da sein.
Ja, er wird da sein.
Ja.
Massive war vorher auch hier.
Ja, das zählt auch.
Of course, I will be there, but...
The best one.
And even the big man himself, Phil Spencer, will be in London for X-Files 19.
Guckt euch doch die zwei da hinten an.
So geil.
All of our great X-Files.
Please find us.
Stimmt.
Wo ist Phil Spencer eigentlich?
I'll tell you what.
I was gonna test you on this.
I've literally got a piece of paper of everything you had to say.
You smashed it, Aaron.
All right.
Thank you.
You said absolutely everything.
And I think, I think that's pretty much.
I think you need to go sit down.
I am.
It's been, it's quite intense in this room.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna throw over to Benny for another world premiere.
Thanks, darling.
Also, Aaron.
Aaron.
If you...
You need a place to stay during X-Files 19.
Während er jetzt labert.
Ich hatte ja auch mal das Vergnügen, 2016 war das, glaube ich, äh, Klatscher zu sein
bei Microsoft.
Da haben sie uns aber ein bisschen jeep-baited.
Kann ich...
Habe ich schon ein paarmal erzählt.
Ich kann es einfach nochmal erzählen, wenn ihr wollt, wenn das fertig ist.
The upcoming of Action-RPG, Griebfall, has already made waves.
And it's not even out yet.
This epic open-world adventure takes you through the diverse factions on an island populated
by not-so-nice locals.
Now, for the first glimpse...
Oh, what?
Excited vergessen.
... we're getting a glimpse into those characters and relationships that can truly shape the
way the game is played.
Let's take a look.
It's awesome.
Today is the big day, isn't it?
Ready to set sail for that island everyone's talking about.
It is said, our people are the best.
It is said, our people lived peacefully.
Until the men appeared from the sea, intent on making our lands their own.
All・anes, free fall.
The world and your story are ever-changing based on the choices you made.
You'll enter the island of Tir-Freddi, not as an assassin or a soldier…
First and foremost you're a diplomat.
Piraten-Game? Ne, das ist was anderes.
Dead Game?
Ne, ist doch kein MMO.
Das ist dieser Piraten-Stelz, glaub ich.
Da hab ich letztens noch mal einen Trailer geguckt.
Das sah gar nicht so blöd aus.
Reckt.
Genau so stell ich mir nen Scientist vor.
Epic.
Literally.
Mein Sohn, es ist klar, diese Frau will uns nicht helfen.
Ich bitte dich, diese Ausländer zu verabschieden.
Sie kennen unsere Gelegenheiten nicht.
Zum Beispiel Ciora ist ein Tier-Freddine-Native,
furchtbar schützend für ihre Menschenrechte.
Sie streitet stark mit jemandem, der sich gegen die Natives enttäuscht,
während sie in ihrer Präsenz ist.
Und eine furchtbare Unterbrechung
kann deine Hand ins Blut schlagen.
Sag mir doch nicht, dass du diesen verrückten Assassinen lachen wirst.
Be sure to pay close attention to your party members' needs.
Each has their own story and unique personal quests.
Ignoring them for too long may even cause them to leave the party.
Petrus is a missionary of Tel Aimee with a remarkable way with words
and an outwardly fatherly nature that masks deep-rooted ambitions.
Vasco.
A captain of the seafaring knots,
is one of the more secretive closed members of your party.
Spend time with the captain and complete his personal questline
and he'll inevitably open up.
Develop close friendships with all of your companions
and some may even lead to romance.
Never forget, relationships in Breedfall
can be as uncertain as the seas that ravaged here for these shores.
Konstantin, I'm here.
I'm here. Pull yourself together.
Nothing said or unsaid can be taken for granted.
Ultimately, the choices you make will shape the future of the island.
We didn't want this fight.
And the lives of all upon it.
You are too blind, too renexe to understand.
Was? 10. September?
Das ist doch in drei Wochen, ne?
Vier Wochen?
Das ist meine Lieblingszeit im Sommer.
Und hör mal,
der Sommer ist der beste Zeitpunkt, um an einem Spiel zu arbeiten.
Und mit der Xbox-Summer-Spotlight-Sale
war es nie einfacher, dein nächstes Lieblingsspiel zu entdecken.
Jetzt, durch September 10,
kriegst du mehr als 60 neue Titel
über die Xbox One-Familie
bei großartigen Preisen.
Und für einen kurzen Zeitraum
kannst du bis zu 4.000 Microsoft-Wertpunkte erzielen,
wenn du 40 Dollar auf die Sommer-Spotlight-Titel verwendest.
Bargain Hunt!
Und mit Games like The Man's Guide,
Overcooked 2,
und Vigor
machen wir heute noch ein bisschen was zu.
Auf Control freu ich mich richtig.
Iiih.
So make sure to check the Microsoft Store every Tuesday
and follow Xbox on Twitter,
so we can keep you up to date
until after the boys of summer have gone.
Nice little Don Henley reference there
for the oldies amongst us.
He got it.
Alright, coming up.
We've got Bungie back on the Xbox stage
for the first time in years with Destiny 2.
Stimmt, die haben sich ja freigekauft.
Die haben sich ja freigekauft von Activision.
We'll show you the latest from Metro Exodus
with the two-kernel-TLC
and a weapon that is truly en fuego.
But first, it's time for another world premiere trailer.
Fans of The Surge, get ready,
because this sequel has a bigger world,
tougher enemies,
and the most customizable Exo-Rig ever.
Oh, wir haben ja Excited-Counter vergessen zweimal.
Welcome to The Surge 2.
Hat jemand The Surge 1 gespielt?
Set in the ruins of a futuristic city,
you must escape a merciless world
filled with mysterious military forces,
a rampaging cult of nanomachine monstrosities.
You are the survivor of Flight 221,
with no choice but to find a way
past Jericho City's war-torn walls.
Explore the city's intricate and desolate pathways
to discover hidden paths and shortcuts.
Create your character and survive
thanks to your Exo-Rig,
a powerful mobile machine
that gives you increased strength,
speed,
and endurance.
To get new gear,
you will need to take them from your foes.
Using the limb targeting system,
you can aim for specific body parts.
Target a weapon or piece you're interested in,
damage it,
and then use a brutal execution to slice it off.
Like every machine,
the Exo-Suit can be tuned,
adjusted,
and upgraded to your liking.
Opt for speed and agility,
or focus on taking powerful blows
to convert them into energy.
Your Exo-Rig is centered around your core power,
which dictates how much fear you can attach to your suit.
Each piece of armor and every implant comes at a cost,
so choose wisely.
Most pieces of armor you find
have both partial and full-set bonuses,
allowing you to either specialize
or hybridize the way you want to fight.
To further customize your Exo-Suit,
you also have access to implants and injectables.
These provide passive and active bonuses to your character,
ranging from effects like predicting parry direction
to slowing down time.
The Surge 2 features 80 weapons across nine types,
such as the dual-bladed twin-rig
and the brand-new transforming double-duty.
These weapons range from military security batons
to jury-rigged homemade spears.
Each weapon has unique attack speeds, ranges, and damage types.
Yeah,
die Sucht, die danach entsteht,
kein Krieger kann alleine mit den Angriffen aufhören.
Du hast eine Vielfalt von defensiven Werkzeugen,
die du hast,
alle mit ihren eigenen Vorteilen und Nutzungen.
Dodge ist für diejenigen, die glauben,
dass Prävention besser ist als Heilung,
und für diejenigen, die eine mehr aggressivere Defense genießen.
Für mehr advanced Spieler
kannst du den Duck oder den Short-Hop verwenden,
um hohe oder niedrige Angriffe zu evadieren.
Diese werden mit einem Counter-Attack gefolgt,
welcher die Feinde aufsteigt
und sie auf einen starken, zerstörten Schuss öffnet.
Ein Block kann dafür genutzt werden,
Energie zu erzeugen,
welches die Ressource ist,
um Injektivitäten und beendete Bewegungen zu erzeugen.
Ein Block kann dafür geschützt werden,
wenn du genug Stamina hast,
um den Angriff zu verhindern.
Du kannst das Ding weiter nehmen,
indem du den Direktional-Parry verwenden kannst,
welches viel mehr Energie erzeugt
und die größte Angriffe aus der Balance verlässt.
Dodge, Blocken und Parrying
können dafür genutzt werden,
um Animationen zu verhindern
und um Komplimente zu erweitern,
um eine Menge der möglichen Möglichkeiten,
die dir vorhanden sind,
um die ganze Welt zu erfüllen.
Nach dir ist dein vertrauter Kampfdrone,
der dir mit mehreren verschiedenen Modulen beiträgt,
ins
special banner in the world that rewards you if you players find it revenge
enemies also appear powerful foes who have been upgraded by slaying another
player als er sogar level 5 statt sie geht
further into the search to you will discover new implants new upgrades new
weapons and new ways to explore and each of them will be needed to rise above the
ruins of jericho city the enemies you face will be both man and machine each
bringing a new and deadly challenge these are the tools at your disposal and
will be the means for you to overcome every threat
survive the search to you on september 24 on xbox one
das ist das nur ein xbox oder gibt es auch wieder auf dem auf dem windows store
und irgendwas dazu gesagt ein bisschen resident sleeper schaut tatsächlich
aber das kann man das kann man wirklich nicht gut einschätzen
und jetzt wird's resident sleeper leute jetzt wird's hyper resident sleeper
oh ne jetzt wird's resident sleeper leute jetzt wird's hyper resident sleeper
ich hab's euch gesagt dieses jahr ist selbst anfeuern übelst im trend
exited doppelt exited
noch mehr exited
könnt ihr mal ein anderes wort als exited verwenden?
ja ich will ein anderes wort als exited verwenden?
ich weiß nicht, ihr habt da ein bisschen kompetition
bitte sagt uns alles, ein exklusiveres detail, das wird niemand verraten
ich sitz jetzt, wir haben eine halbe Stunde
wir fangen mit dem finisher an, das ist einfach ein weiteres element des kombats
ein tool das ihr in destiny kombats einbringt, das ein enemy mit einem flügel ausfüllt
so dass ihr sie sehen könnt, das glöckchen und ein dach über der hände
und ihr rutscht rein, wenn ihr den finisher drücken könnt
ja ich spiel das auf destiny
ihr erlischt sie sofort
schau den stil!
das ist großartig!
super großartig, sehr zufrieden
ich sehe hier einen für einen hunter, einen für einen warlock, einen für einen titan
gibt es auch einen für jede subklasse?
es gibt verschiedene class-orientierte finisher
und jeder, der in destiny 2 schafft, wird alle drei finisher bekommen
sehr spannend
und was ich hier bemerke ist, dass wir hier viel vettel machen
aber es sieht nicht so aus, als gäbe es einen cool down zwischen finishern
könnt ihr einfach durch rampagen und finischen, finischen, finischen
ja, ihr könnt rampagen
aber es gibt noch mehr Dinge, die ihr mit finishern machen könnt
außer, dass ihr den enemy auslöscht
ja
mit armor 2.0 nehmen wir viele customisierungs- und rpg-elemente
und setzen sie in die action game
ok
so, sobald ihr in das system startet, werden mehr dinge als finisher möglich
plötzlich könnt ihr sagen, hey, ich nehme mein artefact
ich werde einen dieser mods verdienen
es ist ein collectable, nicht ein consumable
und dieser hier ist wahrscheinlich mein liebster
wenn du einen enemy beendest mit diesem mod, wirst du einen schweren ammobrück spawnen
für dein gesamtes fireteam
wow, das ist unglaublich
ich kann das zu null sagen
aber es kostet die halbe deiner super
oh, ok, das ist ein schwerer kost
das ist einfach die klappe
ich weiß nicht, ich könnte das auch in der raid machen
und du denkst, oh ja, richtig?
das ist das ding, jetzt haben wir keine schweren ammo
wir sind wieder rein, ich bin ein großer Fan davon
und ja, kombatmods sind ein guter weg
wenn du dein gameplay etwas spicer machen willst, kannst du einen kombatmod nehmen
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr zahlfrei, mehr nützlichkeit
vielleicht weniger selbstbewusst sein, wie man sagt, oder?
das ist das, worum ich denke
es gibt auch selbstbewusste
gibt es in Destiny 2 eine reine Support-Klasse?
es gibt eine exotische Support-Klasse, die Assassin's-Cowl macht dich unbeleuchtet
viele Spielstile öffnen sich, wenn du die Finisher-Mods ansiehst und sie umdrehen kannst
und es sieht aus, als würde das ganze System auf die Persönlichkeit deines Charakters gehören
ja, wir öffnen einen ganzen neuen Welt der Optionen, die dir die perfekte Monster-Killing-Maschine bieten
wie wir in der Studio gesagt haben
lecker
also, wenn du einen Guardian hast, oder wenn du noch nicht einen Guardian kreiert hast
kannst du einen Helden für dieses Spiel kreieren, der wirklich eine Reflexion darauf ist, wer du bist
es kämpft, wie du kämpfst
es sieht so aus, wie du es möchtest
du willst überhaupt nicht in dem Game sein
lecker, ja
das zählt auf
du kannst in Destiny genau so spielen, wie du es möchtest
du bekommst zusätzliche Erlebnisse, wenn du größere Risiken nimmst
wenn du mit deinen Feinden aneinander stehst und eine Finisher-Move nutzt
du kannst... was waren die Sachen, über die wir vorhin gesprochen haben?
du kannst deine Gesundheit zahlen, du kannst unbeleuchtet gehen
du kannst für dich und dein Team Ammunition spawnen
ja, nichts
und das kommt nicht ohne Risiko, oder?
bist du unbeleuchtet, wenn du diese Special-Moves tust?
du bist nicht unbeleuchtet
ich bin nicht unbeleuchtet
du hast einen Mann auf deinem Feuer-Team
der sich einfach nicht helfen kann
er muss eine Finisher-Move machen
und dann...
haben wir eigentlich Teil 3
noch nichts bekannt
und ich habe ihn in meinem Schlauch...
oh, das ist spannend
du siehst diesen Glow...
ich bin so überrascht
ich kann den Mann holen
ich brauche den Rokket
ich brauche ihn
und du rutschst durch
das ist ein Risiko
kannst du es auf den wirklich großen Bossen machen?
du kannst es nicht auf den wirklich großen Bossen machen
okay
ich akzeptiere das
du kannst es auf alles unten machen
aber zu der Personalisierung
du bist auch hier, um zu sprechen
was Spieler tun können
um diese persönliche Herausforderung zu 11 zu machen
DJ, kannst du uns den Geheimtipp nennen, um die Elite von Elite-Guardians zu erschaffen?
ich denke, es geht wirklich darum, dass es so passt, wie du es möchtest, um zu kämpfen
also, wenn du der Typ bist, der gerne mit dem Punchen nahe und persönlich ist
wenn du diese Titan-Sensibilität hast
Finisher-Moves werden genau das sein, was du tun willst
wenn du dich zurückhalten möchtest
wenn du der Sniper bist
wenn du nicht wirklich in die Risiko-Erwartung bist
das Gute ist, dass einige dieser Vorteile
auf dem Team teuer sein können
also, jemand, der sich reinholt und einen Finisher-Move macht
könnte einen Halt machen
mit einem schweren Ammo auf dem Boden
um mit seinen Freunden zu teilen
also, das Destiny ist alles um Teamarbeit
es geht darum, mit den anderen Menschen zu spielen
die auf deinem Feuer-Team sind
um deine Freunde zu kennen
und wie sie spielen
wie du spielst
ist wirklich ein Kompliment für die Art, wie sie spielen
das ist das beste Team da drüben
ich fühle mich, als wäre Lea sehr schuldig
ich glaube nicht, dass ich zu der Herausforderung gekommen bin
aber was denkt ihr?
klingt das gut, ihr großen Destiny-Fans?
ich glaube, für Leute, die Destiny spielen, ist das nice
ich kann es halt nicht einschätzen
und ich glaube, ich wäre auch nicht mehr
irgendwie zum Destiny-Fan
2 Monate
naja, eineinhalb Monate
ich habe mal ein Destiny 1 in Raid gespielt, ja
Metro?
das ist doch schon raus, ne?
lit!
lit as fuck ist das, ja
ist doch, ist doch
und wir folgen Colonel Klablakov
während der letzten Tage seiner Leben in Novobisk
No...Novobisk
ich wollte das schon den ganzen Tag sagen
und jetzt lachen mich alle
ich habe den ersten Balot!
okay
aber
eine Geschichte, die Hermann Millers Mission steuern kann
um zu erlernen, warum sie durch den Verteidigung
ein Jahr später kam
und das Weiß communications-Ereignis
naja, ein Feuerstück, natürlich
wenn du neu bist, oder willst den Metro-Saal wiederleben
damit sie aus welchen Ressourcen es gibt
Metro last night
undsmt
jetzt kommt so eine Flamme her, vor die Ecke
das ist alles auf der Stelle, jetzt
auf Xbox Game Pass.
Jetzt, lasst uns das Flamethrower in Aktion sehen.
Es ist Zeit für ein anderes Weltpremier.
Rollen!
3 zu 2, dankeschön.
Pock.
Weiß jemand, wie lang die Präsentation geht?
Keine Ahnung, spätestens 19 Uhr gucken wir uns Kugel Stadia an.
EA gibt's nicht dieses Jahr, das ist da locker.
EA kommt hier bei Microsoft ein bisschen dran.
Wir haben beide die große Lüge getroffen,
weil wir beide uns verletzt haben, wenn es nötig war.
Aber jetzt kann ich endlich die Wahrheit in die Augen schauen.
Ist das eine Singleplayer-Erweiterung?
Ach, ja, Singleplayer.
Singleplayer-Stells.
Ich stimme komplett zu, aber jetzt,
wenn Spiele die Macht haben, Leute zusammenzubringen,
dann ist der nächste Titel die Glühe zu einer Familienfamilie.
Und der Freezy ist am Start.
Freezy, lull.
Fabian, du bist doch rechtzeitig da.
Jetzt kannst du dir mal das neue Gears angucken.
Leute, macht Fullscreen.
Übertreiben sie es aber.
Gears of War has what it takes
to be one of the most successful video game franchises of all time.
Jetzt übertreiben sie es aber.
Alter, ich würde mir im Leben nicht Marcus Fenix auf den Arm tätowieren lassen.
Marcus Fenix, ey, der schlechteste Actionheld ever.
Beard, Beste.
Der Beard, der Beard war der Beste, oder Fabian?
Der Beard.
And fans get to grow with the characters.
We're basically minutes away before going on stage
in front of millions of people
and introduce the world to Gears 5.
I don't think people really give Gears its due
for the influence it's had on modern video games.
Steckt.
You were playing a game, but you were also watching a movie.
Dumb.
No.
Die Story war ab dem zweiten Teil so.
Gears fanbase is like the most passionate,
Den ersten Teil fand ich richtig geil, der zweite Teil war auch richtig geil, bloß dass
er auf emotionale Story gemacht hat, die null dazu gepasst hat.
Ich glaube wir haben Excited vergessen.
Also ich würde mich persönlich über einen ordentlichen Gears Singleplayer freuen, ich
würde mich wirklich über einen ordentlichen Gears Singleplayer freuen, Horde juckt mich
jetzt persönlich nicht so wirklich, aber ein ordentlicher Gears Singleplayer, das wäre
doch mal wieder was.
Smog, genau.
Stellzohr, der Hijack Jack.
Auto-Mode halt, ich hoffe der Singleplayer taucht, ich hoffe der Singleplayer taucht,
ein ordentlicher Gears Singleplayer, das wäre wieder was.
Ne, du bist da gar nicht eins und die klappt.
Okay, ein paar klappen mit.
Ich bin Katarina und ich bin hier im Koalition Studio.
Heute werde ich mit Studio-Head Rod Ferguson und Multiplayer-Design-Direktor Ryan Fleaven
über die kommende Gears 5 Horde Mode sprechen.
Nur hier im Studio zu sein, kannst du dir die Entspannung und die Präsenz richtig fühlen.
die in dieses Spiel und diese Mode eingegangen sind.
Also lasst uns das mal schauen.
Oh, Counter. Das habt recht, Leute.
Das sieht voll Resident Sleeper aus, ey.
Weil die Idee, dass ihr das als Endurance Run machen werdet,
als eine 3-Stunden-Epic-Erfahrung und eine Mode,
ohne Kutszenzen, ohne Charakter-Bereich, ohne neue Geschichte,
hat die Leute für 3 Stunden Aufmerksamkeit.
Und im Jahr 5, was wir gemacht haben,
ist wirklich fast die komplette Realisierung,
was Gears 2 sein wird.
Warum machen die eigentlich so einen Aufstand drum?
Hatte Gears 3 und 4, hatten die keinen Horde-Modus?
Das ist Mode.
Und eine wirklich große Sache, die jetzt Taps heißt,
das sind diese Energie-Geyser, die auf der Karte auftauchen.
Weil generell, wenn du sie findest,
würdest du dich auf einen bestimmten Ort locken
und du würdest die ganze 50 Wälder verteidigen.
Jetzt, um so viel Macht wie möglich zu bekommen,
um so stark wie möglich zu werden,
musst du deine Base bewegen,
um diese Energie-Tapse zu erzeugen.
Und jede 10 Wälder, nachdem du diesen Boss gewonnen hast,
erscheint eine neue Energie-Tapse,
und du musst sie erzeugen.
Es hat also wirklich die Dynamik verändert,
wo es jetzt viel aggressiver ist,
als es in der Vergangenheit war.
Zum ersten Mal beginnt dein Charakter
mit all den Karten, die sie bereits erzeugt haben,
aber sie werden dann
die Kraft dieser Karten erhöhen
und die Kraft ihrer Core-Abilität
über den Laufe des Spiels erhöhen.
Und das schreit fast schon nach Microtransactions.
Und du kannst es im nächsten Spiel wieder machen.
Und das bedeutet, dass jedes Spiel frisch fühlt.
Du kannst eine andere Kombination von Perken probieren,
die mit deinen Karten in einem spezifischen Weg funktionieren.
Wenn ich so was wie Karts höre,
das schreit, das, das, das, das, das, das,
das springt mir Microtransactions schon aus dem Bildschirm.
Und ich denke, wir werden uns sehr freuen,
dass wir sie miteinander vermischen
und diese verschiedenen Spielstile zusammenführen.
Eine der Dinge, die wir gemacht haben,
die subtil sind, aber super wichtig sind,
ist, dass, wenn du die Kraft erhälst,
die Karte in Horde,
diese Kraft gleichmäßig
zwischen allen verwendet wird.
Und das bedeutet, dass, wenn du etwas Kraft auf dem Boden siehst,
alle wollen, dass du es erhälst.
Und dann haben wir noch Dinge geändert,
um den Spielern mehr Informationen zu geben.
Und Dinge wie Health Bars über Bosse
und viele Bosse und so.
Es sieht immer noch aus
wie Gears.
Wir haben da draußen im Laufe der Zeit
irgendwie was komplett anderes gemacht.
Es ist Gears.
Das kann man jetzt gut oder schlecht finden, ja.
Erst mal kurz den Toten überfahren nochmal mit dem Roboter
und dann weiter.
Und dann retzen.
Das kann man mit einer Drohne spielen.
Schon mal was von Magenta Gaming gehört.
Ist das jetzt ein Witz?
Ist das wirklich?
Was wir hoffen zu sehen ist,
dass die Horde-Community zusammenkommt,
um diesen Raum zu entdecken
und uns zu zeigen,
was die beste Kombination von Charakteren ist.
Ich wette mit euch,
als erstes finden die Leute
irgendwann die Klitsches raus auf der Map.
Das ist das erste, was passiert.
Die Leute finden eine Klitsch auf der Map,
wo die Gegner sie nicht erreichen könnten
und spielen bis Runde 995.
Oder Hexorn das Leaderboard,
weil es nicht ordentlich gemacht ist.
In Videogames
finde ich es wirklich toll,
dass die Horde die Abhängigkeit
der Horde erzeugt.
Die Horde erzeugt eine Abhängigkeit,
bei der man als Team zusammenarbeitet.
Man kann erfolgreich sein,
als Lohnwolf,
aber nicht so erfolgreich,
als wenn man zusammenkommt.
Das ist unser Motto im Studio.
Wir sagen immer,
wenn man schnell geht, geht man alleine.
Das ist auch wahr für die Horde.
Es war so spannend, hier zu sein.
Als Gears-Fan seit Gears 1
kann ich nicht erwarten,
meine Hände auf den neuen Horde-Modus
und alle neuen Features zu bekommen.
Für alle anderen wird das Spiel
am 10. September erhältlich sein.
Ultimates, die unik zu den Charaktern sind,
das gab es ja noch nicht.
Was nicht schlimm sein muss.
Du hast Dell,
du kannst Tracker besuchen,
um ihn zu helfen.
Du musst jeden von ihnen finden,
der für dich funktioniert
und am besten für das Team funktioniert.
Sie sind per Charakter,
also nicht per Rolle.
Auch wenn du mehrere Ingenieure hast,
hat jeder verschiedene Charakter
sein eigenes Ultimatum.
Das kann echt cool sein.
Ich bin gespannt,
was wir in Gears 4 gemacht haben,
obwohl es immer noch super zugänglich ist.
Die Tiefe ermöglicht es,
deine Fähigkeiten zu bestätigen,
welchen Charakter du willst.
Aber auch,
wenn du diese Kraft bekommst,
wie in Gears 4,
hast du die Kraft,
den Ingenieur zu bauen.
Jetzt hast du eine Perkze,
die du gehen kannst und sagst,
ich will mehr Schüsse,
ich will mehr Ammo,
ich will mehr Gesundheit.
Du kannst dich damit verkraften.
Ich bekomme diese Kombination,
diese vier Teammate.
Ich würde das erste Gears spielen.
Das finde ich immer noch das Beste
vom Singleplayer.
Du bekommst nur noch
einen Apple und einen IELTS.
Das erste Gears ist richtig gut.
Es gibt Rückwärtskomponenten,
garantiert kompatibel auf der One.
Ich glaube, das erste Gears
gab es sogar auf dem PC.
Hey Gary!
Vielleicht waren wir nicht so gut bei Gears.
Aber die Idee,
in den Cover zu gehen, Pixel zu holen,
zu schießen und all diese Sachen,
Jack hat das nicht.
Jack fliegt über den Körper.
Wenn du jemanden hast,
der neu am Spiel ist,
kann er dir helfen.
Er kann dich heilen,
er kann dich umsetzen,
er kann dich anhalten.
Wir wollten,
dass sie ein wichtiges Teil des Teams sind.
Es geht nicht nur um einen Support Class,
der nicht alles macht.
Jack ist super kritisch.
Wir wollten ihn als deinen besten Freund
als deine beste Freundin
wie alle anderen Classes.
Ich will Jack!
Ich will, dass Jack mich folgt.
Und jetzt gibt es so viel Bedrohung für Jack.
Wenn du ihn spielst,
fährst du immer diese kleinen Pferde.
Und er hat so eine verrückte Ultimate.
Nice, nice, nice.
Jetzt kann der Troll herumfliegen.
Stadia ist in 33 Minuten.
Kann das Fisch gekillt werden?
Ich glaube, wir haben Exalted vergessen gerade.
Nee, nicht bei den Twitter-Nachrichten.
Das müssen die schon sagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du deine Basis bewegen oder einfach lassen willst.
Sie sind optional.
Aber sie bieten eine Menge Kraft, um deine Perle zu steuern, um Fortifikationen zu kaufen.
Wenn du sie alleine verlässt, ist es in deinem Verlust.
Aber wenn du ambitioniert bist und dein Team weiß, was sie tun,
können sie ihre Basis langsam erweitern, um mehr Territorie zu kontrollieren.
Guck mal hier oben. Seht ihr das hier oben?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Das sah nach Ingame-Währung aus.
Und ich habe zwei Ingame-Währungen gesehen.
Und zwei Ingame-Währungen schreien schon gerade zu.
Die schreien schon gerade zu nach Microtransactions und Shop.
Sie haben ja gut mit Gears so vor.
und sie lehnt sich über und öffnet einen Stich von Schnee und sie sieht eine Reflexion der Omen, die an ihr zurückblickt.
In der Realität gibt es Elektronik in dieser Konsole, es gibt keinen Weg, dass wir eine Omen mit zwei Fingern darin legen können.
Also mussten wir eine optische Illusion kreieren, die so aussehen würde, als ob eine Omen unter dem Eis eingeschraubt wäre.
Wir konnten die Idee ausdrücken, indem wir diese Eiskracken über die Omen laserrechten.
Wir haben noch nie so viel laserreicht. Ich meine, die Laserrechnung ist überall auf der Konsole.
Das Eis kreist überall auf der Konsole.
Die Thematik des Controller nach Kate Diaz war wirklich ungewöhnlich, weil sie der Hauptcharakter im Spiel ist und sie dieses arktische Umfeld besucht.
Sie trägt ein arktisches Armament, das neu im Spiel ist, was uns aufregend war.
Was auch immer wir mit Accessorien und Hardware arbeiten wollten, wollten wir die Familie mit dem, was die Konsole aussehen wird.
Und so konnten wir mit Seagate arbeiten.
Wir haben einen fantastischen 5TB und 2TB-Drucker, der im Grunde eine Mini-Version der Konsole aussehen wird.
Das wird auch perfekt aussehen.
Und wir arbeiten mit Razer auf einem Keyboard und Maus.
Das ist einer der ersten, ich glaube, wireless Keyboard und Maus auf der Konsole.
Und wir bekommen eine ganze Familie von Produkten, die alle zusammenpassen.
Arbeiten mit Rod ist eine tolle Erfahrung.
Er versteht, wie man die bedeutenden Momente bemerken kann, die wir als Industrie-Designer aufnehmen können.
Wir gehen immer in die physische Welt.
Wir gehen immer weg von diesen System-Kollaborationen mit ihm.
Ich fühle mich, als wäre dieses Produkt so authentisch.
Es könnte nicht mehr authentisch sein, weil es so nah an all unseren Gesprächen mit ihm verbunden ist.
Das ist fantastisch, diese Konsole.
Ich möchte es so sehr.
Ich habe den Rest von Seagate im Design.
Denn das ist unglaublich.
Und der Harddrive.
Aber es sieht so süß aus.
Aber das ist nicht alles, worüber wir sprechen müssen.
Wir haben auch ein paar Nachrichten mit unseren Freunden bei Valve.
Ja.
Erzähl uns ein bisschen mehr darüber.
Das erste Mal sind wir bei Steam gekommen.
Und heute kannst du heute die Vorbereitungen für Gears 5 auf Steam starten.
Und es wird Crossplay sein.
Ich vorbereite das nächste Mal.
Crossplay.
Partnership News für Gears heute.
Rod, bitte.
Ja.
Erzähl uns, was Gears mit Halo zu tun hat.
Also, wir haben über die ultime Edition gesprochen.
Wir haben über den ultimen Game Pass gesprochen.
Wir haben nicht wirklich darüber gesprochen, was du bekommst, wenn du das machst.
Also sind wir sehr froh, dass wir beantworte, dass wir zwei Charaktere von Halo Reach einbringen werden.
Sie werden zu Gears of War kommen.
Wir haben Kat und Emil.
Und sie werden kommen und sie haben ihre eigenen Rollen.
Sie werden spielbar sein in Horde und Escape und Versus.
Was zum Teufel hat Halo mit Gears zu tun?
Willst du über die beiden Ultimen sprechen?
Ja.
Also, wir haben wirklich versucht, sehr authentisch zu Halo zu sein.
Während wir es immer noch in die Gears-Welt integrieren.
Also, wir haben das Drop Shield auf Emil.
Und wir haben, wir haben nach Reach geschaut.
Und wir wollten etwas machen, was Halo-Fans wirklich als das echte Drop Shield erkennen würden.
Und dann haben wir das Hologramm auf Kat.
Und es ist, du weißt, sie ist die...
Das ist keine Ahnung.
Die Marcos-Phoenix in Mario Kart.
Und es sind die gleichen Charaktere.
Also, wir sind rausgekommen und haben den originalen Pass bekommen.
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Und so, nach einer Jahrhunderte, haben wir sie zurückgebracht in die Kabine.
Und wir haben es wieder aufgeschaut.
Es sind kleine Details.
Und wisst ihr was?
Wir haben ein Video, das genau das zeigt.
Schaut es euch an.
Sieht fantastisch aus.
Die Charaktere in Reach waren so flach.
Ich kann mich da überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Aber Leute, ich hab's euch gesagt.
Dieses Jahr auf Pressekonferenzen ist yeah und wow und selbst feiern ist der neueste Trend.
Endlich wieder zwei Nichtsagende Halo-Charaktere, die schon jeder vergessen hat.
Ich hab's schon erlebt.
Seit E3.
Du musst es wirklich wegnehmen.
Bitte, Benny, wasch etwas für die Mädchen.
Wachen, manchmal.
Ja, ja, ja.
Waschen, bitte.
Ja, ich meine, wir arbeiten mit den Leuten von Bathing Ape.
Sie haben eine Ape-Line.
Ihr habt eine Tease von E3 mit unserem Blau.
Ja.
Und ihr seht, wir machen das auch im Spiel.
Das Blau kommt in das Spiel.
Und ihr werdet ein Teil der Kamo-Effekte sein.
Weil die meisten Leute mitgerissen werden, wenn jemand neben ihnen klatscht.
Und dann haben wir eine physische Line, die sollte jetzt rot sein.
Eine rote Kamo-Effekte.
Ich wahrgucke.
Frage mich, warum die Leute applaudieren.
Weil die meisten Leute mitgerissen werden, wenn jemand neben ihnen klatscht.
Nee, die werden nicht bezahlt.
Die lädt Microsoft einfach ein und dann hast du halt ein paar passende Klatscher verteilt.
Und dann klatschen die Leute mit.
Das ist ansteckend.
Ich erzähl's euch gleich.
Ich hab's schon mal beschrieben.
Oh.
Was?
Mich haben sie ja auch debatet als Klatschereimer.
Als ob so ein Excited Clown da eigentlich so, klar!
Und wahrscheinlich haben wir sogar noch ein paar vergessen.
Wie kann ich meine Hände auf das Hoodie holen, weil es nicht hier ist?
Nein, es ist nicht hier.
Das ist übelst Resident-Sleeper, was interessiert mich den Gears of War Hoodie?
Zeig mal irgendwas Interessantes, bitte!
Oh, so excited für das Hoodie!
Wir sind auf der Bühne, aber ihr geht direkt zu den Gamescom Opening Night Broadcast.
Könnt ihr uns erzählen, was da los ist?
Ah, ja.
Also, seit E3 haben wir viele Leute gefragt, was die Kampagne angeht.
Wir haben darüber geredet.
Ja, zeig mal was vom Singleplayer.
Ja, zeig mal die Story, da bin ich gespannt drauf.
Auf Mixer? Wie, nur auf Mixer?
Na komm, Leute, Halo! Da muss jetzt noch irgendwas kommen!
Don't forget.
Gears 5 Ultimate Edition launches September 6.
Included in the Xbox Game Pass Ultimate.
I am so excited.
So, who's gonna be picking it up on the 6th?
Yeah!
Was mit Halo?
But that's all from us here at Gamescom!
Remember, the fun continues next month.
All inside Xbox, September 26th!
And keep up with everything Gamescom!
Und in the corner of your drive, on Mixer.com slash Xbox on Tuesday and Wednesday.
noch eine sache zum schluss jetzt haut noch mal was raus leute das war hyper
residents liefer diesmal
vor zehn zeigen uns nichts wir zeigen uns nichts das hat jetzt nicht gelohnt
heute zu gucken das war mega langweilig ich habe jetzt
gehofft dass wenigstens noch mal was zum 19 zum neuen halo kommt
am schluss oder so
ich wollte sehen ob sie cortana eine noch größere oberweite verpasst haben
als die anzeige ist raus wir müssen euch mal die
entwicklung angucken das nicht normal in den ersten beiden halo games hatte
cortana faktisch keine oberweite und ab halo 3 ist es immer größer geworden
das war es wirklich da kommt nichts halo mäßiges mehr
gut dann suchen wir uns jetzt den stream für google raus
und
in der zwischenzeit kann ja mal die geschichte erzählen was das mit microsoft
und dem klatschen auf sich hat also ich glaube das war die gamescom 2016 ich bin
nicht mal ganz so sicher ist aber auch praktisch aber im prinzip wurscht ja ob
das jetzt 2015 also 17 kann sich gewesen 17 war ich nicht da ich glaube es war
die gamescom 2016 also zu zeiten wo ich noch ein bisschen aktiver auf youtube ja
und noch ab zumal was hochgeladen habe
da habe ich mir überlegt weißt du was letztes jahr gamescom war nice fest dieses
jahr wieder hin aber dieses mal machen wir das ein bisschen ein bisschen
geplanter Hazard ist geplant
mal von euch zufälligerweise hier nicht belastet
minister
von google carter wir machen wir waren tinke starrti t
twitter
die starte
ad jobs stadia twitter
und um worshipping twitter 162 Что說?
Und dann gucken wir einfach mal, was die gepostet haben.
Was auf YouTube ist das nur?
Live in one hour.
Take a friend and you'll be watching.
YouTube.
Ah ja.
In 20 Minuten.
Dann mache ich nochmal kurz ein bisschen Musik an.
Oh nee, machen wir nicht.
Irgendwas anderes.
Na gut. Zumindest habe ich mir gedacht,
okay, wir machen das ein bisschen
organisierter,
wie letztes Mal bei der Gamescom.
Nicht
no female vocal, no vocal.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
So,
in der Zwischenzeit warten wir hier mal.
Also, zumindest, wo bin ich stehen geblieben?
Genau, ich habe gedacht, wir machen das ein bisschen organisierter,
wie letztes Jahr.
Und haben uns im Vorfeld darum gekümmert,
dass wir eben ein paar Termine kriegen.
Und da habe ich alle möglichen Leute mal angeschrieben.
Was habe ich? Activision, EA, Ubisoft,
Nvidia, Microsoft.
Und
Microsoft hat gesagt, oh, das ist ja richtig
cool.
Was haltet ihr denn davon?
Wenn ihr schon, also ihr, klar, ihr könnt
uns auf der Gamescom besuchen.
Komm, machen wir einen Termin, Gamescom,
wo uns alles ankommt.
Aber was haltet ihr denn davon?
Ein bisschen leiser.
Okay, ein bisschen leiser.
Wo habe ich es denn?
Okay.
Ähm.
Ja, aber was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn ihr einen Tag vor der Gamescom,
ich meine, da sind die meisten Leute ja schon da.
Was haltet ihr denn davon, wenn ihr schon auf unsere,
auf unsere Pressekonferenz einen Tag vor der Gamescom kommt?
Haben sie doch, haben sie auch erzählt, ja,
kannst du exklusiv die Sachen schon ansprechen.
Anspielen, gibt auch kostenloses Zeug zu futtern.
Haben wir gesagt, wisst ihr was, Leute?
Ich bin mit dem, mit dem, mit dem Mesh hingefahren.
Ähm.
Und haben uns gesagt, eigentlich, eigentlich eine coole Geschichte.
Machen wir. Machen wir.
Und, äh, als wir uns dann da angemeldet haben,
ich muss jetzt gerade mal den, den, den, den Titel,
den Titel vom Stream
aktualisieren.
Gamescom,
Google Stadia Pressekonferenz,
19 Uhr. Danach,
danach, wie heißt das, was danach kommt?
Nach Google Stadia,
äh, Xbox Gamescom Night
oder so.
Night, oder irgendwie sowas, ne?
Gamescom
Opening.
Wie heißt das so? Moment, ich erzähl, ich, ich
erzähl's euch. Mal kurz gucken,
dass der Titel stimmt, weil es geht ja schon in 15
Minuten weiter. Ähm.
Ist heute nicht Modern Warfare Präsentation?
Äh, weiß man nicht.
Äh, genau. So, wie hieß dieser
Kram jetzt hier? Opening Night.
Äh.
Gucken wir mal, wie weit wir da
kommen. Wie interessant das ist.
So. Titel sollte
aktualisiert sein, wenn's das jetzt hingekriegt hat.
Okay, also, wo, wo bin ich
stehen geblieben? Genau, also Microsoft gerade kommt
vorbei, alles super, alles toll. Und da haben wir
uns gerade gehört, das klingt doch gut, das machen wir.
Und, ähm, es ist in der Regel
immer, immer nice, wenn man bei
solchen Sachen quasi direkt vom
Hersteller eingeladen wird.
Das ist immer, das ist eigentlich am, am unproblematischsten
immer bei solchen Geschichten.
Und haben wir gerade gehört, das ist nice.
Gehen wir hin. Und als wir dann da hingekommen
sind, ähm, haben sie uns erst mal
in so einen extra Raum geführt.
Und, ähm, haben uns erst mal erzählt,
so nach dem Motto, oh, wie toll das hier alles ist.
Also, bevor wir überhaupt irgendwas gesehen haben,
haben wir erst mal erzählt, wie, wie, wie super und, und toll
das Ganze ist. Und haben uns jeder so
einen Microsoft, ähm,
Microsoft Goodie Bag in die Hand gedrückt.
Und wir haben halt da gesessen und haben uns gedacht, oh, nice,
cool. Und auf einmal sagt dann
so einer von denen, oder eine
von den, von den Anheizgrills, die sie da hatten,
ähm,
sagt dann so, ah, Jungs, hier, packt doch mal,
also, nee, hab ich nicht gesagt, Jungs, äh, Leute,
packt doch mal, waren ja auch Mädels bei, äh,
packt doch mal hier, äh, packt doch mal die Box aus,
guckt mal rein. Und da war halt zufälligerweise
ein Xbox-T-Shirt drin, ne?
Auf dem drauf stand,
ähm,
ich ver...
Versucht das gerade noch zusammenzukriegen.
Da stand auf dem Xbox-T-Shirt
steht, ich hab das heute noch, ich zieh das heute immer noch
gern an, stand sowas drauf wie,
ich war dabei,
also, also auf Englisch, ähm,
irgendwie, ich war dabei, ähm,
als die größten und besten
Games aller Zeiten vorgestellt wurden.
Sowas stand da drauf.
So, I, I witnessed the greatest games
of all times. Irgendwie sowas. Also,
so ein bisschen, bisschen, bisschen dick aufgetragen
war das Ganze schon, was da drauf gestanden hat.
Und dann hab ich gesagt, ja, zieh das doch mal an.
Und dann hab ich mir gesagt, alter,
ich hab hier, sich,
ich hab hier Zeug schon an, ich zieh,
wenn ich das hier drüber zieh, da seh ich ja
Hyper Kokona aus, äh.
Und dann haben sich dann da,
30 Typen
oben ohne gemacht und das
Xbox-T-Shirt angezogen, erst mal.
Und da war ich noch einer der Schlankeren bei.
Äh,
das war nicht so unbedingt der
nicest Anblick.
Naja, zumindest, ähm, die Mädels hatten kein Problem,
die konnten sich das direkt oben drüber ziehen.
Aber bei mir hätt das halt überhaupt nicht gepasst.
So, und dann haben sie uns da da
reingeschleust und ich, ey, wie kam mir das
alles schon ab diesem Zeitpunkt sehr
merkwürdig vor, ne?
Dann haben sie uns da da durchgeführt und da haben sie auch schon,
ihre, ihre, ihre Gaming-Area aufgebaut
und sowas. Und die haben uns als erstes
in diesen Pressekonferenzsaal
reingeschleust.
Da war noch kein Mensch da.
Wir sind so an den Rocket Beans und alle da gestanden
und da haben sie uns, da durften wir vorbeilaufen,
ne, da war noch kein Einlass und wir durften
schon rein. Ich hab erst gedacht, boah, ist ja nice, aber irgendwie
ist mir's dann gedämmert, so nach dem Motto,
irgendwas, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht, ja.
Und da haben sie uns dann in die erste
Reihe buxiert.
Das ergibt das nämlich auch alles Sinn.
Die haben uns da als Xbox-Fans hingesehen.
Die haben uns ein Xbox-T-Shirt
angezogen, in die erste
Reihe gehockt
und haben gehofft, dass wir jetzt
den, den super-excited
Klatscher machen. Und die haben uns da
natürlich dann auch ein bisschen angeheizt und wieder
erzählt, wie super-kandios toll das ist.
Und das, und das Beste war,
ähm, dass danach,
danach, die haben das so hingestellt,
so quasi, dass dann danach, wenn man
fertig ist, dass es danach nochmal
irgendwie so eine exklusive
Interview-Runde mit, ähm,
war das schon, war das schon Phil Spencer
oder war es noch, es war noch, war schon Phil Spencer,
genau, äh, danach nochmal gibt
für die exklusiven Xbox, äh,
Premium-VIPs
genutzt. Ich hatte mein Leben lang mit Xbox
nix am Hut, ja. Also, die haben anscheinend
wirklich händeringend nach Leuten gesucht, die das Ganze
machen, weil, also, dass mal
der Max irgendwo Xbox-VIP ist,
da hätte ich im Leben selbst nicht dran geglaubt. Egal.
Und, ähm,
haben wir da halt gesessen und haben sie auch
so ein Typ besitzen gehabt mit, mit, äh,
VR-Kamerade, das Ganze dann super 3D,
äh, den ganzen Hype und Excitement
dokumentiert, ja.
Und wir haben dann halt da wirklich
gesessen, um uns zu freuen.
Und die haben dann
dazwischen drin auch Microsoft-Leute gesetzt.
Die haben sich auch später entlarvt,
dass da Microsoft-Leute
dabei gehockt haben, halt mit dem normalen
Xbox, also mit dem, mit dem Xbox-Fan-T-Shirt
an. Und, ähm,
da wurde dann versucht,
übertrieben zu hypen.
Und, ähm, im Nachhinein muss ich
sagen, war die Pressekonferenz, wo wir gewesen
sind, viel besser als das, was wir heute gesehen
haben. Ähm, dort wurden nämlich
Games gezeigt. Es wurden
viele Games gezeigt, die bis heute nicht rausgekommen sind.
Oder, doch, mittlerweile schon.
Es wurde, Dings hier gezeigt, Scalebound,
das haben sie eingestellt. Es wurde zum ersten Mal
Quantum Break gezeigt, übelst nice, das Game.
Es wurde, Dings, gezeigt, äh, äh, ähm,
Crackdown, was dann irgendwie noch, noch
ewig gebraucht hat, bis es raus war.
Ähm, also, besser,
besser als der Kram heute war das auf jeden Fall.
Und, ja,
das ist die Story zu, wie ich zur Microsoft-Klatscher
geworden bin. Und ihr glaubt
das nicht, wenn
ihr da vorne sitzt.
Oder ich hab mich in die zweite Reihe gehockt.
Es gibt, wahrscheinlich, also,
wahrscheinlich müsstet ihr mich sogar, also, ihr wisst ja nicht, wie ich
ausstehe, aber, ähm, den Felix hab ich
gesehen im Video danach. Wir haben danach extra
nochmal geguckt, ob er uns irgendwie gesehen hat.
Ähm,
und ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie ansteckend
das ist.
Ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie ansteckend das ist,
wenn man da sitzt und, und, und,
und hinter Neba und links,
rechts, neben einem und hinter einem
klatschen die Leute und
auf der Bühne steht einer, der super excited
ist. Das ist wirklich ansteckend.
Schon von RTX
in Minecraft gehört, ja? Wundert mich auch,
dass die da heute nix bei Microsoft erzählt haben.
Ich mein, Minecraft ist doch der, der
Shit bei Microsoft.
Wir haben den Kram doch für was, weiß ich nicht, wie viele
Millionen gekauft. Ja, Xbox
ist ja auch gar nicht mehr Xbox-rein Konsolen bezogen.
Die Java Edition bekommt nix,
das wundert mich nicht, ja.
Wonka, Wonka Java, äh.
Ja, das hat mich gewundert, dass die nix
zu, zu, zu Minecraft erzählt haben.
Xbox ist ja bei Microsoft mittlerweile
und ich denke spätestens
ab der nächsten Konsolengeneration wird man es auch sehen,
dass Xbox
nichts mehr ist,
also im Kopf bei Microsoft auch,
was, was reine, was sich
rein auf eine, eine Hardware-Xbox
bezieht, sondern eher auf
Xbox an sich so als
Gaming-Plattform und nicht unbedingt auf die
Xbox-Hardware. So Leute,
ich hab jetzt hier ein Brötchen stehen,
ob ich euch was ins Ohr schmatzen soll.
Aber irgendwann muss ich heute Abend noch mal was
futtern. Guck mal, ob ihr mich
essen hört. Mal gucken, ob das...
Ne, nein, sie hört mich nicht essen, das ist schon mal gut.
Aktuell esse ich
paar Heidelbeeren. Und ihr kennt mich,
da werde ich nicht satt von.
Social Eating, genau.
So, 9 Minuten 40 geht's los.
Ja, das ist so viel zur Story
von, ähm,
wie ich zum Microsoft-Klatschen
mal gekommen bin.
Achso, wir wollten noch gucken, wo der, wo der in
Frankfurt
wo der Entwickler sitzt.
Deck 13.
Gucken, wo die sind.
Goethestraße, Louis Vito Store.
Teil die Kollektion Bar.
Fick auf Sponsor.
Ne, Moment.
Das, wo ist denn das?
Wo ist der Bahnhof irgendwo, ne?
Ah, das ist ein
Stückchen
weg von uns.
Das ist die
Zeil.
Moment, hier ist die Hauptwache.
Ja, ne, da ist doch, da ist doch Crytek auch um die Ecke irgendwo.
Die sind doch auch hier irgendwo.
Das ist doch alles, die, die sind doch irgendwo an der Hauptwache, Crytek.
Ups, warum Shop?
Warum hab ich jetzt nach Shopping gesucht eigentlich?
Waren die nicht an der Hauptwache?
Ne, sind sie anscheinend nicht.
Vielleicht sind die umgezogen.
Ich bin nicht mehr eingekrallt, Crytek war früher an der Hauptwache.
Ne, die sind an der
Hanauer Landstraße. Das ist die Hanauer Landstraße, oder?
Das ist die Hanauer Landstraße.
Ach, die sind hier. Hier ist auch der D6 irgendwo.
Hier ist doch irgendwo auch der D6.
Also, D6 ist
somit der größte Internetknotenpunkt
der Welt, oder zumindest in Europa.
Interaction, hier.
Hier ist der D6.
Das ist so, ich weiß nicht, ob es der
größte Internetknotenpunkt der Welt ist,
aber auf jeden Fall saumäßig
groß. Der größte der Welt,
ja.
Da haben die sich einen guten Standort ausgesucht. Ich hoffe mal,
die haben schnelles Internet bei Crytek.
Ich meine, es ist nicht weit, ne?
Also, hier ist quasi der schnellste
der größte Internetknotenpunkt
der Welt und da oben ist Crytek.
Ich hoffe, die haben einen ordentlichen Internetanschluss.
Ich bilde mir an, Crytek war
früher an der Hauptwache irgendwo aus. Kann sein, dass ich
voll daneben blicke.
Der Rüpel, Stufe 1, Nummer 2,
äh, nein, äh, zweiter Monat.
Pock. Nice, danke schön.
Von Crytek dahin
kommst du ja fast mit einer Richtfunkantenne.
Oder du buddelst dir einfach
ein Kabel drunter durch.
Nämlich, ja, gleich geht Google los in 6 Minuten.
White Lion 58
Lesebit. Was?
Ähm, Void Danny
Twitch Prime, danke schön. Pock.
So, ich mute
mich mal ganz kurz und beiß mal in mein Brötchen
rein. Bad Company 3
kommt ja mit der neuen Konsolengeneration raus.
Das ist alles
nur Gerücht bisher. Ich meine, es deutet
alles darauf hin
und, ähm,
das liegt von dem, von dem
wie hieß der Typ?
Der, der schon vor 2 Jahren Bad Company
und, und World War 1 geleakt hat.
Ähm,
bei World War 2 geleakt hat.
Hab vergessen, wie der Typ. Deck?
Irgendwas mit Deck? Mighty Deck? Oder so?
Also, da, ich, ich, ich
gehe auch davon aus, dass was dran ist mit
Bad Company 3. Aber bisher ist das
nur Gerücht.
Kommen die neue Herbst
20. Es gab doch irgendwie Gerüchte,
dass wann, äh,
wann, wann war das genau?
Ne, warte mal, ähm, nicht PS4.
PS5. Es gab doch Gerüchte
über ein Release Date.
Also März 2020 glaube ich nicht.
März
2020, ähm,
da hätten sie jetzt mal langsam, aber
sicher schon angefangen, die Werbetrommel zu rühren
und, äh, da ist die
Gamescom eigentlich die letzte Variante, ähm,
diesem, diesem Jahr. Deswegen glaube ich
nicht. Deswegen glaube ich eher, dass es
Ende des Jahres 2020 wird.
Xbox kommt Herbst 2020.
Ist das, ist das auch schon...
Wie heißt die denn eigentlich? Die heißt ja, die heißt ja bestimmt nicht
Xbox.
Xbox 2, oder?
Scarlet, Scarlet. Ich finde,
Microsoft hat richtig
gute, ähm,
Projektnamen.
Beispiel Project Natal für Kinect.
Und dann kommen so Zungenbrecher raus. Kinect.
Ich meine, Xbox Scarlet.
Ich finde, ich, ich hab mich da schon mal über den Namen
drüber ausgelassen, dass ich den Namen übelst pock finde,
ja. Ähm,
ich finde, Xbox Scarlet,
das klingt irgendwie edel,
ja.
Das, ich,
ich finde, das klingt gut.
Das sollten sie beibehalten.
Denkst du, es würde seinem Namen gerecht werden?
Du meinst, mit Company 3? Pff, keine Ahnung.
Ich hoffe mal, dass sie das
auf die Reihe kriegen.
Hallo, darf man nicht anklicken.
Weihnachtsjahr, ja.
Ah ja. Okay, das ist anscheinend offiziell.
Ende 2020.
Dann kommt die PS4, äh, die PS5 auch so in den Dreh.
Oder Sony ist diesmal ein bisschen langsam.
Kommt wieder ein bisschen später, wie bei der PS3.
Aber das glaube ich nicht.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Ja, ich denke, auch Ende 2020.
Aber Scarlet klingt gut, oder?
Finde ich auch.
Warum machst du keine Sub-E-Modes?
Oh, da gibt es was Neues zu.
Ich habe heute auf Fiverr
jemand beauftragt, Sub-E-Modes zu machen.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
ob das was wird.
Ich habe gedacht, ich probiere das jetzt einfach mal über Fiverr.
Fiverr, 14 Euro pro E-Mode.
Das ist nicht teuer,
muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen.
Ja, das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Ich habe ihm gesagt, also ich habe ihm
verschiedene, ich habe ihm geschrieben,
ich habe ein paar Ideen, aber so wirklich,
so wirklich, wirklich gute Idee habe ich nicht.
Er soll einfach mal kreativ sein.
Was?
Wie ging das?
Embedded? Oh, Leute, ihr müsst mir mal helfen.
Oh, wie ging das? Embedded?
Fuck.
Ah.
Wie ging das? Wie ging das mit dem Embedded nochmal?
Fuck it.
Was? V mit V ersetzen?
Ne, fuck, was?
Wie? Oh, shit.
Okay, Leute, wartet.
Wartet mal, wartet mal.
VLC.
Oh, fuck, wie kriege ich denn den...
Wie kriege ich denn den Kack jetzt angezeigt?
Oh, der Rick.
Der Rick 535.
Der kriegt jetzt einen Sub geschenkt von mir.
Fuck.
Ich muss meinen eigenen Sub bezahlen.
Ich habe keinen PayPal eingerichtet.
Rick, du kriegst nachher einen Sub geschenkt.
Ich muss meinen PayPal erst eintragen.
Hört man schon was?
Oh.
Bewegt sich.
Noch kein Sound da.
Oh, jetzt.
Hey, everyone.
I'm Ray from the Stadia team.
I'm here today to give you a brief update on Stadia,
the new generation gaming platform,
where you can buy the games you want
and play them across your favorite screens.
We're also going to reveal more games
that you'll be able to play on Stadia,
starting this November.
Instead of needing to buy a console to play your games,
we give you access to Google's powerful custom data centers.
Our servers are designed with today's most demanding games in mind.
To ensure your games run at the highest graphical settings
and frame rate available today.
You can just fire up Stadia to play your games on your TV,
desktop,
laptop
and select tablets and smartphones.
With Stadia, you get 4K gameplay
without annoying game downloads, patches, installs...
Das haben die gerade schlecht zusammengeschnitten, oder?
The days of waiting to download and update a new game are over.
Just grab your controller and you're in.
To play Stadia, you'll need the Stadia Founders Edition,
which you can pre-order today for only $1.29.
It comes with three months of Stadia Pro,
Ich kann auch einfach warten, bis es rauskommt.
a Stadia Controller and a Chromecast Ultra
to play on the biggest screen in your home.
And as an added bonus,
Founders will already have the full Destiny 2 experience
in their Stadia library,
ready to play from day one.
Wenn ich möchte, habe ich das auf Steam auch jetzt.
And are almost sold out of Founders Edition in some countries.
So, if you want to be one of the very first gamers on Stadia later this year,
you'll need to get your Founders Edition,
so that you can play Stadia quickly.
In our last Stadia Connect,
we showed you a collection of launch titles coming to Stadia
from the best publishers and developers in the world.
Warum muss ich mir dafür überhaupt kein extra Gerät kaufen?
And we keep adding more games to the Stadia Catalog.
Egal.
Whether you're looking for a mythological storybook adventure
in Gods and Monsters,
or a chance to take back London
with a team of specialists in Watch Dogs Legion,
Ubisoft has you covered with both games coming to Stadia.
So let's get to it.
I'm going to pass it off to my friend Shauna,
another member of the Stadia team,
who will run you through some more big names to add to that list.
Hi, I'm Shauna.
And I'm excited to share the latest titles we're adding to the Stadia portfolio.
My team and I have been traveling all over the world.
For years we've been meeting with the best catalogers and publishers
with the goal of bringing more of your favorite games to Stadia.
We've been to Japan, England, Germany, the US, Canada, and most recently Poland.
Our first video is with CD Projekt Red,
who are making one of the most anticipated games of 2020.
And it's coming to Stadia. Let's take a look.
This is my Watch Dogs, huh?
Stadia, it's not Stadia.
If you replace your body with a machine, are you still human?
Is it possible to maintain individualism without any human parts?
No, not Watch Dogs. Cyberpunk.
Maybe that individualism is actually what creates humanity in us.
It rattles, by the way. Just noticed.
CD Projekt Red has always been a company
that put a very big emphasis on the story, storytelling
and creating a very strong emotion in players.
I'm sorry.
It's a bit quieter than the other one, right?
We're adding a whole new sort of pillar to it,
which is what we call open-ended gameplay.
It has non-linearity in storytelling,
non-linearity in the way you explore the world.
And now we want to introduce non-linearity in gameplay.
You can play your character any way you would like to play him.
I like to complete missions in a way
that I have managed to outsmart my opponents.
No matter what game it is,
I always play big, butch characters
that kind of plow through everything.
And all these things have an effect
in how your story plays out.
My first member of the band, the myth, Johnny Silverhand.
Good morning, Night City.
The song on the radio is by rocker Johnny Silverhand.
Johnny Silverhand, who's a legend in Night City,
a musician, but also an activist.
We were creating this character
and as we were in the process, we realized,
hey, it would be really cool
if Keanu Reeves could play this character.
Breathtaking.
Keanu Reeves is amazing.
Johnny Silverhand will be our player's guide to the city.
He's with you throughout most of the game.
Wake up, samurai.
We have a city to burn.
This project is of a scale that we've never tackled before.
The ambition is crazy.
Something like Stadia really allows more people
to experience our stories.
Everyone gets to experience the same awesome story,
quests and locations.
It's so good.
It's a very technologically demanding game,
but with Stadia you can actually play it
with the power of your devices.
There are many things that people
are gonna have very strong feelings about.
I hope that the lens of the game
and the lens of the future will show them
in an exaggerated way
things that are already happening in our society.
And hopefully our future is gonna be better
than the grim future of Cyberpunk 2077.
Wieder perfekt den Sound abgemischt.
Ich finde, manche Spiele sieht man,
denen sieht man schon eine gewisse Qualität an,
auch wenn man den Trailer sieht.
Und manche sehen einfach 0 nach 15 generic aus.
Und das, finde ich zumindest,
versprüht eine gewisse Qualität.
Rein beim Angucken.
Das ist schwierig festzumachen,
woran und weshalb.
Das war doch garantiert gerade eine Entschuldigung, oder?
Es stimmt überhaupt nicht,
dass ihr das zu der World revealed.
Die waren eben eine Stunde vorher,
hat man das auch schon gesehen.
Nightmares plague our galaxy.
Your past confronts you, guardian.
End to it.
Ja, das hatten wir gerade ja bei Microsoft schon.
Excited counter, ach so, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, wo wir sind, bei 5?
You haven't seen darkness.
Not yet.
A great battle approaches.
Wie ich schon bei Microsoft gesagt habe,
für Leute, die Destiny spielen,
ist es bestimmt toll.
Oder besser gesagt,
ich kann es nicht einschätzen.
A trio of adorable machines
decide to follow their hearts
and form a band.
Help them chase their dreams
in the upcoming 3D-Puzzle-Platformer.
Kind.
Das ist mal gut.
Bla bla bla bla.
Gameplay.
So muss das sein.
Schade, aber du kannst.
Jetzt fehlt noch der Epic-Sucks-Guy eigentlich dabei.
Ich meine,
das Game muss ich nun wirklich nicht über Stadia streamen, oder?
Das sieht jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig anspruchsvoll aus,
als dass ich es nicht auf irgendeiner x-beliebigen Kiste
nicht daheim ablaufen lassen kann.
Mich würde interessieren,
ob die ein bisschen was zu der Technik dahinter erzählen,
wie sie beispielsweise schneller als Lichtgeschwindigkeit sein wollen.
Würde mich mal interessieren.
Jetzt wartet mal ab.
Gleich kommt, gleich kommt der Nvidia-Dude
und schreit RTX und...
schreit RTX on und dann wird hier geratet raced auf einmal.
Wie soll er...
Up next is Darksiders Genesis.
A brand new take on a beloved adventure franchise.
Ja, Flame Haze, das geht ja nicht.
Deswegen frage ich mich, wie sie das mit Input-Lag
und generell Lag in halbwegs anspruchsvollen Games
auf die Reihe kriegen wollen.
Moment, ist das ein Diablo Darksiders?
Darksiders 1 war übertrieben pock.
2 war auch gut.
3 habe ich nicht gespielt.
Hat mir nicht gefallen im Vorfeld.
Und das ist jetzt ein Darksiders Diablo.
Das passt aber zu Darksiders eigentlich.
Und einen netten Soundtrack haben sie.
Ach, YouTube-Leist. Ja, ist gut.
Muss man mal eine Maus daraus machen.
Hat man nicht Nachteile beim Online-Spielen?
Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Also im Vergleich zu lokal auf jeden Fall.
Der Stream ist laut,
weil die alle ihre Sounds nicht abmischen können.
Weil jetzt kommt das Gelaber, das ist jetzt wieder leise.
For our next deeper look at a new exclusive game
coming to Stadia,
the talented team at Robot Entertainment
are here to introduce you to the next installment
of their popular franchise,
Works Must Die.
Das ist Tower Defense.
Das ist doch Tower Defense Game, oder?
Wie ist eigentlich die Lautstärke? Passt doch, ne?
Schon mal ein Stück leiser.
Das ist auch so ein Game, wo du nicht unbedingt über Stadia spielen musst.
Warum muss man so Games über Stadia spielen?
Ich mein, das läuft ja auf jedem 0 nach 15 PC.
Der kann sogar so uralt sein, dass es denn jeder bei sich daheim stehen hat.
Oder auf jeder Konsole oder auf nem Tablet.
Woah, woah, woah!
Is the Sorceress teaching them that?
Aber Leute, ich find das gut, wie die das machen.
Blablabla, Gameplay, blablabla, Gameplay, so muss das sein.
Nicht dieses Excitement-Gelaber.
Hat der Jörg schon recht.
Smorg.
Jetzt ist wieder die Sprache, ist wieder leise.
A 500 mob army.
Ups.
You can't win.
Brokelt!
My name is Jerome Jones.
Stadia Experience.
I'm the design director here at Robot Entertainment.
We really just wanna make games that people wanna play and share with their friends.
My name is Patrick Hudson.
I'm the CEO of Robot Entertainment.
When you're making an interactive experience, you know it's going to end up in somebody's hands.
You want them to feel something.
You wanna connect with that player.
That matters.
That means something to us.
Musik?
The other people that Orcs Must Die is a puzzle game.
Each level is a puzzle.
You're a hero.
You're trying to stop a bunch of bad guys from getting into your house.
We get a lot of letters.
Wo ist mein Haus?
Das da?
You guys make OMD 3 already?
Just make OMD 3.
Give us what we want.
So we're doing it.
I think from Orcs Must Die 3 fans can expect more of everything they love.
It's just a bigger setting.
The physics are over the top.
And so that just creates a really fun landscape for uh, for orc mayhem and orc destruction.
Wo gehst du hin, hm?
Wir wurden eingeladen, Stadia im Januar 2018 zu prüfen.
Google handelte die Controller und erlaubte uns eine frühere Version von Doom auf Stadia zu spielen.
Und es war großartig.
Es war eine fantastische Erfahrung.
Und ich habe sofort gesehen, dass die nächste transformierende Plattform in die Industrie kommt.
Das gleiche Gefühl hatte ich, als ich das iPhone gesehen habe und was das für Spiele bedeuten könnte.
Wir wussten, dass wir ein Teil davon sein wollten.
Als ich das iPhone gesehen habe, wusste ich, dass es für Spiele nicht unbedingt gut ist.
Seitdem hat Mobile Crap Überhand genommen.
Und das war abzusehen.
Das ist ein großes Problem.
Ich habe immer Orks Szenarien gewünscht, in denen man sich nicht gewinnen kann.
Immer.
In den Kriegsszenarien werden wir jetzt eine 500-Mob-Armee haben.
In einer einzelnen Wave.
Und das ist nicht wie 50 Leute hier, 50 Leute hier, 50 Leute hier.
Das sind 500 Orks.
Das ist das, was Stadia ermöglicht hat.
Wenn wir in diesem Ort kommen, werden wir die Menschen damit erleben.
Nach 25 Jahren von klassischen Rückkehrszeiten.
Setzen Sie sich für Windjammer 2.
Was können wir denn haben?
Das ist Budget Lucio gewesen hier.
Budget Lucio.
Dann könnten Sie mal wenigstens RTX ON machen, dass wir schöne Raytracing-Effekte haben.
Alle Games, die meisten Games, die die zeigen, brauchst du kein Stadia zu.
Das läuft auf einem N64.
Hallo Freunde.
Habt ihr jemals in den Sonnenschein geschaut und überlegt, ob es möglich ist, auf anderen Planeten zu leben?
Das erinnert mich an diese, an Majora's Mask, an diese, an diese Farm.
Wie hieß die Farm?
Romani.
Die, die Romani-Farm.
Mit den Kühen und den Aliens.
Was sind das für Games?
Nach Phuc?
Was zum Teufel?
Warum guckt mir gerade der Kuh beim Scheißen zu im Livestream?
Nächstes Mal werden unsere Freunde von Warner Brothers euch erzählen, wie eine ihrer größten Franchises auf Stadia wiederhergestellt wird.
Hey, mein Name ist Aaron Piepergirdes und ich bin der Exekutivproduzent von Mortal Kombat.
Wir sind bekannt für unsere tolle Spielweise, unsere schnell-brutale Aktion und unsere über-die-top-Finish-Movements wie unsere Fatalities.
Teil der Grund, warum die Leute uns immer wieder zurückkehren, ist unser in-depth Story-Mode.
Ich finde es gut, dass die Games zeigen. Das finde ich wirklich gut. Es ist erfrischend im Vergleich zu Microsoft.
Und Mortal Kombat 11 ist genau da, wo Mortal Kombat X losging.
Du wirst viele neue Charaktere, die dir die Fans lieben, sehen.
Lass die neue Ära beginnen.
Wir haben auch einen zeitgemäßen Element zur Geschichte, damit du einige alte Versionen, präsente Versionen und sogar weitere Versionen dieser liebsten Charaktere sehen kannst.
Es wäre kein Mortal Kombat, wenn wir keine Fatalities hätten.
Und mit Mortal Kombat 11 haben wir bestimmt ein größeres Multiplayer-Deckel, als wir jemals produziert haben.
Ein tolles Kampfspiel beginnt mit dem Kampf. Es muss flügelig sein, es muss schnell sein, es muss präzis sein.
Spieler verbringen Stunden, um die Bewegungen zu trainieren, um das Timing genau zu erreichen.
Was wirklich kompetitiv ist, ist, dass Mortal Kombat nie online gespielt wird.
Ein Spiel wie uns ist sehr wichtig. Wir haben eine bestimmte Qualitätsbar, die wir behalten müssen.
Und mit Stadia fühlen wir uns, dass wir das erreichen können.
Seit dem Anfang des Entwicklungs von Mortal Kombat 11, haben wir die Spielweise verwendet, die wir an der Plattform verwendet haben.
Google hat uns die ganze Zeit mitgebracht.
Sie sind ein guter Partner, um sicherzustellen, dass wir die Qualität erreichen, die wir von unserem Spiel erwarten und die Spieler auch erwarten.
Eine der Gründe, warum wir auf der Plattform von Stadia gespannt sind, ist einfach die Einführung unserer Spieler.
Es ist spannend. Es ist legitim cool, die Spielweise aufzupassen und dann auf dein Handy zu gehen und es auf dem Handy zu spielen.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Wir freuen uns sehr, Mortal Kombat zu Stadia im November zu bringen.
Oh, wir haben den Excited-Counter vergessen.
Wir sind, wir sind bestimmt mittlerweile schon, keine Ahnung, bei 11 oder so.
Dank den Warner Brothers und den Netherrealm Studios für diesen Blick in ihren kreativen Prozess.
Wir haben die Ehre, ein neues Zuhause zu sein für eine der französischen Premiere-Franchise von Games.
Wenn die Welt nur bewegt, wenn du bewegt, werden Dinge wirklich seltsam, wirklich schnell.
Immerse dich in die stylische Aktion von Superhot.
Superhot. Superhot.
Superhot.
Das ist aber auch schon 5 Jahre alt, ne?
Dafür braucht man auch unbedingt Stadia jetzt, weil das Game lokal keiner schafft, ja?
Das ist aber auch schon 5 Jahre alt, das Game oder so was. Das ist uralt.
Morris1610.
Das Input-Lag wird sich in Grenzen halten, wenn du Singleplayer spielst.
Oder nicht so wild sein.
Aber niemand, der competitive online spielen will, spielt das gestreamt.
Keiner, der bei Verstand ist, spielt das gestreamt, wenn er wirklich Multiplayer spielt gegen andere Leute.
Guck mal, Leute geben massig Geld aus für einen Mini-Vorteil und dann streamen sie es.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Für Singleplayer-Spiele vollkommen okay.
Das ist der Landwirtschaftssimulator oder wie kommt der jetzt?
Huge.
Diese Musik dabei.
Jetzt kommen gleich die Zombies um die Ecke.
Die Musik, ey.
Da ist mal der Baum abgesägt.
Huge.
Baumsägen-Experience.
Ja.
Next Level Baumsäging.
Warum muss ich mir das jetzt ankommen?
Vor allem, als wäre das jetzt so übertrieben.
Action-packed Gameplay, ey.
Das ist Googles neue Server-Farm.
Ja, genau.
Das ist einfach gut, ey.
Da läuft Stadia drauf gerade.
Was?
Sekiro.
Oder?
Ne.
Was ist das?
Doch.
Tekken?
Ne.
Ne, nicht Sekiro.
Ich habe nur einen Weg.
Und das ist...
Shido.
Samurai-Stells-Clop-Game.
Mada, Mada.
Neat Healing.
Mace to the Face.
Was gucke ich mir da gerade an?
Einen Fighting-Game auf jeden Fall.
Samurai Showdown.
Aha!
We can't wait for you to play Grid on Stadia.
Let's have a look.
Wenigstens labern die nicht, sondern zeigen einfach Sachen.
zeigen einfach Sachen. Das gefällt mir schon mal gut.
Ich frag mich, ob diese Trailer
auch über Stadion laufen.
Jetzt ruckelt immer zwischendurch.
Das finde ich
ist keine gute Werbung für den Service.
Die wollen ja quasi beweisen,
Online-Games kann man gut
online spielen.
Und wenn es immer zwischendurch
ruckelt, ist das keine gute Werbung.
Previously, ja das stimmt.
Das war gut.
Ja, neues Doom.
Das macht bestimmt Bock.
Ich fand das letzte
auch...
Das letzte war eigentlich auch ganz nice.
Was mir auf den Keks gegangen ist,
vom letzten Doom...
Oh, hier.
Vom letzten Doom genervt,
da waren die Kill-Animationen.
Wo ist der Sebaru,
wenn man ihn braucht?
Cute Chat.
Okay, das ist nichts für mich.
Aber für alle Weeps unter uns
ist das wahrscheinlich
die Krönung des heutigen
Livestream-Tages.
Das Spiel sieht Woodface aus, okay.
Ich kenne weder die Vorlage, noch habe ich irgendwie den ersten Teil davon gespielt. Keine Ahnung.
Haben sie wenigstens die Originalsprecher?
Für Leute, die das kennen?
Ich sag, ich hab's nicht geguckt.
Entschreckt.
Oh, es kommt eh so.
Ja, eh so.
Die sind gar nicht so excited bei Google.
Das Game soll sich wohl richtig gut gemacht haben.
Nach dem schlechten Start.
Das ist nicht Skyrim, das ist eh so.
Diese Lauf-Animationen.
Konvir險 ist eigentlich ja float, also so eineubeweisezugές Call R creo.
じゃやた?」
Ja, das ist ein MMORPG.
Aber, aber eh so, hat wohl ziemlich guten,
Nennen wir's mal Singleplayer für den MMO.
Für den MMO.
Läuft das auf Linux? Kein Schimmer.
An Stadia wird auf Linux laufen, das wird ja gestreamt.
Hust roho daa!
Das Overlay passt echt gut dabei, oder?
Domo-Effekt.
Anthem Jack ist immer noch bester Bösewicht, aber...
Ich meine, es sagt null über das Game aus, ne?
Aber irgendwie passt der Trailer trotzdem.
Ich start mich so an!
Ubisoft.
Watch Dogs, hä?
Watch Dogs 3?
Ja.
Ich fand das erste Watch Dogs auch nicht gut.
Gekommnetet!
Gingen sie in Watchdog nicht mal ums Heck sohren?
Gehen wir weiter! Alle sind anders.
Du musst also entscheiden, was für dein Team am besten ist.
Aber warum wollen diese feinen Leute mit dir zusammen sein?
Warum sehen die alle so krass hipstermäßig aus, ey?
Ich will dir helfen, mich gegen den Gangster zu retten, der meinen Bruder getötet hat.
Hilfe ihnen mit ihren Problemen.
Und sobald sie dir vertrauen, werden sie spielbare Charaktere werden.
Jedes deiner neuen besten Freunde ist ein einzigartiges Spielzeug.
Also nimm dein Handtuch raus und gib ihnen eine Klasse.
Dann level sie auf und entdeck neue Chancen.
Oder du würdest lieber Menschen aus den Schatten stürzen.
Ein Team mit diversen Fähigkeiten wird für deinen Erfolg wichtig sein.
Jedes neue Rekrutierende wird dein Team stärker machen.
Du kannst sogar deine Teamleute kustomisieren.
Du musst keine Behinderung durchhalten.
Everyone can help themselves.
What the hell are you doing?
You are a human being.
You never questioned our ability to help others.
You never questioned our ability to save themselves.
People are the same.
They are the same.
Ja, Watch Dogs.
Ich mein, mit Hexon hatte das jetzt wenig zu tun, oder?
Thanks for joining us today.
As we move closer to launch in November,
we're continuing to add games to the Stadia portfolio.
Das war doch gut.
We look forward to sharing more with you in the next Stadia Connect.
Pog.
Es war wenig dabei, was mir gefallen hat,
aber die Präsentation war gut.
Ja, genau. Mach's gut, Shana.
CU.
Aber es war wenigstens schön präsentiert, das Ganze.
Wenigstens ging's da Schlag auf Schlag.
So, als nächstes kommt die Gamescom Night.
Da müssen wir jetzt erst mal schauen, was wir im Stream finden.
Und ich muss den Titel anpassen.
Gamescom Opening Night.
20 Uhr.
Vor allem, wo ich schon mal aufs Klo.
Und das machen wir so lange, bis ich pennen gehe.
Je nachdem, wie lange das geht.
Keine Ahnung, ob die Night auch wirklich wörtlich nehmen.
Ach, perfekt. Top.
Gibt schon einen Link.
Dankeschön.
Link.
Mal gucken, ob wir wieder den Trick brauchen mit Embedded.
Nee, brauchen wir nicht.
Wollt ihr mich mal kurz pinkeln?
Dauert voraussichtlich bis 22 Uhr.
Das ist gut. So lange halte ich durch.
Mal gucken, ob das nicht, dass es wieder genauso langweilig ist wie das andere.
Übrigens, Watch Dogs.
Da muss ich nochmal an eine Sache erinnern.
Watch Dogs 1 hatte die schlimmste Variante, die ich je gesehen habe, was unterschiedliche Versionen angeht.
Hier.
Guckt euch das an.
Das waren die unterschiedlichen Watch Dogs Editions, die es gegeben hat.
Bei Watch Dogs 1.
Was ist mit denen los gewesen?
Das ist so schlimm.
Das habe ich bei keinem anderen Game gesehen, dass das so extrem schlimm war.
Wie bei Watch Dogs 1.
Ja, was soll das sein?
Watch Dogs 2 war dann wieder halbwegs normal.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum sehen die Leute in Watch Dogs, warum sehen die so extremst, so nicht einfach nur Hipster-mäßig aus.
Die sehen, die sehen extremst Hipster, Hipstiger als Hipster sehen die aus.
Für die reicht noch nichts.
Es ist schon nicht mal das vegane Salat-Restaurant mit Blick auf irgendwie sonst wo zu melden.
Nein, die sind so krass Hipster, die geht, weiß nicht.
Die sind so Hipster, dass Hipster, echte Hipster schon nicht mal sagen würde, dass sie zu ihnen gehören.
Im ersten Teil sah die noch relativ normal aus.
Der erste Teil hatte ja auch eine relativ normale Story gehabt.
Der erste ging halbwegs.
Ich meine, der war jetzt nicht so ein Überflieger, aber es ging eigentlich.
Und wer denkt, dass Hacker so aussehen, der soll sich mal nicht mehr vorstellen.
Ich meine, das ist so ein bisschen, das ist so ein bisschen, das ist so ein bisschen, das ist so ein bisschen, das ist so ein bisschen, das ist so ein bisschen.
Der soll sich mal den CCC angucken.
Äh, den, den.
Fuck, wie hieß das?
Der, der, der Kongress.
C3, ach fuck, ich hab's vergessen.
Lull.
Äh.
Der hieß CCC, ne?
Ja klar hieß der CCC, Schwachsinn.
Der soll sich mal, der soll sich mal ein paar Vorträge vom CCC angucken.
Und dann sagen, ähm, Hacker sehen so aus.
Wollt ihr mal wissen, wollt ihr mal sehen, wie Hacker aussehen?
Ja, zum Beispiel so.
Richtig cooler Talk.
By the way, übrigens, ähm, äh, Scan.
Ja, da.
Das ist ein richtig, das ist ein richtig guter Talk.
So sehen richtige Hacks so aus.
So absolut nicht hipster wie die Typen in Watch Dogs.
Das ist übrigens ein extrem guter Talk, kann ich jedem nur empfehlen.
Da geht's da drum, wie, ähm, ich glaub Xerox Scanner, ähm, falsche Sachen scannen.
Wo sie dann drauf kommen, dass eventuell auch Obelisks,
Obamas Geburtsurkunde, ja, Achtung Verschwörungstheorie, ähm, Obamas Geburtsurkunde mit einem Xerox Scanner gescannt wurde
und er da drin Zahlen ausgetauscht hat.
Oder, oder nicht Zahlen ausgetauscht hat, Zahlen komprimiert hat.
Das zweite fand ich nicht so gut.
Das zweite ist diese Spiegel-Mining-Geschichte.
Die hat ein paar coole Elemente, wie diese, wer, wer, wer mit wem fremd geht beim Spiegel.
Das fand ich ganz interessant.
Aber die, die, der, der erste Talk mit dem Xerox, äh, äh, Scanner, äh, Scanner, beziehungsweise Kopierer, der war richtig gut.
Was ich, was ich ein bisschen schade finde, ist, dass auf dem letzten, ähm, also wie gesagt hier, Leute, in 17 Minuten geht's los, vorher muss ich nochmal aufs Klo.
Also, die Talks, also der Talk ist wirklich gut, den kann ich jedem empfehlen.
Ähm, aber generell könnt ihr hier mal gucken, es gibt, wer sich für Technik und Sachen interessiert und auch ein bisschen die Hintergründe.
Ähm, es gibt, es gibt wirklich viele, viele nice Talks.
Ähm, was ich ein bisschen schade fand, beim letzten Kongress, dass da, dass da irgendwie ein ziemlich großer Fokus, äh, gelegt wurde, nicht irgendwie auf Technik und Inhalt, sondern auf Feminismus und sowas.
Und ich mir denke, okay, muss das bei einem Hexor-Event, ist das, ja, wirklich das, was man unbedingt haben will?
Kann, es kann ja jeder sehen und tun und machen, was da lustig ist.
Aber ich mein, das ist eigentlich ein Kongress.
Das ist ein Kongress, immer gewesen, wo man sich die Talks wegen den technischen Inhalten angeguckt hat.
Wenn ich Feminismus will, da kann ich auf Twitter den passenden Leuten folgen.
Ist das dann ein Scun-Mare?
Huge Brainer.
Ein, ein Scam-Mare ist das, wenn schon.
Scamars.
Ähm, und ich hab die andere Konferenz vergessen, wie die hieß.
Da hat einer einen super, einen super Vortrag gehalten.
Über Sicherheitslücken in der Intel Manage, Management Engine oder wie dieses heißt.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Intel Manage, Management Engine, ja.
Ähm, Talk.
Das war ein super Talk, den ich hier, es war, es war nicht, es war nicht hier, es war vor einer anderen Konferenz.
Aber das könnte, könnte auch hier gewesen sein.
Oder das hier?
Nee.
Disabling Intel Management.
Ich weiß nicht mehr.
Aber es gibt ein paar wirklich gute Talks auf YouTube zu dem, zu, zu, zu Security-Themen.
Nice.
So.
Warte, ich bin mal kurz auf dem Klo.
Das ist jetzt gut.
Jetzt kann ich hier oben das Ding verwenden, um reinzuschreiben.
Afg-Klo.
Oh, gleich wieder da.
Mal Leute, eine Frage an euch.
Was hat euch besser gefallen?
Xbox oder, oder Stadia?
Okay.
Ähm, also ich muss sagen.
Ich fand beides vom Inhalt her ziemlich gut.
Ich fand es ziemlich langweilig.
Ähm.
Die Art und Weise, wie es präsentiert wurde, war bei Stadia aber umwelten besser.
Weil ganz ehrlich.
Stadia ginge, ging 35 Minuten.
Microsoft hätte ohne Probleme ihre eineinhalb Stunden.
So, über eineinhalb Stunden.
Das war ein Tick länger sogar.
Hätte Microsoft ohne Probleme auf 30 Minuten eintampfen können.
Und es wäre nichts verloren gegangen.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal, was uns erwartet bei der Gamescom Opening Night.
Und, also wenn es zu cringe wird, schalten wir ab.
Den gibt es ja auch noch.
Gamescom 2019 Opening Night Live.
Okay, was, was passiert da?
Ach, es wird auf Twitch gestreamt.
POG.
Gucken wir uns das doch hier an, oder?
Dann gucken wir uns das doch hier an.
Und zum Abschluss.
Zum Schluss bleibt die angesprochene Gamescom, bei der sich zahlreiche Publisher die Klinke in die Hand geben, genannt.
Werden unter anderem 2K, Activision, Namco, Bungie, Capcom.
EA, Deep Silver, Sony, Square Enix, Ubisoft.
Okay, da kommt dann auch Death Stranding.
Um noch mehr die Leute zu verwirren.
Telekom Cloud Gaming.
Ach, ich dachte das ist ein Scherz.
Die meinen das ernst, oder was?
Magenta Gaming.
What the fuck?
Die Telekom, Alter.
Ich glaube immer noch, dass das Fake ist.
Fuck, das ist kein Game.
Das ist kein Fake.
IGIT.
Das sieht aus wie ein Fake Xbox Controller mit Telekom Logo drauf.
Alter, hör mal auf.
Jetzt ist vorbei.
Weltuntergang ist nah.
Der Weltuntergang ist nah.
Es haben alle fehlgeschlagen, das voraus zu sagen, aber 2020 wird es soweit sein.
Der lag switch button.
Genau.
Geringe Latenz dank starkem Netz.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal die Telekom Werbung an tun.
Wir haben noch 10 Minuten Zeit, bis's los geht.
Mit Magenta Gaming, bla bla bla bla bla.
Beta Phase 24 August.
Ach so, auf der Gamescom.
Das ist wieder sowas typisches, wo die Telekom mit den großen Pissen gehen will.
Und ist dann voll verkackt.
Erinnert sich noch einer an die Telekom Whatsapp Konkurrenz?
noch zufällig jemand dran erinnern so weiß noch jemand dass die telekom
whatsapp konkurrenz machen wollte vor vier fünf jahren weiß wahrscheinlich
keiner mehr wenn ich sms nicht sms jahren einen eigenen messenger dienst
eigene messenger dienst ich weiß sogar noch wieder hieß der land hat sich immer
von der telekom immer das okay das dinge wurde wurde eingestellt schon mittel
mitten letzten jahres eine totgeburt powerpoint heute telekom das trifft
ganz gut die joint ist was anderes joint ist was
anderes immer hieß das immer joint ist joint ist diese diese joint ist von
prosieben glaube ich irgendwas oder zumindest diesen diesen fail und die
telekom hat einiges an diesen fails produziert habe ich so meine zweifel ob
die telekom das mit
mit
magentagaming telekom ich weiß nicht irgendwie habe ich da so meine meine
bedenken übrigens habe ich schon erzählt ich habe noch gar keinen sellout
modus gestartet wenn ihr einen amazon prime account habt,
könnt ihr den kostenlos mit eurem twitch account verbinden und mit twitch
dein könnt ihr einmal im monat kostenlos einen streamer eurer wahl
unterstützen mit einem tier 1 sub
das bringt dem streamer alle vorteile der normaler SAP auch bringt ihr bekommt
auch alle emerge
alle subbatches und es kostet euch nix das heißt wenn man irgendwelche primers im chat haben den
das gefällt was ich hier fabrizieren switch prime beste das haben wir schön sehr laut gemacht kann
wir uns die telekom telekom pizza pizza de the fuck was die beste name hast du den namen pizza
die nur gekriegt auf twitch so 690 hughes das hier ist max auch frisch bleiben dankeschön
iq zweiter monat in folge zu welchen alten youtuber hast du noch kontakt eigentlich kaum
letztes mal wieder eine runde geschwätzt übrigens leute hier wegen subbatches ich
hab's am anfang schon mal erzählt wegen subbatches und emotes ich habe mittlerweile elf oder zwölf
emotes slots ich habe jemand auf auf fiverr beauftragt mal ein paar emotes zu erstellen
ich habe ihm geschrieben ich bin super und kreativ was solche sachen angeht aber ich
habe halt ich hätte gern ein paar so super klein so
die klassiker an emotes ich habe mir vorgeschlagen so hier zum beispiel diese sache mit dem smoke was
wir hier schon haben irgendwas ein bisschen halt in schöner farbe ich habe auch geschrieben dass
das das ganze sollte irgendwie so ein bisschen bisschen meme charakter haben ich habe keine
ahnung was der was derjenige daraus macht ich habe kein schimmer ich habe gesagt man könnte
man könnte den emote machen so auf auf basis so nach dem motto dass ich mich überall irgendwo
spiegeln ich weiß nicht was ihm dazu einfällt könnte ein sellout emote machen pay to win emote
natürlich ein five hat nen lull emote
q chat emote monka smoke poc chat alles mögliche ich habe das mal vorgeschlagen habe gesagt er
soll einfach mal machen was ihm so einfällt und ich bin mal gespannt was da rauskommt wir gucken
uns das dann zusammen im stream an der floh 690 wirft mit abos um sich huge abos danke drei stück
zwei stück und zwar verschenkt er an den saints napalm und an hannes surft massive
prime ist da warten an die dankeschön jedes mal verzähle ich mich ja weil weißt du warum ich
mich verzähle weil für zwei subs drei nachrichten im chat kommen soll also stream geht in fünf
minuten los und ich muss unbedingt mein brötchen fordern telekom bla bla bla bla bla bla ich werde
mich jetzt mal ganz kurz muten
ein brötchen rein stopfen und ich bin ich bin ja da ich habe bloß mal gemutet weil ich will euch nicht so
ausschwätzen was join gibt es noch war join war join nicht irgendwas von pro sieben irgendwie bringe ich den namen mit mit mit irgendwas von pro sieben in verbindung
sat 1 serien irgendwie sowas ich weiß gar nicht was ist neue neue mediathek live tv stimmt irgendwas ja hab ich gelesen stimmt
invasion 45
aber ich wollte mal kurz was
übrigens ist er jetzt erwarte ich erwarte dass sie ankündigen
das ist nächstes wochenende hier ist 4 exklusiv denn k conduc im interwar fair
testing weekend gibt da habt ihr gerücht im vorfeld jetzt schreckt eben welchen
von was die chatbox ich glaube dass das ist
investigation 45
jojo macht ich glaube das ganze rendering backend ist die xvk von von proton steam kommt da jetzt
auch axel forst gleich axel forst ist auch auf der gamescom er wollte wahrscheinlich mal irgendwo
hingehen wo er besonders beliebt ist
der applaus ist real jetzt doch jetzt jetzt schon
ich bin ganz freudig von der
gamescom ist der will eigentlich nur schlange stehen
zelebrieren
gamescom
genannten early
haben gerade
laptop
video
beHave toilet
uABS
Und nicht schon wieder.
Wir haben uns schon 40 Minuten Gears of War angeguckt vorhin.
Please, come on, bruh.
Nicht nochmal 50 Minuten Gears of War.
Außerdem ist es keine World Premiere.
Die haben vor 40 Minuten darüber geschwätzt.
Nee, vor einer Stunde haben sie 40 Minuten darüber geschwätzt.
Wir schreiben einfach mal überall World Premiere drauf, ne?
Überall World Premiere.
World Premiere.
Huge Action geladenes Kamera einschalten.
Was, Monka Smoke?
Sag mal, die Lautstärke ist wieder...
Die können sich heute nicht entscheiden, ob es laut oder leise sein soll.
Requires Windows 10.
Ah, okay. Oder Xbox.
Jump In.
Ist das jetzt neu, oder?
Jump In hatten sie früher nicht.
Ist laut genug.
Und wir sind leise, bruh.
Ja, das sagen sie immer.
Bei jedem Game.
Native ist 4K mit 60 FPS.
Niemals. Nie.
Das glaube ich erst, wenn ich sehe.
Ja.
Das will ich sehen.
Fuck.
Ja Leute, ich weiß.
Das Gleiche haben wir vor zwei Stunden schon mal gesehen.
Ich kann es ja auch nicht ändern.
Ja, sein Ultimatum ist großartig. Es heißt Hijack, weil wir Funs lieben.
Und im Grunde schießt man einen Dart in einen Feind und dann besitzt man sie und nimmt sie über.
Also gehst du gegen einen Sion mit einem Boomshot, hijackst ihn und jetzt bist du ein Sion mit einem Boomshot und du kannst die Feinde mit dem zerstören.
Sieht so cool aus. Und Jack, wie ich verstehe, wird auch in der Kampagne spielbar sein?
Das ist korrekt, ja. Wir sind ein Dreijähriger-Koop, wir spielen auch auf dem Kühlschrank, nicht nur online.
Und Jack ist der dritte Spieler, oder er kann auch dein zweiter sein, aber einer der drei ist Jack.
Und wie gesagt, es ist ein komisches Flieger-Ding.
Wann kommt Kott? Keine Ahnung, ich habe das Programm nicht erstellt.
Wollen wir in Wald fehlen?
Ach, Wald fehlen, nicht Wald fehlen.
Das haben wir gerade schon mal. Wie gesagt, wir haben unbedeutende Halo-Charaktere in fragwürdiger Mission.
Wenn du die Ultimate Edition oder den Ultimate Game Pass hast, bekommst du sie, plus alle Kustomisierungen.
Okay, ich weiß, dass das Spiel hier bei Gamescom ist, und die Fans müssen nicht lange warten, um es zu spielen, oder?
Nein, und in den Storien in Nordamerika kannst du eigentlich in deinen lokalen Microsoft-Store spielen, wie diese Woche.
Okay, das ist sehr cool. Und das Spiel kommt in nur ein paar Wochen, oder?
Ja, September 6 für Ultimate, für Early Access, September 6 für Record, und ein bisschen Gears Pop ist heute, also wenn du Gears mehr holen willst,
und in deinem Koffer, dann ist es okay.
Es ist auch, dass es da draußen ist.
Alle Dinge Gears.
Na, wenn es um Gears geht, möchte ich dich begrüßen, weil wir heute Abend erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut erneut.
Und wir haben heute Abend den Gamescom-Award für das beste Xbox-Game für euch gewonnen.
Oh, das ist großartig.
Du hast einen guten Job gemacht.
Oh, danke.
Danke dir sehr.
Das ist großartig.
Gratulation.
Danke.
Großartig.
Und wir müssen nicht so lange warten, um es zu spielen, wie ich gesagt habe,
Ende September für Xbox und PC.
Wir kommen sehr schnell auf, und ich kann nicht warten,
bis alle online spielen.
Rott, ich freue mich, dass ihr das hier von Vancouver gemacht habt.
Auch nicht lauter.
Ihr seid einfach...
Also, in meiner ersten Zeit in Cologne,
es war großartig, die Leute sind großartig,
die Fans sind großartig, also habt ein tolles Mal.
Großartig, Rott, Ferguson, alle.
Coalition Gears 5, danke, Rott.
Ich weiß, was ihr wissen wollt,
aber heute haben wir ein paar Überraschungen für euch,
mit brandneuen Dingen, die nicht irgendwo geleakt wurden.
Und wir freuen uns immer, Leute zu überraschen.
Also, schaut euch mal an,
das Announcement von...
Ich hab den Counter ein bisschen vernachlässigt,
ich mach mal auf 5, weil wir haben garantiert ganz viel verpasst.
Word Premiere, irgendwas, was wir schon gesehen haben,
aber Hauptsache, Word Premiere.
Jetzt ist es wieder übelst laut, ne?
Noctua,
Noctua bringt jetzt ein eigenes Game raus,
wo man ihre Lüfter umfärben kann.
Ah ne, das ist ein Hubschrauber.
Was?
Ach, guck mal da!
Die Serie gibt's noch?
Das war mal eine Heli-Flugsimulation von vor 20 Jahren, oder so.
Die Leute, die da sitzen, kennen das überhaupt nicht mehr.
Keiner reagiert.
Zeig mal ein bisschen Ingame-Grafik, da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
THQ Nordic,
the cool guys, and said,
we have an idea how to get it back to life in the 21st century.
And they liked the idea, and so here we are.
Okay, so, and this is a,
it's a team-based online game?
Yeah, it is, yeah.
Team-based online? Okay, das hat ja mit dem Organismus zu tun.
We've done a lot of stuff in the past,
multiplayer-wise, and so,
yeah, but you will see some live footage later on, so.
That's right, because we're not just CG-Trailers,
we've got real gameplay for you guys to check out.
Real gameplay for the first time, yeah.
And you want fans to be a part of making this game, right?
Tell us a little bit about that.
Absolutely, because everybody loves helicopters.
They kick ass, they go in,
can hide somewhere, and then shoot somebody.
Ja, das können natürlich nur Helikopter machen.
Alright, well, let's take a look
at the first gameplay from Comanche, right?
But you can join us as well in the development.
In Q4 this year, we go into Alpha and Beta,
and in the beginning of next year, we go into Early Access.
So, sign up for the game.
Okay, check it out.
Wenn es die Leute jetzt nicht gut finden,
fehlt bloß noch, dass ihr nachher fragt,
you guys don't have helicopters.
Oh, das hört sich mega-Pedo-Bär-mäßig an.
Oh, intense.
Huge intense.
Okay, das hat mit dem Original nichts mehr zu tun.
Das ist, das ist,
ja, das ist World of Helicopters,
sowas in der Richtung.
Das sieht wirklich so aus.
Okay, guck mal, ist keine Ahnung.
All THQ Nordic has,
they got some more drones for you.
Check this out.
Grinse, grinse, grinse.
Battle Royale, genau, brauchst du auch noch.
Was, was, was zum...
Oh, nice!
Was, the game?
Sowas will ich doch nicht spielen.
Sowas will ich machen.
Also, als, als, als Game,
als Game stelle ich mir das Fail vor.
In echt würde ich das übertrieben gerne mal machen.
... the night, please welcome from England,
Dronen, Dronen Racing.
Das würde ich übertrieben gerne mal machen.
How you doing?
Hey, good, glad to be here.
Alright, so, Need for Speed Heat,
we saw the announcement last week.
Tell us a bit about this game.
How is it new or different for Need for Speed?
Well, you know, it focuses on the core experience
of street racing and modified cars
at night with cops.
And to this we've added sanctioned racing by day
to keep that experience fresh.
Oh, wir haben einen vergessen.
... explain why all these racers are in town.
Alright.
Uh, sounds pretty cool.
Uh, we wanna see, you guys wanna see the game play?
Shall we do the honors, Riley?
Let's check it out.
Need for Speed Heat.
World Premiere.
Alles World Premiere, ja.
Ich warte dann auf die alte 4-Games-Review,
woran es erklärt, dass das Game suckt.
Welcome to Palm City, a fresh world
with new customizations and the return of cops.
Make Palm City an urban oasis for those who burn,
make Palm City an urban oasis for those who burn,
and live by their own rules.
Daytime offers sanctioned racing events
through the Speed Hunters Showdown.
Compete and score bank with each new win.
Then use the rewards to tweak your car's performance
and visual customization.
Warum hat fast jedes Game mittlerweile Hip-Hop im Hintergrund?
Hip-Hop oder nicht, sagen die Epic-Dings-Scores.
... by the rules, finding you for speeding
and limiting your progress using controlled moves
to slow you down.
Roam the open world,
nab challenges and collectibles.
... nab challenges and collectibles.
Hat's wieder ein 30-FPS-Limit?
Es ruckelt, ich seh's, dass es ruckelt,
Ich hab's genau gesehen.
30-FPS-Lock.
Das ruckelt!
What the fuck?
Also wenn schon in der Demo quasi
in der Presi ruckelt ...
äußerst realistische Schadenmodell wieder
gut, aber das ist ja auch nicht for Speed
da brauchen wir sowas nicht
ja
und dann kannst du Microtransactions
kaufen, dass du sie wieder kriegst
Speedboote hast du recht
die Lichteffekte werden total übertrieben
mittlerweile
ich mein, Städte bei Nacht
haben ein gewisses Licht
aber es ist nicht heller als am Tag
okay
das hat bestimmt die übelste
Grille
Wunsch-Story wieder
jawoll, endlich Adidas-Socken im Game
easy, wollte ich schon immer haben
ich hoffe es gibt auch so eine Adidas-Schnellfickerhose
wer hat danach gefragt?
wahrscheinlich irgendein BWL-Typ bei EA
ich weiß es auch nicht
DNA-Versorgung
nix
das zieht an
sem
gibt's noch eine Demo?
eine verwechselte Demo, ein D-Bot oder eine Karte?
da ist kein Auto mehr da tall, es ist schon kalt
oder meinen die, wir haben da kein Auge für, warum zeigt eine Demo vom Game GOTRON so ruckelt?
oder meinen die wir haben da kein Auge für, dass leid gemacht wird?
keine Technology Document fordi es ist so schrecklich. das wird auch sicherlich, aber nachher machen wir das Wunder und necesse den D-Bot auf den Milchwagen, dann etwas kürzer, aber ich glaube das geht auch sehr gut.
sodass 30 FPS vielleicht nicht so flüssig ist.
Heat.
Okay.
Download the app now.
Für was?
Die haben es nicht so drauf mit der Lautstärke heute.
Könnte das auch am Stream liegen?
Nee, der Rest vom Stream ist ja flüssig.
Oder sie haben Fail aufgenommen.
Was? iOS?
Was?
Warum?
Oder tut jetzt von der...
Die App hat angeblich schon super Bewertungen.
Von was?
Love it.
Must have.
Oh Gott, das ist...
Also wenn das nicht Fake-Bewertungen sind,
dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Ein Raumschiff.
Not actual gameplay.
Das baut schon mal immer Vertrauen auf.
Was ist das?
Mondlandung, the game.
Was ich richtig geil finden würde,
wenn sie ein geiles Game daraus machen.
Ich weiß halt nicht,
wie man da draußen ein Game machen sollte,
aber warum nicht?
Ja.
Ich brauche...
Ich brauche Armstrong mit RTX on.
Ach, Kerbal Space Programm ist es.
Haha, cool.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das so aktiv entwickelt wird.
Das ist aber ein schönes Game.
Ich glaube, das ist das erste Game, was wir heute Abend gesehen haben.
Wo ich mir tatsächlich...
Näh, nicht Cyberpunk,
aber aus dem Vor...
Ich mir vorstellen könnte,
das mal wieder auszuprobieren.
Das Core-Game ist ja auch schon vier Jahre alt.
Ich konnte mir keine Mondbasis bauen.
Das ist ja mal nice.
Nee, von Halo gab es nichts.
Ach ja, Borderlands auch.
Vergessen.
Oh.
RIP.
Half-Life 3, klar.
War direkt bei der Eröffnung.
Kerbal Space Program 2 coming next year.
Ach, das ist der zweite Teil?
Check this out for the first time, here at Gamescom.
Wonkaes!
Und das Game.
So...
Snake Tarnum.
Ach, das ist das...
Das ist...
Das kenne ich.
Da haben wir doch letztens schon mal einen Trailer geguckt.
Und streamen.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es...
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es hieß.
Da haben wir E3...
Da haben wir doch auf der E3 mal was geguckt, glaube ich, von, ne?
Ja, ja.
Ich weiß nicht mal, wie es hieß.
Little Nightmares?
Ja, genau.
Ja, ja.
Hat das gerade MonkaS gesagt?
Ne.
Ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
Brawline.
Little Nightmares 2.
Dave, how you doing?
I'm alright, thanks, yeah.
How did you get this shirt on?
Did you do that during the trailer?
I've been wearing this all day.
Oh my God.
Alright, well, hopefully you had a jacket on or something.
Don't spoil any announcements.
Alright, well, anyways.
Little Nightmares 2.
The first game was, I mean, beautiful.
And what we saw there, again, in-engine footage from the game.
Für you guys...
Ach, wir haben uns das letzte Mal einen Trailer angeguckt vom ersten, okay.
Yeah, it's a new character called Mono.
Das konnte ich jetzt nicht so aus meiner Halt.
Mono 6 is there as well, so...
But you'll be playing as Mono, and you...
The...
The pair of you are going to a place called the Signal Tower,
which is the center of the whole story.
I mean, this is, you know, beautiful platforming,
just incredible graphics with Unreal and what you guys have put together.
Incredible, das zählt auf.
I noticed we have weapons now.
We're gonna have some combat.
Kitchen utensils.
Okay, yeah, those could be weapons.
Okay.
So is this gonna be a little bit...
Is it even darker?
Is it gonna be...
Is combat a big part of this game?
It's a part of the game.
It's just another part of the balance, really.
I mean...
Wie bekannt ist der Moderator eigentlich?
Ich hab den mal auf Twitter gesucht, der hat irgendwie 100.000 Follower oder so.
Ist der bekannt?
Ziemlich bekannt, also sehr bekannt, oder jeder kennt ihn außer ich?
Wir werden nie wieder einen anderen machen, also wir könnten so eine schöne Überraschung haben.
Aber jetzt haben wir, wie ihr seht aus dem Trailer,
ihr seid draußen, also ihr seid nicht frei, aber ihr seid draußen.
Also es gibt Plätze wie die Wildnis,
und wie ein verlassener Schark.
Die gesehen, okay.
Ich bin ja nicht der Einzige.
Label-Kombat.
Looks incredible, we can't wait to see more of it,
and you'll have, I'm sure, more to share at Gamescom in the months ahead?
Yeah, absolutely.
Alright, well, what do you guys think of that?
Little Nightmares 2, announced right here at Gamescom.
Thanks so much, Dave, great to see you.
Alright, well, there's so much other stuff going on at Gamescom in the days ahead,
and IGN's gonna have a live studio, where they'll be doing tons of coverage,
and joining me now to talk about the Gamescom Awards,
and some of the things that are happening this week with awarding great games,
is Sydney Goodman from IGN.
Sydney, take it away!
Well, thank you, Jeff.
With me is none other than Mark Healy, Creative Director at Media Molecule.
Mark, you and your team won Best Original Game and Best Sony PlayStation 4 Game for Dreams.
Sackboy, congratulations.
And Sagan, how are you feeling?
Well, that's fantastic, I'm very happy, I'm sure that the team will be very happy about that.
And I'm just relieved, actually, that we managed to get this far, because it's been a long road.
So I should probably say thank you to Sony for letting us take so long to get here.
And really importantly, I want to thank the community, actually, who are obviously the lifeblood of Dreams,
and it's blowing us away constantly, so thank you to them as well.
That's awesome, let's hear it for the community.
So, speaking as community...
Easy.
So, speaking as community, you and your team have been in early access since April.
How has it been seeing players create and explore in Dreams?
Oh, it's humbling, because there's just so much talent out there waiting to break into this industry, you know?
So, it's really exciting watching people get better and better, day by day.
There's already some superstars in the community, so yeah, it's just gonna get better.
Awesome, well, congratulations again, and back to you, Jeff.
Thank you, Sydney.
And congratulations to the Molecules.
Such a great game that's empowering creators around the world.
Alright, now our next game is one that has been announced, but everyone's been wanting to see gameplay on it.
Well, tonight we got the first gameplay for you.
Predator Hunting Grounds from Illphonic and PlayStation.
Check this out.
Das klingt nach einem Lizenz-Game, also so, nicht Lizenz-Game, halt so...
Games zu irgendeiner anderen Marke.
Da bin ich immer skeptisch.
You claim he has a misery, but he...
He has a misery, but he...
...must be in Medford, Sanger, ja?
Let's get in, find the satellite, and upload the malware to Stargazer's network.
Ich hab jetzt nicht aufgepasst.
Was, was gucken wir gerade?
Steals, Steals Game.
Found on your position, keep your heads down.
Sieht aus wie ein 360 Game.
Truffel übrigens auch.
Das sieht aus wie ein Xbox 360 Game.
Niklas Pryad, Twitch Prime.
POC.
Dankeschön, Niklas.
Ah, da ist ja ein Predator.
Das sieht aus wie ein 360-Game, oder?
Also ich finde, das sah jetzt nicht irgendwie so nach Next-Gen-Graphics aus.
Ah, Eax, das ist doch was für dich.
Das ist bestimmt sowas wie Evolve.
Du warst doch krasser Evolve-Pro auf dem einzigen Turnier, was es gab, oder?
War da nicht was?
Du hattest die Lizenz, du hattest es, glaube ich.
Ja, ich bin nach Fox gegangen und dann nach Sony und hier sind wir heute.
Das ist also ziemlich toll.
Gut, das ist ein String von Glück, aber es sieht wirklich cool aus.
Das ist ein Multiplayer, was ein großes Spiel ist.
Ja, ja.
PlayStation, ein großes neues Multiplayer-Spiel.
Und das ist natürlich 4v1, oder?
Ja, 4 Fireteam-Mitglieder.
4v1, das ist wirklich ein bisschen was wie Evolve.
Das ist ein bisschen wie das 87-Film.
Und dann, ja, die Predators, dann die Fireteam-Mitglieder.
Also es ist ein bisschen wie ein Hunt-bekommt-Hunted-Type-Moment.
Also, ja.
Und zwischen, natürlich musst du es ausbalancieren,
also es ist lustig, auf der Team zu sein,
oder du musst es ausbalancieren.
Erzähl uns über das Balancen.
Oh, ja, also wir sind, du weißt, es ist immer etwas,
was wir bis zur Schlusslinie machen,
aber es ist wirklich lustig, beide zu spielen,
als Predator oder Fireteam.
Also gerade jetzt gibt es nur eine Menge Kompetenz im Büro.
Also wir haben viel Spaß.
Er ist beigepoppt, so so.
Naja, das hat mich jetzt nicht so geschockt.
Was, kommt jetzt Kott?
Ne, kommt jetzt?
Das ist...
Also, ist Monster Hunter, hä?
Monster Hunter? Ne.
Ja, doch, Monster Hunter.
Ja, wirklich, ein schöner Soundtrack.
Ja, neu ist das nicht.
Auch wenn sie World Premiere dran schreiben.
Die schreiben alle World Premiere dran.
Die haben übrigens Excited ein paar Mal vergessen.
Der Typ sieht aus wie aus For Honor.
For Honor, gibt's das noch?
Aber einen schönen Soundtrack haben sie.
Wenn das Ingame Soundtrack ist.
For the Lag Players.
Wow, wow, eier!
Das reiht man nicht.
Es ist selbst publiziert. Es ist ohne Kompromisse. Es ist PvE. Es ist PvP. Es ist ein neues Genre. Willkommen im Zyklus.
Bloß fühlen sich die Waffen schon beim Zugucken nicht so gut an, wie in Destiny.
Was soll er auch sonst sagen?
Es gab schon ein paar Games, die es versucht haben.
Das sind die von Spectrum. Ach stimmt, ja.
Oh, das wird wieder Hate geben. Epic-Game-Store-Exclusive.
Warum habt ihr das so gemacht?
Wir nehmen sehr viel Risiko mit dem Zyklus, um ehrlich zu sein.
Es ist sehr innovativ. Und das ist nicht wirklich für alle.
Nach 20 Jahren. Jaeger ist seit 20 Jahren da gewesen.
Wir mussten es wirklich auf einen Punkt gehen.
Ich bin super froh, dass wir als Firma die Gelegenheit hatten, das zu machen.
Und ein großer Applaus für Epic für die Unterstützung und ihre Gelegenheit.
Es wäre nicht möglich, ohne ihre Hilfe.
Viele coole deutsche Game-Developer sind heute auf der Bühne.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Also, äh, großartig.
Schön, dich hier zu haben.
Gratuliere.
Wir werden das auf der Epic-Game-Store anschauen.
Und jetzt werden wir schauen, dass...
Ich bin sicher, das nächste Episode von Life is Strange 2, Episode 4,
kommt diese Woche.
Und wir haben den ersten Blick auf den Trailer.
Schaut ihn an.
Es ist so anders jetzt.
Viermal am Tag. Ich werde es nicht vergessen.
Ich habe alle verloren.
Ich habe Daniel verloren.
Wo würde er sich verstecken?
Wir haben viele Leute, die nach deinem Bruder suchen.
Wie lange?
Es ist seit über zwei Monaten.
Fiburo hat seinen Profil über vier Staaten veröffentlicht.
Das ist, wo ich mich entschieden habe.
Aber haben die Games schon 30 Milliarden Reviews,
wenn sie noch gar nicht rausgekommen sind?
Warum macht er nicht einfach STRG-F?
Bei uns, das ist ein gutes Comment.
Life is Strange 2?
Moment.
War in Life is Strange...
Ich habe das nie gespielt.
Hatte das nicht eine weibliche Heldin?
Und im zweiten Teil dann die andere mit den blauen Haaren?
Hideo Kojima ist hier, Leute.
Oh ja, jetzt kommt Death Stranding.
Aber wir haben noch Death Stranding für euch.
Aber jetzt wollen wir noch ein neues Spiel veröffentlichen.
Sega und Amplitude teamen zusammen, um ein neues, historisches,
turnbasiertes Strategie-Spiel zu veröffentlichen.
Was, wenn du es wiederholst?
Ein Prequel?
Ah ja, okay.
Eine neue Story.
Kommt jetzt Death Stranding?
Nee.
Garantiert nicht.
Außerdem ist Death Stranding kein Strategy-Game.
Das ist alles World Premiere.
Warum macht ihr das so scharf, wenn der am Knopf dreht?
Dem geht voll einer ab?
Was wollt ihr uns sagen, Leute?
Was genau möchtet ihr uns sagen?
Okay, hat nichts mit dem zu tun, was man gerade gesehen hat.
Riesen-Mammut.
Massive-Mammut.
Civilization?
Wahrscheinlich.
Nee.
Humankind.
Was Neues.
Das war einer der wenigen Games, die wir heute Abend gesehen haben,
die keine Serie-Teile waren.
Nicht noch mal.
Oh, ich liebe das Enthusiasmus.
Bitte willkommen von Gearbox.
Borderlands haben wir heute schon dreimal, zweimal gesehen.
Hey, Jeff, how are you?
I'm doing pretty well.
You've been traveling around the world.
There's so much Borderlands stuff going on.
Ich meine, auch mit Borderlands, geil, dass ich dreimal, weißt du.
Excited-Counter.
Let's talk Borderlands 3.
First of all, the campaign.
Last week, a lot of previews went up.
Influencers, press got to play it.
Was haben die sich eigentlich bei der Programmgestaltung gedacht?
Ich meine, du machst die einzigen drei, nennen wir es mal,
die Pressekonferenzen, die es gibt, hintereinander.
Und dann zeigst du dreimal das Gleiche.
The fuck?
And then we moved on to Eden 6, which is a new planet.
We've never showed up before.
And we tell this kind of heartwarming story
of two AIs who fall out of love.
Ja, wir haben bestimmt schon viel mehr mittlerweile.
And one AI, who's a jilted lover,
takes and shoves the other AI
just straight up into a pink plush bear,
who is voiced by none other than the charismatic Ice-T.
Oh, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
There you go, Ice-T.
Alright, in Borderlands 3.
Of course, right?
Now, you've got obviously amazing characters
playing with Flak.
I mean, people are super excited about what you've shown
kind of on campaign.
And the thing, though, that everyone is always curious now,
I know it's kind of silly to be talking about the endgame
before the game's even out,
but folks want to know, you know, what's the challenge?
What can you tell us about the endgame for Borderlands 3?
Alright, so all this week
and probably next week and a few more weeks,
we're going to be talking about endgame.
There are two things we're going to talk about.
The first one is called the Circle of Slaughter.
We're bringing back Circle of Slaughter from Borderlands.
And it's just this wave after wave
survival mechanic of fighting off enemies.
And the cool thing about this is that,
you know, the more you survive, the better your rewards are.
And there's more, though, right?
There is more.
So we're announcing something called Proving Grounds.
Okay.
Proving Grounds starts off with the Oridians.
We're showing off, you know,
a little bit of the Proving Grounds here.
And the nice thing is,
you have to go throughout the game
and discover Oridian writing.
This is this ancient alien race.
And then you find the coordinates to planets
once you kind of decipher all these things.
And then you find out
that you can take a mission
from this Oridian that you see here
and the mission has different objectives in it, right?
So it's got one, which is kill everything
because Borderlands.
And then it's got optional objectives
like don't die, alright?
Do it within a certain amount of time
and kill a certain thing.
So you have optional objectives right here.
And then the nice thing about the optional objectives is
that if you do those optional objectives,
at the end we have a chest
and the loot gets better,
how the optional objectives play out.
So if you're really good, you'll get the best loot in the game.
Super replayable, obviously.
It's all about replayability at this point.
It's loot, it's life.
So time-based, obviously, going through there
with you and your friends and having an amazing time.
So this, obviously, Proving Grounds,
this is one map.
Are there multiple Proving Grounds, obviously?
Scattered throughout the game.
Actually, sorry, I said seven and a half, six.
But, you know, it works.
I'm sure there'll be more down the road.
Alright, so I'm sure there's probably even more in-game?
Huge recoil.
Again, like I said, we're gonna talk about it more.
We have something called Guardian Rank,
which is if you play Borderlands 2,
it's like badass rank 2.0.
We talk a lot about that.
Alright, well, we don't have to wait long for Borderlands 3,
but it's so awesome to see Proving Grounds.
And when can we check it out, Paul?
You'll be able to check it out on Friday the 13th.
That's September 13th, 2019.
I hope everybody is there.
Oh yeah, and I'm sure you're gonna have it playable here at Gamescom.
So everyone will be checking it out, right?
Alright, Borderlands 3, the guys from Gearbox.
Paul, thank you so much for kicking off Gamescom with us.
Really appreciate it.
Alright.
So now we've got a cool new game to show you guys.
And this comes from a German studio.
And sometimes we get pitched indie games for Game Awards
or even Gamescom.
And sometimes we get trailers that just blow me away.
And this is a game that you may not have heard of before
from a studio that you may not know about.
But take a look at this.
I was really impressed with this trailer.
So we're so proud to announce this brand new independent game
made here in Germany on opening night live.
Check this out. Let me know what you think.
I was really impressed.
Was ist das?
Rockfish Games.
Wer ist Rockfish Games?
Star Citizen.
Bloß fertig.
Ist das so was wie Wing Commander?
Everspace.
Kenn ich nicht.
Das ist ein bisschen so was wie Wing Commander.
Oder Freelancer.
Oder wie das andere Ding hieß.
2021. Okay, da ist es noch ein bisschen hin.
Rockfish Games.
Von denen habe ich doch nie was gehört, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist heute alles World Premiere.
Wir haben es zwar vorher schon vor 3 Stunden gesehen,
aber World Premiere.
Oh. Chat. Ausmachen.
Für Switch ab 18.
Ach komm.
The Witcher auf Switch.
What brings you to this no man's land?
Huge Graphics.
Switcher 3.
The far more interesting places to visit.
Sydney Valleys.
Peace. Quiet.
The wild.
Lots of wild.
Skellige.
Friendly nature.
Breathtaking landscapes.
Kind folk.
Welcoming of travelers.
I wait you'd have a much better time there.
A Novigrad.
That's another beast, I tell you.
A Novigrad. That's another beast, I tell you.
Merchants.
Freaks.
Horse races.
Oh no.
Because here's where my journey begins.
Switch.
It's still pretty pixelated.
But it's still pristine.
I can only added one more thing.
The graphics' score has improved.
But I believe the score has quite low.
You have a close call.
Alright, there you go Winter 3 Switch,
announced October 15th.
There was an announcement.
Now we're going to talk about FIFA 20.
Mit mir von EA ist Matt Turner von EA. Matt, komm mal raus.
Gut, dich zu sehen.
FIFA 20 ist ein großer Deal, besonders hier.
Alle lieben FIFA.
Erzähl uns ein bisschen über das neue Volta.
Was ist Volta in FIFA 20?
Volta-Football ist wirklich alles darum,
etwas zu feiern, was unsere Fans gefragt haben.
Wir haben eine tiefe und authentische Erfahrung
für die 11 vs. 11-Spiele gespielt.
Wir bringen dir deine Lieblings-Squads,
Klubs, Spieler und Stadien.
Aber wir müssen verstehen,
dass für Millionen von Menschen weltweit
Stadien oder Straßen sind.
Sie sind Käse.
Und das sind die Räume,
in denen sie sich ausdrücken können
und ihre Kreativität zum Spiel erzeugen können.
Und manchmal sogar die Influenz darauf,
wie spezifisch ein Spiel gespielt wird.
Also wir werden die Kreativität
und die tiefe und authentische Erfahrung
in unserer Erfahrung mit der Stadien-Football-Szene
und bringen diese Kreativität
zur Führung des Stadien-Spiele-Skills.
Didn't they see the difference in our new changing
and customizing teams?
We can choose what your character looks like
and how they play
and how they wear on the court.
And with all the ways you can play Volta-Football
with Volta-Story included,
you're gonna see here
more competition in the main up.
That authentic-team
and a depth of real life
in street football."
It's going to see all over again
for money and to time.
And I know we saw in the trailer
that we're going more around the world,
right?
Like the Tower, other places, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, it's really serious.
Ich habe nicht für das Game.
Nice.
Subscriver.
Jetzt haben sie ja mittlerweile schon alles drin, oder?
Dritte Liga, Fußball irgendwie, oder zweite oder dritte Liga, Fußball, Halle, Steinplätze, Mädels.
Jetzt ist es ja schon, also mittlerweile ist es wirklich, viel mehr geht jetzt ja nicht.
Awesome, alright, well you brought a clip for the first time, a premiere clip from the story mode, what are we gonna see?
Yeah, well, you're gonna get to, you know, create your avatar and really see how they look and how they play on the court
and obviously spend a lot of time on the pitch, but you're also gonna get to experience Volta-Football through the story.
Genau, als nächstes, nächstes Jahr wird es ein FIFA-Handball.
Und one of our legends, Kotaro Takuda, is gonna give you a little taste of his world championship winning routine in Tokyo.
And like any adventure, you're gonna make some friends along the way
and maybe a few enemies, too, at the same time.
Alright, well, let's take a look at a premiere clip from FIFA 20 Volta coming up in September, right?
Yeah, you wanna check it out on Gamescom right now, you can.
If you wanna get your early hands on it, it's gonna be on EA Access and Origin Access on September 19th
and for the rest of the world on September 27th.
Awesome, alright, let's check it out. FIFA 20, world premiere clip, Volta Story.
Stimmt, FIFA Battle Royale, das fehlt natürlich auch noch.
Cool.
Da kommen die Koreaner, die erstmal hier krassen Breakdance-Fußball machen.
Gibt es so Events wirklich?
Also dein Model ist auf jeden Fall nicht cool.
Das sieht aus wie von vor acht Jahren.
Private Division.
Wow, look at you.
Not actual gameplay.
Destiny NG.
You'd think we'd learn.
I don't own the name of progress, right?
They say there's always something better.
Burn the old.
Bring in the new.
Risked our whole future.
And we trusted them.
And they say, and they say, and they say.
Ja, ist genau.
And that we fight them any way we can.
And they say, and they say, and they say.
Zu null.
For what's left of humanity.
Sieht aus wie Destiny.
Ist aber wohl kein Destiny.
Es ist...
Ein...
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was es ist.
Ein Titanfall-Destiny.
Irgend...
Ich weiß nur, dass es definitiv nicht Half-Life 3 ist.
Knärbär.
Der Grav-Cycle?
Ich bin Pilot.
Es heißt Pre-Flight-Inspektion.
Kein Witz hier.
Auch Titanfall? Nee.
Disintegration.
Reboot Humanity.
Ja, manche Leute müsste man wirklich mal rebooten.
Okay, warum nicht?
Man hat zwar keine Ahnung, um was es geht.
Keine Ahnung, um was es geht.
Aber man...
Warum nicht?
Neue Sachen sind immer gut, Leute.
Wir haben...
Wir sehen so viel Neues.
Zweiter, dritter, vierter, fünfter, hundertster, hundertster Serien-Teil.
Neue Sachen bin ich immer froh.
Excited-Counter muss hoch.
...
Ein Craft-Cycle-Pilot. Ein Craft-Cycle, das ist das, was du, wenn du was programmierst, definitiv nicht haben willst.
Das ist ein Craft-Cycle-Pilot in diesem Grab-Cycle-Vehicle, das über dem Boden hofft und du hast Anbieter für Offensiv- und Defensiv-Kompetenzen und dann auch eine kleine Gruppe von Units auf dem Boden, die alle ihre eigenen Unik-Kompetenzen haben, also es ist dein Job, sie zu strategisieren. Das ist wirklich cool.
Ja, es sieht fantastisch aus und es hat das Gefühl, das wir in der Welt kennen und lieben.
Ich muss mehr so Mainstream-Zeug machen.
Das ist ein Epic-Welt, das große Musik.
Nice!
Es gibt viele Signature, aber es ist nicht...
Es gibt neue und unterschiedliche Spielplätze.
Es ist alles in meinem DNA.
Das, dass du Kampagne und Multiplayer machst, finde ich, ist absolut großartig, mit einem Team von 30, was so fantastisch aussieht.
Danke, ja, wir machen etwas ziemlich ambitiöses mit einem Titel wie diesem, aber das 30-Menschen-Team in Seattle ist ein Powerhouse von Talent, von AAA-Devs wie mir, sowie von vielen erneuerbaren Talenten, also es ist ein großartiges Mix.
Das ist definitiv ein Spiel, das 2020 zu sehen ist, aber jetzt wirst du die Leute spielen lassen.
Ich meine, es ist hier bei Gamescom.
Das ist richtig.
Wir spielen Multiplayer auf dem Boden, also wir sind ziemlich gespannt, dass jeder Kumpel in eine 5v5 kommt, ziemlich frenetisch.
Ja gut, müssen wir mal abwarten.
Es ist ziemlich großartig.
Ich liebe es, euch im Spiel zu erneuern, die Leute hier bei Gamescom zu spielen zu lassen.
Es sieht fantastisch aus.
Viel Glück damit.
Danke.
Hoffentlich sehen wir uns bald wieder.
Das ist Integration.
Markus und V1.
Ich vermisse, ich vermisse so ein bisschen, nicht bei dem Game, sondern allgemein, so ein bisschen die Ultra-Hype-Dinger, wo jeder drauf eskaliert.
Wie es der Eax gerade geschrieben hat.
Würdest du Gordon Freeman sehen, der einfach nur mit der Cobra einen Luftschacht aufschlägt?
Die Leute würden den explodierenden Kopf...
Wow.
Übertreib mal.
Ach mal wieder das Darksiders, was wir vor drei Stunden schon gesehen haben.
Die machen echt überall World Premiere.
Überall steht World Premiere drauf.
Egal, was World Premiere ist oder nicht.
Felix T. geht mit Prime zwei Monate.
Das ist super nice.
Spock.
Samus Grimer.
Nice.
Das erste Darksiders war richtig gut.
Das war richtig gut.
Das zweite war auch gut, aber das erste war richtig gut.
Wer es noch nicht gespielt hat, sollte das mal spielen.
Das ist wirklich...
Das beste Zelda, was nicht Zelda ist, das erste Darksiders.
Raul.
Oh, good to see you, man.
How are you, man?
Yes.
So, this is exciting.
You guys are, you know, a studio that's done a lot of really interesting, new, unique projects.
This is a Stadia-exclusive game and we've got some gameplay.
So, tell us a bit about, why did you guys want to build this game?
What is it?
Well, first of all, I'm very happy to be here.
Yes.
Because it's Tequila World.
Ich bin froh, dass ich...
Ich freue mich so, dass ich da sein kann.
Yes.
That's really the only reason why we're doing this.
Right?
Well, two years ago.
In fact.
In how the games are evolving and how the way we build, the way we play changes.
Yeah.
Actually, well, we were excited by the vision of Stadia and the Stadia team for, well, the
next step in evolution.
Right?
And the thing is that, if you look at our games, we are mostly about touching players
with deep, meaningful stories.
Yeah.
And the thing is that that was perfectly aligned with what the Stadia were looking.
Right?
Well, the result is guilt.
Yes.
Of latest creation and, as you said, Stadia exclusive.
Yep.
Stadia exclusive.
Okay.
Also, tell us a little bit about the game.
I see there's a...
Get out.
... a woman girl who's walking around with a flashlight.
What is she trying to do?
She's looking for her sister, right?
Well, her cousin.
Emily.
Yes, her cousin.
Okay, sorry.
So, yeah.
As you can see, guilt is a...
A woman girl.
Rock hat gedacht.
So, how does it work?
A woman girl, right?
Rock hat gedacht.
Wait.
One moment.
I thought...
... Emily, right?
Aha, Ah, she's looking for Emily.
Ah.
Ja, doch, Tremor, auf der Gamescom gibt es selten was, außer Blizzard, die ab und zu mal eine WoW-Expansion ankündigen.
Mir gefällt der Grafikstil von dem Game irgendwie, ich habe zwar keine Ahnung, was es geht, ich werde es wahrscheinlich auch nicht spielen.
In meiner Hilfsmannschaft?
Ja.
Also, das ist das, was wir als Delikates Horror bezeichnen.
Okay.
Das ist eigentlich Sallys Reise, mit der Taschenlampe, und gleichzeitig versuchen zu verstehen, wie die Welt um sie herum läuft.
Und du verdoppelst diese Monster mit dieser Flasche, es bringt dich ein bisschen zu...
Das ist nicht das Gleiche, aber Alan Wake, wir sind so wie...
Genau, Alan Wake, exakt, daran habe ich auch gerade gedacht.
Das ist richtig.
Schuld ist ein Abenteuer, ein narrativer Abenteuer.
Das bedeutet, dass wir Elemente wie Exploration, Stele,
Aktion, Puzzles,
du hast viele Werkzeuge an deinem Handel.
Und in diesem Fall, zum Beispiel,
äh, naja, die Flasche ist dein Beacon in die Dunkelheit, das ist natürlich das, was du finden musst.
Die Sache ist, dass diese Monster tatsächlich sehr sensibel sind zu Geräusch und Licht.
Sie können dich sehen.
Wenn du die Flasche nutzt, bist du tatsächlich selbst ausgewogen.
Aber das ist ein Weg, um deine Angst zu lösen.
Ich meine, ja, einige Monster sind ziemlich dünn,
und wenn...
Was ist da? Das ist Google Streaming Service.
Okay, der Kerl, das, was mir bei dem gefällt,
der ist wohl echt von seinem Game überzeugt,
und er mag sein Game, das ist schon mal gut.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass es gefakt ist.
Oh, wenn das jetzt die Präsentationsrhetorik-Schuler sehen würden,
dass er seine Hand im Säckel hat.
Wow.
Okay.
Very deep, and looks cool that you guys are doing it for Stadia.
So, Tequila Works, great to see you, Roel.
Look forward to hearing what's next.
Roel Rubio, Tequila Works.
Fantastic. Alright, well, thanks very much, Roel.
You can't games in browser spielen, sobald das rausgekommen ist,
und nur die Games, die dort unterstützt werden.
Well, hello, Jeff. Again, I am here with Celia from Nintendo.
Celia, you and your team won best Nintendo Switch game
for the Legend of Zelda Link's Awakening.
Congratulations. How are you feeling?
Oh, I'm so excited.
Wie können die denn... Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Yes, actually...
Wie können die für ein Spiel den Preis gewinnen, was doch gar nicht raus ist?
He's won this award.
Und ähm...
A few weeks ago we asked fans to send us fan art
and we received within two and a half weeks
450 letters, emails, pictures, sculptures, miniatures...
Magic, ja.
And it's really amazing that you can see here
that the love that Nintendo puts into these games
the love to detail comes back right to them.
It's amazing. I love that a lamp.
What creates...
So, in a minute, that Link's Awakening is just such a beloved...
Da, Hero, das ist nice, dass du auch am Start bist hier.
How has it been being on the team that's working on that game?
Yeah, unfortunately I'm not part of the team...
Das ist ja... Ihr Chat-Message ist ja höchst kappa bright hier.
... von Anuma-san.
And he said they always want to keep the heart of the game,
but on the other hand they always want to introduce something new.
That's the reason why we see here this beautiful graphics,
which is like a miniature world.
And another new thing is the Dungeon Chamber,
which is super exciting for players,
because here they get the chance to arrange chambers the way they want it.
Yes, so...
I think even for players who played it 26 years ago,
they now find something new in this new game.
Well, congratulations again, Celia.
I know I am not alone when I say I cannot wait to get my hands on that.
And back to you, Jeff.
Fantastic. All right. Thank you very much, Sydney.
Congratulations to Nintendo for this.
Also, Guitar Hero 1,
ich mache kein Reaction-Content.
Oh, jetzt... Ah, nee.
Ach nee, ich dachte, jetzt kommt Halo.
Vergiss es ja. Bungie ist ja gar nicht mehr Halo.
Ich glaube auch, dass du... Ich glaube, du jubilierst nur.
So hardcore Fanboy heute 2019 keiner mehr.
Things are going well. You guys are very well branded here.
Come on up.
So, let's talk about Destiny 2.
First of all, the newly independent Bungie.
It's so cool that you guys are...
Ja, die haben sich ja freigekauft.
Die haben sich ja freigekauft von Activision hier.
As your shirt says, Shadowkeep is coming October 1.
So, we're going back to the moon.
But tell us a bit about what we can expect from this expansion.
Yeah, well, Shadowkeep is our new expansion.
Like you said, come out October 1st.
It involves the return of a character we haven't seen in a while.
Eris Morn.
One of the beloved characters from Destiny 1.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, wer das aus Destiny ist.
Eris has gone around looking around in the moon, and from Destiny 1 also,
and has discovered something horrible
that has unleashed nightmares for all Guardians to come back and battle.
So, the moon, but it's totally transformed by the Hive.
There's some new spaces that you've never seen before.
And there are some spaces that you think would really have happened
and totally, totally reimagined.
Wow.
Now, you guys are also changing kind of the business of Destiny a little bit
in how you're approaching it, you know, free to play,
and obviously, you know, first light to be able to come up with.
Tell us a bit about that and how that's going to change or affect the game.
Yeah, new light is definitely the best time to start Destiny.
Not only because it's free to download,
but because the player very quickly is going to unlock the game.
So, if you want to jump in and play campaigns, no problem, we got you covered.
If you want to fire a team up, jump in the Crucible, jump in the Gambit,
play co-op strikes, it's all available right off the bat.
Wow, very cool.
And cross-save, you can play your Guardians on any platform you want.
Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah, cross-save coming online,
which everyone's excited about.
And, you know, Armor 2.0, there's so much in this game,
which everyone wants to know about.
But tonight, I know you guys prepared a little bit of news for folks
on the season that's starting of the Undying.
So, who's...
This is, by the way, the third time we're seeing Destiny.
Well, I'm very lucky, because I get to work on one of the teams
that focuses on seasons, which means we're keeping Destiny fresh all the time.
It's always a great time to jump in.
And this fall, while your Guardians are going to the moon to confront nightmares,
the Vex are bringing the fight to us.
Okay, the Vex.
Well, let's check it out.
You guys have a little story trailer here to set it up, right?
Yes, we do.
Awesome.
All right, well, let's check it out.
A brand-new trailer for Destiny 2 Shadowkeep from Bungie.
We appreciate them putting this together.
Let's check it out.
We have already seen Destiny twice today.
Okay, we haven't seen it yet.
I haven't seen the game since Activision.
To be honest, I can't really imagine it.
Because I don't think that Activision...
alone...
alone made it so that Destiny 2 isn't what people wanted it to be.
Dude, Guitarrero, don't overdo it.
It's forever.
But I think it's cool that more and more people are finding their way here,
even though I intentionally named myself differently on Twitch.
We say that the Black Lord is the birthplace of the Vex.
But it was not the beginning.
It was the reason.
The life in the garden called out a question.
The Vex are the answer.
They will do anything to protect the garden.
Okay, the voice actor is not the best, or the voice-over guy.
Why do you want to distance yourself from your YouTube channel?
I don't want that.
I just don't want to make it so obvious.
The gateways have opened.
The Vex are coming.
Vex?
It sounds like hair removal, right?
The Vex.
Pre-alpha-footage.
Daryl Arts...
Okay.
I didn't hear anything from him.
Miracoli?
Let's look at the Miracoli, grandma.
Okay.
What...?
What Rem Nether Red?
How do you say that?
Grammar.
Neu gemuttert, oder was?
Was war das für...
Jawohl, ordentlich Dubstep. Endlich.
Das hat uns heute noch gefehlt.
Da muss der Beat gedroppt werden.
Ich dachte schon,
wir kriegen überhaupt keine ordentliche
Dubstep-Collection mehr heute.
Die letzten Jahre
wurden wir überall mit Dubstep
zugekleistert. Heute noch gar nicht.
Ich sag doch,
das ist voll out, Dubstep.
Wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp, wupp.
Kontro...
Hoffentlich zeigen sie...
Da freu ich mich richtig drauf.
Das ist der Taxifahrer...
Das ist der Taxifahrer aus...
aus Dings.
Aus Quantum Break.
Und das ist die Polizeifrau
aus Quantum Break.
Hält mir jetzt erst auf.
Die haben wieder gleich einen Schauspieler genommen.
Außer der Hobbit. Der Hobbit ist bestimmt immer dabei.
Ach, guck mal.
Guck mal.
Hättest du mal jemanden, der mal kennt.
Okay.
So, coming this winter to Epic Game Store.
Max, you're a big Magic player,
streaming, playing it.
What do you like about MTG Arena?
Ähm,
Max, bester Name, da weiß ich schonmal Bescheid.
Der Chat wieder, das war vollkommen gut passendes Englisch, dass Deutsche immer über Englisch
playen müssen.
Der hat das echt gut gemacht.
Das war toll.
Das war wirklich gut gemacht.
Chat.
Kommt jetzt?
Da, Eis-Kläuter.
Oh ne, Interaktiver Film, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das suckt sowas.
Das mag ich überhaupt nicht zu Sorte Games.
Ich fand schon cool.
schon die ganzen heavy rain nachfolger fragwürdig was was den game charakter
angeht aber in interaktiven film auch
was jetzt
von collect was geiles gezeigt heute wo heute eigentlich nicht mehr zu kot
kam auch nicht da bin ich mal gespannt drauf ich warte noch darauf dass er
ankündigt doch kam es
doch kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es
kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es kam es
denke ich dass sie dass selbst verkacken werden
das game gut wird und rauskommt wären sie es mit nach stumbled to win
zerstören
Sind die Typen einfach nur so riesengroß?
Vielleicht sind die anderen aber einfach nur so riesengroß?
Ich wusste ja, ich muss ja gestehen, ich habe eine Schwäche für kleine Mädels, ja.
Ich bin ja selbst nicht, ich bin ja mit 1,74 auch nicht der allergrößte, aber ich mag kleine Mädels.
Haha, Penobär!
Ah!
Alter, Leute!
Twitch-Chat, äh.
Hat er gerade gesagt?
Hat er gesagt, ein, ein, ein Wassercooler?
Das hat sich angehört, als hätte er gesagt, ein, ein, ein Wassercooler.
In all diesen verschiedenen Richtungen und so.
Oh mein Gott, es war, es war verrückt.
Es war so, es war ein ganz großer Herausforderung, weil ich natürlich noch nie etwas so gemacht habe.
Und Filme sind ziemlich linear.
Und ja, wir hatten all diese verschiedenen Bräuche, die runtergehen.
Und es ist ziemlich emotional für den Charakter.
Es geht in ganz viele tief und dunkle Orte.
Aber auch, weil es auf der interaktiven Seite ist, hat es diese Physikalität.
Also musste ich, obwohl ich im Umfeld war und da war, um die Nuancen eines echten Charakters zu bekommen.
Und nicht ein CGI Charakter.
Also musste ich, obwohl ich im Umfeld war und da war, um die Nuancen eines echten Charakters.
Und ja, musste ich, obwohl ich im Umfeld war und da war, um die Nuancen eines echten Charakters.
Du musstest alles machen.
Ich musste alles machen und die Physikalität, ja.
Ich musste meine eigenen Stunts machen.
Es war unglaublich hart und sie war absolut großartig.
Sie wusste einfach jede Art des Spiels.
Es war absolut magisch.
Aber ja, es war eine wirklich gute Leistung.
Super cool und das ist großartig, weil du es heute weltweit auf PlayStation downloaden kannst.
Genau, nach dem Show kommt es.
9,99 Euro, Pound, Dollar.
Es ist ein Lieber und Lieben für Jahre.
Also, das ist wirklich spannend für uns.
Und dann kannst du es auf dem Show spielen.
Und dann kannst du es auf dem Show spielen, wenn du morgen bei Gamescom bist.
Toll, okay.
Also, Jack Hawley, vielen Dank, dass du bis hierher gekommen bist.
Danke.
Erika, danke, dass du bei uns bist.
Danke, dass du bei uns bist.
Okay, wir haben noch viel zu erzählen über Gamescom diese Woche.
Denn wir fangen einfach heute ab, am Montag.
Und wenn du das beobachtest oder hier bist,
möchte ich dir sagen, dass du auch jetzt bei Gamescom gehen kannst.
Das ist auf der gamescom.global Webseite.
Und das ist eine Art, dass du Gamescom sehen kannst.
Ich habe es euch heute schon öfters gesagt.
Jetzt kommen die Feministen.
Ich werde gebannt.
Also, benehmt euch.
Tremor fragt, warum das nicht von den Deutschen moderiert wird.
Das ist doch kein Ami-Event.
Weil die Influence wollen.
Weil die international krass sein wollen.
Und mit den großen Pinkeln wollen.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Diese Gegend ist die Gamescom-Event-Arena.
Und es werden hier große E-Sport-Tournaments stattfinden.
Die ESL-Sommer-Championschaft in CSGO.
Die League of Legends wird hier sein.
Asphalt 9.
Und es gibt auch etwas, das ist so cool.
So cool.
Die Farming Simulator League hat hier ihr Tournament.
Ich musste euch ein paar Fotos von dem zeigen.
Als sie mir das gesagt haben, dachte ich mir, nein, ist das wirklich so?
Es ist unglaublich zu sehen, dass das hier in Europa passiert.
Ich liebe das.
Farming Simulator League.
Direkt auf Twitch, hoffen wir.
Mit all den Aktivitäten.
Aber das ist tatsächlich passiert.
Die Farming Simulator League.
Kompetitive Farming Simulator League.
Ich glaube, ihr wisst das.
Als ich das vorhin gesehen habe, habe ich mir gedacht, wir müssen das Game zeigen.
Ihr, wenn ihr interessiert seid, könnt ihr die Farming Simulator League sehen.
Live hier von Gamescom.
Es gibt auch eine Cosplay-Area, ein Indie-Village.
Wir haben 5.000 Quadratmeter Indie-Games.
Und es gibt auch...
Konzerte auch.
Ihr bekommt eine ganze Woche von Gamescom.
Es gibt ein Festival in Cologne dieses Wochenende.
Aber zu den Konzerten.
Sydney von IGN ist mit.
Einer der Aktivitäten, die diese Woche präsentiert werden wird.
Sydney, mit wem bist du?
Ich bin mit Par Sundström von Sabaton.
Par, ihr präsentiert.
Er erzählt uns mehr darüber.
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, hier zu sein.
Ein paar Jahre her waren wir hier.
Und...
Jetzt geht einfach eine Runde Headbang.
Bam.
Machen leise Musik.
Und wann spielst du?
Wir spielen am Wargaming-Boot.
Donnerstag um neun Uhr.
Perfekt.
Na gut, schau dir das mal an.
Und du hast auch eine Kollaboration.
Kannst du uns mehr darüber erzählen?
Ja, natürlich.
Es gibt ein neues Spiel, das aus Wargaming kommt.
Und es ist ein Hack'n'slash-RPG.
Nennt sich Pagan Online.
Und wir dachten...
Wargaming kann sich mal verkaufen.
Wir brauchten einen schwedischen Pagan.
Verkrümeln, ja.
So we kind of put our singer's skin, but looking better than he would do in real life.
Das ist voll das Tier, der Sabaton-Sänger.
You can have the skin in the game now, along with some legendary weapons.
Pega Online.
Well, I can't wait to see it.
And good luck, not that you need it.
Das hat sich fast so angehört wie Pega Online.
And now it's time to check out some more world premiere trailers.
Okay, Achtung Ubisoft, alle in Deckung.
Es werden Aussichtstürme erklommen.
Das ist jetzt die For Honor Farming Simulation.
Ach nee, es ist wahrscheinlich Anno.
Ach ja, das ist dieser...
Das ist gar keine World Premiere.
Das ist seit einer Woche raus oder so.
Der Anno DLC.
Anno Battle Royale.
Das ist keine World Premiere, das ist schon released.
Oh, DLC 2.
Hast du Anno gezockt?
Ja, das neue Anno ist richtig gut.
Anno Auto Battler, jawoll.
Jetzt kommen hier die Ideen zum Geldmachen im Chat.
Jetzt haben sie ATX angeschaltet, genau.
Gut, dass man nichts zu den Inhalten sieht, sondern einfach den Namen vom DLC.
Aber einen schönen Soundtrack haben sie.
Free Game Update.
Day and Night Cycle Free Game Update.
Dass man das überhaupt erwähnen muss.
Also manche Sachen in der heutigen Gaming Welt wirken irgendwie recht...
Grotesk.
Day and Night Cycle Free Update.
Haben MMOs vor 20 Jahren schon gemacht.
Free Update, Back gefixt.
Das mehr Klischee behaftete Pirate Lead hätten sie auch nicht auswählen können.
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie Alestorm.
Das hört sich übrigens an wie Alestorm.
Ich weiss nicht.
Das wäre die Idee zu nehmen, die ich das letzte Mal hatte.
Nee, jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber ich finde der Sänger am Anfang ist ein bisschen zu einem gehört.
Ho Ho Ho!
Port Royal 4...
Kennt jemand Port Royal 1, 2 oder 3?
Hey gamescom 2019, es sind Tobi und Julian von The Iron Harvest Team.
Ich bin Tobi und Julien aus dem Team von Iron Harvest und wir sind stolz auf euren klassischen Real-Time-Strategie-Spiel Iron Harvest 1920+.
In Iron Harvest wurden riesige Diesel-Punk-Masks geschaffen, um die Leute zu unterstützen, aber stattdessen Träume, Chaos und Leidenschaft zu verursachen.
Und jetzt ist es eure Zeit, wieder zu kämpfen und mehr über die drei Faktionen in unserer erstaunlichen Single-Player-Kampagne zu lernen.
Oder challenge eure Freunde und intense Multiplayer-Wedges in diesem Squad-based Combat RTS,
die auf PlayStation 4, Xbox One und PC kommen.
Und wenn wir PC sagen, sagen wir, dass es auf Steam ist und dass es in anderen Storien oder am Launch ist.
Und wenn ihr in Cologne seid, gebt uns euren High-Five, kommt in Hall 9 und seht uns in der Deep-Server-Area.
Ich fühle mich so bedrängt durch die Kamera.
Also jetzt genießt euren neuen Trailer und wir sehen uns auf der Battlefield.
Wir waren alle beschäftigt mit unseren eigenen kleinen Leben.
Wir wussten nicht, was im Geheimnis war.
Wir haben nicht gesehen, wie die Welt kommt.
Sie sagten, dass der Krieg in Monaten gewonnen werden würde.
Eine Erleuchtung, die Freude und Ehre versprochen hat.
Am Ende wären es fünf Jahre.
Jahre von Schmerz und Schmerz, wie die Welt es noch nie gesehen hat.
Der große Krieg, der alle Kriege beenden sollte, ist vorbei.
Während im Geheimnis der See für den nächsten Krieg gesungen wird.
Sie dürfen solche Videos nicht machen.
Die ganzen Verschwörungstheorien dürfen nicht inspired werden.
Die ganzen Verschwörungstheorien gehen da wahrscheinlich voll drauf ab.
Okay, das war jetzt schlecht animiert.
Battlefield Generals, Battlefield 1 Generals.
Aber Strategiespiele gibt es viel zu wenig.
Es gibt viel zu wenig RTS-Games.
Mir hat sich viel erkannt, aber auf jeden Fall, umso mehr Strategiespiele, umso besser.
Gibt es viel zu wenige.
Das bedeutet, dass wir mehr 2019 Gamescom-Winner haben.
Wir wissen.
Die Gamescom-Winnerin kommt zurück.
Mein Gott, wie können Leute...
Warum gibt es Gamescom Awards?
Die Gamescom fängt morgen an und die Spiele sind alle noch nicht raus.
Tom Cog?
Oh Gott, ich darf es nicht aussprechen.
Best Family Game, Concrete Genie von Sony.
Best Role Playing Game, Wasteland 3 von Koch Media.
Und Best PC Game ist Ghost Recon Breakpoint von Ubisoft.
Das sind die besten Games in deinem Gute Nacht...
Hype, Hype ist real.
As Jeff said, IGN will be all your Gamescom 2019 needs.
Gamescom is the biggest gaming event on Earth.
With over 350,000 fans attending from all over the world.
Aber nicht, das ist wichtig.
But if you're not one of them, don't worry, because IGN has you covered.
Starting Tuesday, IGN is bringing you a week of live coverage from Hall 7.
Streaming exclusive demos, tons of brand new gameplay, developer interviews and sights and sounds from the show floor.
This is the heart of gaming and it all starts Tuesday on IGN Gamescom Now.
That about does it for me tonight, but like that wonderful video just said, we will be live on IGN all along.
Thank you so much, Jeff, for having me.
And back to you.
Thanks, Sid.
Great to have you with us.
Congratulations to all the winners.
There are more awards coming from the fans on IGN this weekend.
Alright, now let's turn to the world of Call of Duty Modern Warfare.
Oh, der Hype ist nicht real.
Der Hype ist nicht real.
Der Hype ist definitiv nicht real im Publikum.
Alright, so Call of Duty Modern Warfare.
You're on brand and this is...
Call of Duty Modern Warfare, but it's a reimagining.
Is this the Infinity Ward, David Wunderhaar?
Exactly, that is the exact term we use at Infinity Ward, is that it is a reimagining of the Modern Warfare franchise.
So it's still Modern Warfare through and through, complete with some familiar characters as well,
but the overall narrative and the single player storyline are completely new and fresh
and updated to be relevant and fit in the present day.
Okay, you guys had the multiplayer reveal a couple of weeks ago, lots of news around that.
Tell us, what's the focus?
What's the focus of MP for MW this year?
So first of all, we were just blown away by the reaction from the fans and the players.
Jedes Jahr wird reinvented and reimagined und verbessert und bestes Call of Duty ever.
So we've got all sorts of shapes and sizes of experiences.
We've got our smaller, tighter, faster 2v2 maps.
We've got our more traditional 6v6 maps.
And we've also got experiences on our larger scale maps that are going to support upwards of 100 players.
Oh wow, okay, and you're also doing crossplay as well, right?
Yes, we are indeed.
So we've actually had a lot of questions from the community about how crossplay works.
In a nutshell, you'll be able to play console to console and console to PC.
So if you're partying up on console and you have a friend on PC that you want to play with,
you guys can't play together.
Oh wow, okay, so cross everything.
It's all going to work.
Absolutely.
You also had a fun mode that I got to play back in May at the studio, 2v2 gunfight,
which is like, tell us a bit about it, but it's like a ton of fun.
It is fast-paced.
It is a ton of fun.
It's fast, it's frenetic.
I actually heard you did pretty well over there.
We had a fun time, me and Andy McNamara from Game Informer took down some other heroes.
I don't think we compete against some of these, Courage or those guys.
Those guys are real slayers though, so I think you held your own.
Yeah, it was a fun mode and I understand that you guys are going to be,
we know you're doing a beta in September.
Yes, we are.
I hear there might be something before that.
Absolutely.
So first of all, if you're here and happen to be at the show,
you will be able to play Modern Warfare.
It's on the show floor.
Check it out at the PlayStation.
Okay.
And so in preparation for our beta,
where we get to be able to collect a lot of feedback from the fans,
as well as test crossplay,
we're doing an early test and we've partnered with PlayStation
to have an open 2v2 Alpha that's going to start this Friday, August 23rd.
Okay, this Friday, August 23rd, and that's worldwide on PlayStation 4?
Yes, it is.
Okay, we will check it out.
Call of Duty Modern Warfare Alpha, I understand we got a little sneak peek.
Absolutely, and brought a trailer along with me so that people can see what's coming up.
Alright, see all the maps from the Alpha.
Thanks so much, Dino.
Thank you very much, Joe.
Let's check it out.
Call of Duty Modern Warfare.
Man kann so oder so mal aufs Keyboard, auf Konsole spielen, glaube ich nicht.
Dann wird man aber nicht mit Konsole gematcht.
Vorbestellt?
Nö.
Ich hab beim Keyshop einen Beta-Key gekauft.
Okay, das haben wir jetzt.
Aber dieser 2-in-2-Modus, ich weiß nicht, ob das so der, der...
Das sah aus wie Killbox aus COD 4.
Dieser 2-in-2-Modus, der so der Hype wird, weiß ich nicht.
Aber erks, das könnten wir mal wieder spielen.
Ein bisschen.
2-in-2-Modus, wenn es taugt.
Machen wir.
Nächstes Wochenende.
Wird COD gespielt.
Das hat ihn nicht am Ende von halb so weit um die Welt bestanden, um hier bei Gamescom mit uns zu sein.
Ich bin so stolz, dass er hier ist.
Ihr könnt ja wissen, worüber ich rede, aber schaut euch das mal an.
Das hat er doch, Death Stranding.
Das habt ihr doch schon meilenweit gekommen sehen.
Um zu reisen, zur tonights Awards Ceremony, um die Awards abzuhalten.
Das Gebet, bitte genießt.
Nur die Chance.
Only Hideo Kojima.
Industry Icon.
Fantastic.
Such an honor to work with you.
You're such a genius.
He is one of those principled, loyal and...
Games out of this world.
I did love you all from my heart.
I'd do anything for this guy, for real.
Oh yeah.
Games come.
Strand on your feet.
He's here.
The one and only.
Hideo Kojima.
Mr. Kojima.
It is such an honor to have you with us.
I know how hard you've been working to finish up the...
Who is that?
Is that the guy from Solitude?
I returned after five years to visit Games come again.
It's great to have you back.
And everyone's going crazy.
Look at the selfies happening here.
It's so nice to see you live.
Death Stranding.
I dare to emphasize it.
I think the emphasis of Japanese in English Murder is really awesome.
Death Stranding.
Seriously.
I think it sounds nice.
Death Stranding is in the final really crunch time of development stage.
And I shouldn't actually be here.
But I really wanted to meet you all.
So I came to Germany.
Mr. Kojima.
Always here for his fans and for us.
Which is so amazing.
So Mr. Kojima.
We know that you're, as you said, just about finishing up the game.
And everyone's very curious.
The whole world is curious what you can tell us about this game.
And what you want to share tonight with all of us.
So what can you tell us about what you want to introduce?
Death Stranding is a completely new open world game.
I'm making a new one.
The second beta is public.
Death Stranding is a total new game.
It's an open world game.
And it's very, very new.
And I hope that everyone will like it.
So since it was quite popular to show a new character at Comic Con, today I would like
to introduce more new characters today.
Let's look at the first one.
Okay, let's take a look at the first character for Mr. Kojima.
Mr. Kojima.
Oh, Premiere.
All is world premiere.
Man sieht ein Charakter-Model.
World Premiere.
Zweites Charakter-Model.
Alles klar.
Der Typ erinnert mich an Daryl von The Walking Dead.
Na gut, das ist er ja auch.
Das war die Vorstellungsszene von Mama,
gespielt von Miss Margaret Qualley.
Death Stranding.
Es gibt viele Charaktere, die in Death Stranding erscheinen.
Und jeder unique Charakter hat eine Sub-Story,
abgesehen von der Hauptstory.
Alles klar.
Ich warte ja noch drauf, dass Death Stranding rauskommt
nach diesem Ultra-Hype der letzten drei Jahre
und das Game übel sagt.
Das wäre echt...
Dann würde das Inhalte explodieren.
Aber ich glaube es nicht.
Ich glaube es nicht, dass es sagt.
Ja, das Game ist ewig in der Entwicklung schon.
Das Spiel hängt von der Zeit her raus.
Es ist mir wohl schon ein bisschen älter als mehr als ein Jahr.
Es ist mir ein bisschen übel.
Was ist das?
Das ist dein Film?
Ja, ich habe das Film.
Ich habe das Film.
listsin.de
Oh, das ist doch ein Film.
Sagen wir mal, dass du ja auch seine mountain heroin gespielt hast.
Ich hätte das natürlich nie gesehen.
Aber es ist eine gute Idee.
Bestehend alles um dich.
If you do not understand me, I love you, Anne.
Ich bin ein Comedian.
So, wir folgen den jeweiligen Weg vor uns.
Mit taxis und so was.
Ja.
Okay.
Ja, dann jornal.
Na gut.
Okay, dann lass ich dich an.
Connect yourself to a baby, granting you the ability to sense beauties.
These pods were designed to simulate the conditions inside a still mother's womb.
Babies need to believe their in one at all times to function properly.
However, we can only maintain this deception for so long,
which is why we must periodically update the environmental data
by synchronizing it with the still mother via the chiral network.
Das ist nur für 900 IQ-Leute.
The update is in progress.
Right now the pod is synchronizing with the still mother in capital North City
and reconfiguring its settings based on the latest data.
Returning your baby to the womb in this manner will temporarily reduce its stress levels.
That being where it technically belongs, of course.
The kid looks happy.
Thank yous.
Das ist der Windows Update Balken daneben.
Die
Okay, das war jetzt ziemlich nichts sagen.
Das war eine Vorstellung von Deadman, gespielt von Guillermo del Toro, und auch eine Vorstellung von Bibi.
Jetzt sahst du das Video, das erklärt, worum Bibi ging, und du sahst, dass Sam immer dieses Baby in seinem Pod hatte.
Und du fragtest dich, worum es ging, und das gibt eine großartige Erklärung davon.
Bibi und Sam sind verbunden, und so sieht man den BT.
Aber Sam kann nicht zurück in diese Welt. Das ist eine sehr traurige Vorstellung.
Das ist eine sehr traurige Vorstellung, die Sam mit Bibi hat, weil Bibi mit dem Todes-Welt verbunden ist.
Und das ermöglicht, dass Bibi mit Sam verbunden ist, damit Sam die BTs sehen kann.
Und jetzt ist alles klar.
Ja, alles klar.
Also, du wirst diese Reise mit dem Baby zusammen haben, und du wirst eine Verbindung haben, und mehr Verbindung, und das wird Teil der Spielstunde sein.
Wow, das ist ziemlich großartig, das zu sehen.
Ja, super großartig, ich habe nichts verstanden, aber voll krass großartig.
Das ist großartig.
Herr Kojima, ich denke, dass alle hier gespannt sind, Charaktere zu sehen, die sich in der Welt befinden.
Ja, super großartig, ich habe nichts verstanden, aber voll krass großartig.
Ich habe keine Klartheron im Microsoft-Board.
Würden Sie etwas Aufplus sehen von Death Stranding?
Es ist nicht Zeit dafür, oder?
Ich dachte, ich würde es im TGS sehen.
Ich denke, ich werde es im Tokyo Game Show sehen.
Aber...
Jeff sagt so viel, und es ist so heiß.
Ich werde es nur ein wenig zeigen.
Jeff, da es Jeffs Show ist und alle so gespannt sind,
möchte ich Ihnen nur ein wenig zeigen.
Es wird auch ein Hinweis sein.
Ich werde es nur ein wenig zeigen,
aber es wird auch eine erstaunliche Star zeigen.
Schauen wir es gemeinsam an.
Das ist nicht das erste Gameplay, das haben wir schon gesehen.
Also ob wir das jetzt schon gesehen haben, weiß ich nicht,
aber es gab schon Gameplay-Trailer.
Da, wo er Leitern gebaut hat,
das war jetzt Hypersleep.
Der hat einfach mal zwei Sekunden geschlafen.
Er ist fit.
Das kennen wir doch, oder?
Kennen wir das nicht schon mit der Leiter?
Pinkelt er?
Er pinkelt.
Fuck.
Warum?
Was soll jetzt verarschen aus?
Warum die Leute klatschen dann erstmal?
Weil er hat überhaupt nichts gepinkelt.
Weil er auf dem Pilz gepinkelt hat.
Walking Simulator.
Wie er atmet.
Das ist angeblich Ingame.
Sieht auch, sieht auch.
Von den Controls, sieht auch Ingame aus.
Das ist mit der Leiter, sag ich doch.
Das haben wir doch schon mal gesehen mit der Leiter.
Oder ist es einfach jetzt die längere Version von dem,
was wir schon mal gesehen haben.
How you doing, Sam?
Good job, man.
Kennt man den?
Good job.
Join the UCA.
Äh, snow.de?
You can't help me do that yet.
Ich hoffe mal, das war nicht unseres.
Werde ich morgen sehen, wenn ich auf die Arbeit fahre.
Nee, nee, das sind wir nicht.
Nee, das sagt mir nichts.
Was, was genau?
Wie ist das? Sollen wir den kennen?
Kennt man den, den Schauspieler?
Ach, das ist der Host.
Ernsthaft?
Sieht nämlich wirklich ähnlich.
Das ist Jeff from Overwatch, genau.
Eindeutig.
Ist das echt der Moderator?
Find ich nicht, ist überhaupt nicht ähnlich.
Wow.
But why?
Das Spiel wird jetzt ja wie bei Yoshi's Island.
Wenn Mario vom Sattel fällt.
Erst mal schön 180 Grad in der Luft drehen.
Also, ich weiß ja nicht.
So steil, dass man das leidet, ist das eher nicht, oder?
Klapper, klapper.
Okay, das ist er doch.
Ich finde, es wird überhaupt nicht ähnlich gesehen.
Ähm, Jeff hat uns ein Cameo gegeben.
Die Stimme ist anders, aber wir haben Jeff gefragt,
in unserem Spiel als Cameo zu sein.
Danke, es war eine Ehre, in dem Spiel zu sein.
Matthew Mercer spielt die Stimme des Charakters,
den ich in dem Spiel spiele.
Und ich weiß, dass es viele Cameos gibt,
auch von Freunden von dir.
Bekri.
Erzähl mir ein bisschen über das Spiel,
das wir dort gesehen haben.
Ich weiß, es ist ein neuer Stil des Spiels.
Und du hast über das Strand-Genre gesprochen.
Und ich denke, es ist sehr wichtig,
dass die Leute sehen, dass es viele Hinweise gibt
über die Art des Spiels, das du spielen wirst.
Jetzt ist genug der Stranding.
Ich kann nicht so viel sagen,
aber du spielst als Sam,
und du musst die verbreiteten Städte und Menschen
von Ost nach West verbinden.
Und du musst dich mit ihnen verbinden.
Und es gibt Terroristen, die ihn in die Mitte bringen.
Und es gibt auch Obstakel,
wie Terroristen oder Terroristen,
um das zu vermeiden.
Terroristen, oh ja.
Und in diesen Obstakeln
gibt es Leute wie Jeff,
die sich alleine befinden.
Und auf dem Weg findest du Leute,
die alleine leben,
wie du Jeff gesehen hast.
Wir nennen sie Prepper.
Und sie leben versteckt.
Das hat nichts mit der Hauptgeschichte zu tun.
Es gibt eigentlich eine Art Verbleibung,
also müssen sich einige Prepper
nicht wirklich mit der Hauptgeschichte beschäftigen.
Ich gehe auch mal stark davon aus,
dass es Absicht ist,
dass wir das nicht checken.
Weil ich meine,
wenn er jetzt alles erklären würde,
warum müsste man das noch spielen?
Und wenn du mit ihnen verbunden bist,
hast du vielleicht einige gute Dinge,
die sie dir bieten.
Und das ist natürlich so,
dass du dich in die Hände greifst.
Wenn du dich mit ihnen verbunden bist,
dann kannst du das auch nicht.
Du siehst mit ihnen alle zusammen.
Und das ist das,
was man dann auch gut auf der Welt
machen kann.
Also,
ich kann es nicht so viel zeigen,
aber wenn du mit Preppern
in der Geschichte so verbunden bist,
wirst du bemerkt,
dass du mit den Leuten weltweit verbunden bist.
Und ich denke,
es ist auch so,
dass wenn ein Video von Deltro
aufgespult wird,
dann wird VVV
selbstverdienlich.
Also,
du weißt ja auch,
wie man auch
Mit Twitch Prime.
Das Video von vorhin wurde mit dem Motion-Sensor-Controller von PS4 veröffentlicht.
Oh nein, oder? Oh nein!
Aber wenn du zu langsam schiebst, dann schiebst du zu schnell.
Ich will keine Babys... Also ich bin froh, dass ich da bisher in echt drum herum gekommen bin, ja?
Babys wiegen zu müssen. Ich möchte Babys nicht mit meinem PS4-Controller wiegen müssen.
Basteo und Twitch Prime, dankeschön!
Fock!
Na, na, na!
Subscriber!
Sam wird wechseln, sodass du niemals sehen wirst, was er macht.
Und wenn man in der Stadt ist, dann schiebt man Sam.
Und es gibt auch die Möglichkeit, sich so zu verlassen, dass man sich nicht verlassen kann.
Wenn Leute vor dir sind.
Also keine Sorge, Norman-Fans, du musst dich nicht überlegen.
Obwohl ich gehört habe... Ist es wahr, dass das auch eine Waffe sein kann?
Ja, es ist eine Waffe.
Und es ist auch eine Waffe, die euch verbindet.
Ja.
Also, äh, ja, es könnte als Waffe verwendet werden, aber es könnte auch...
Kie, Kie, Kie.
Es wird eine Art von Kie sein, und ihr werdet es später herausfinden.
Wenn man Oshikko macht, dann kommen da die Zwiebeln raus, aber wenn alle Oshikko machen, dann passiert etwas Gutes.
Ihr habt die Zwiebeln gesehen, also wenn alle das an dem gleichen Ort machen, dann wird es...
Niklas V, genau so muss es sein!
...etwas Gutes später.
Na, das ist nicht das Spiel.
Ja, komm Leute, ist gut jetzt. Genug Death Stranding.
Gibt eh nichts Neues, Gescheites, was uns irgendwie weiterbringt, ja?
Wow.
Well, I gotta say, it's so amazing...
Oh, amazing. Counter.
...a little insight into your mind between those clips and the gameplay.
I think everyone's trying to piece together how this all fits together.
But it's amazing stuff.
Next, please.
Wobei, es gibt kein Next mehr, das ist fertig jetzt um 22 Uhr.
You wouldn't even tell me what we were doing.
But you're like, come down to San Diego.
Sit here, they put dots on my face, they did the full scan, I was there the same day that
Niklas von Reffen did his scan as well.
It was like, I think September, October, two years ago.
And I didn't know what you were gonna do with it.
You're like, trust me, Jeff.
I'm like, okay, sure.
And then I find out, I'm Ludens fan, right?
Ludens fan.
Ähm, Karren toko itte, Karren iroiro ko nakayoku naruto ii mono kureta.
So, if you find him in the game, and if you go into him and, um,
make the connection with him, he might give you something good.
Jeff is actually kind of apparent, and you could find him easily.
So, when the game comes out, just look for Jeff.
Well, I'm honored to have a little role with a cameo.
There'll be some other cameos, I'm sure, as well in this game?
Yes, I can't really say who yet, but there are many people in cameos.
Mr. Kojima, äh, thank you so much for coming all this way to share a little bit more of Death Stranding with us.
What do you guys think? Pretty insane, right?
Hideo Kojima, there's so much there, and we don't have to wait long,
because you guys are on track for the game to come out this November, right?
Excellent. All right, Mr. Kojima, thank you so much.
Yes, that's right, and Mr. Kojima will also be doing a signing session here at Gamescom, right?
And that'll be, uh...
Ah, one more thing, sorry.
Thanks.
At the Sony booth, you'll see more about, like, the briefing,
the reason why Sam has to do this, the briefing scenes,
you'll see at the Sony booth from tomorrow, so if you have time, just stop by.
And if you see that, you'll understand...
Der geht damit, der geht weg.
Easy.
Easy clap.
Hideo Kojima, thank you so much, my friend. It's always such a pleasure.
Aki, thank you so much.
All right, guys, well, that's gonna do it for our first-ever Gamescom opening night live.
Jawoll, wir haben's geschafft, Leute.
Did you guys have fun? Should we do this every year?
All right, well, I gotta say, it's been a ton of fun putting this together.
It's been great to be here in Europe. I wanna thank all the developers.
I wanna thank Game and Cole Messi for giving us the opportunity to do this.
I wanna thank a lot of my team that came all the way over from Los Angeles to produce this with me.
We will see you guys, of course, this December.
The Game Awards will be back for our fifth anniversary live in Los Angeles.
Much more information coming soon.
We've got some pretty cool stuff to show you guys and some big new announcements.
So stay tuned for that.
But enjoy Gamescom, guys. Thank you so much. I'm Jeff Keighley.
Have a great Gamescom and we'll see you in December at the Game Awards.
Good night.
Also, Leute, nice, dass ihr dabei wart.
Es waren richtig viele zwischenzeitlich.
Ich glaube, peak hatten wir irgendwie 270 oder so was Zuschauer.
Das war ordentlich.
Ich habe das nirgendwo angekündigt, weder auf YouTube noch auf Twitch.
Da hätten wir wahrscheinlich die 300 Logger geschafft.
Eventuell 400.
Aber so ist mir das viel lieber.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Es war leider nicht so viel Gutes dabei.
Hielt sich auf jeden Fall in Grenzen.
Und jetzt gehe ich pennen.
Macht's gut. Bis morgen.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. See you.
Ach so, meine Outromusik.